Jetzt müsste es besser gehen.
Ja.
Jetzt. Nice.
Jetzt haben wir ordentliche Bitrate.
Jetzt sieht es auch gescheit aus.
Es ist deutlich schärfer.
Ja, ja, ja. Gleich viel, viel besser.
Jetzt ist mal richtig scharf alles.
Progress sharp ist es.
Ich schreibe mal Chat F5.
So, jetzt.
Jetzt ist viel besser.
Ich sehe es hier nämlich gerade in meiner Vorschau.
Jetzt ist auch, wenn ich move, alles scharf und es blurt nicht ineinander.
Ja.
Zu Darug PVE müsst ihr übrigens nicht viel wissen.
Darug PVE ist, wir laufen einem hinterher, zergen alle Mobs kaputt und bekommen am Ende eine Quest Reward.
Fertig.
Ja, viel besser sieht das jetzt aus.
Es wäre sehr nice,
wenn der Raid mal
movt.
Woven wir?
Ich glaube, wir moven.
Ja, nice.
Ja, wie gesagt, zu Dark PVE
muss man nicht allzu viel wissen, außer alle
Mobs wegzuergen, easy Quest abholen am Ende.
Am Ende von dem Dungeon krieg...
What the fuck?
Warum ist der...
Okay.
Whatever.
Kein Plassen.
Hier waren wir übrigens gerade eben.
Schon.
Weiß nicht, warum wir da wieder hingehen.
Wie siehst du, wenn du heilen musst?
Hier.
Ich bin zuständig für alle in dieser Gruppe.
Gruppen in Dark sind, by the way, acht Leute.
Ja.
Ach ja, genau.
Ich...
Ich hab zu viel Zeug im Kopf, was ich sagen will.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo meine Gruppe ist, ganz ehrlich.
Es ist ein bisschen der Job der Leute, zu gucken, wo der Raid-Leader langläuft.
Wow, massive High-IQ-Jump.
Also hier, das sind die Lebensbalken von denen.
Ich bin nur für 8 Leute zuständig.
Ich kann alle anderen heilen, da muss ich es aber anklicken.
Es gibt keinen, also es gibt nicht, falls ihr das von World of Warcraft vielleicht drauf anspielt,
es gibt keinen Raid-Frame.
Es gibt
nur ein Group-Window.
Ich habe echt keinen Plan, wo die Leute sind.
Ich bleibe einfach beim...
Ich bleibe einfach beim Raid-Leader
und
zerge mit durch.
Ganz ehrlich, was willst du machen?
Und spamm ein bisschen Group-Heal.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was so schwer ist, da hinterher zu laufen.
Es gibt übrigens ein gutes Kommando für alle, die ein bisschen epileptische Anfälle kriegen bei Dark, wenn zu viele Leute auf dem Bildschirm sind.
Es gibt ein Kommando slash Effekt.
Oder Effekts ist es, glaube ich.
Da kann man einstellen, ob man nur Group-Zauber, alle Zauber und was man sehen will.
Weil ganz im Ernst, obviously, was hier gerade passiert, oder?
Ich geh mal kurz in den Pulk rein.
Ist klar, oder?
Chat.
Logisch.
Ich glaube, viel klarer, was gerade passiert,
gerade hier in der Ego-Perspektive, könnte es nicht sein.
Übrigens, der Typ mit diesem roten Schimmer ist der Raid-Leader.
Dem müssen wir hinterher.
Und alle, die das nicht machen und verrecken,
sind halt am Arsch der Welt und können nicht wiederbelebt werden.
Moment, ich mach mal ein bisschen entspannendere Musik gerade.
Dings hier. Machen wir hier sowas hier.
Ah ja. Fantasy
Fantasy Background Music.
Excellent.
Das ist deutlich entspannender.
Ich hoffe, ich kann
meine Leute noch wiederbeleben.
Aber ich hab keinen Plan, wo die sind.
Ich mein, sie sind zumindest anklickbar. Das heißt, sie sind schon mal in der Nähe.
Vielleicht hier? Ah, irgendwo
hier in der Mitte sind sie. Okay.
Ich kann...
Ich sehe sie schon mal.
Man sieht sie ja auch auf der Map.
Okay, der erste lebt wieder.
Nice.
Und wo ist Plo?
Ne, Plo kann ich noch nicht mal anklicken.
Aber dann keine Ahnung, wo er ist.
Ich hoffe nur, meine Leute tanken alle Mobs,
da ich am Ende die Quest kriege.
weil ansonsten hat sich das nicht gelohnt.
Und es ist jetzt nicht so,
als würde Trollheim durchzergen.
Als wäre das die Krönung des Spielspaßes.
Sagen wir mal so.
Ja.
Also es gibt nur ein Group-Window.
Du siehst im Endeffekt.
Was ist die Quest?
Die Quest ist, äh, Moment.
Wir sollen diese Viecher hier killen.
Remadun
den laert.
Aha, alles klar.
Apolo geht nesuir.
Overs de
Kalejo, war es auch immer
das für einen Namen, sind man
Alchemist Forzberg, das ist der
beste, der hat wenigstens mal
einen gescheiten Namen, der Alchemist Forzberg
ähm, und
Magister Kurgol
Forzberg, ah ja
weißt du, ich hab mir den Wappennamen nicht ausgedacht
äh,
Shade of Adimedus
und The Rift soll man killen
Ah, der Rift, da kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Das ist ein Portal, wo Mobs rauskommen.
Das muss man irgendwie 5 Minuten durchhalten oder so.
Ja.
Genau, und das müssen wir alles
machen und am Ende kriegen wir
dann ein Level als
XP. Also Level Cap ist 50
in Dark. Also im Prinzip ist
alles ab 45 Easy Mode.
Alles ab 45, da gehst du mal auf
irgendeinen Raid, machst mal irgendwas mit und gut ist.
Und dann bist du, bist du ratzfatz
50. Und ich mach danach ja auch noch die Epic
für die Epic Rüstung.
Und da bin ich 2x50.
Also die Quest ist hier durchlaufen, ein paar Bosse killen.
Und man kriegt den Encounter, wenn man halt mindestens ein Damage gemacht hat.
Also wenn eine aus der Gruppe mindestens ein Damage gemacht hat oder irgendwas drauf gecastet hat, was als Spell zählt im Endeffekt.
Also eigentlich kann man das nicht verkacken.
zumal ich gelesen habe in den patch notes die haben auch irgendwas eingeführt dass man
glaube ich encounter bekommt wenn man nur in einem umkreis von 1500 einheiten oder so ist
will ich mir ein habe ich in den patch notes habe ich den patch notes gesehen was macht ihr
wir machen sinnlosen pvp raid damit ich den level kriege und ein quest reward ich bin mir
sicher war dass ich hier nehme vielleicht erst mal das vielleicht erst mal das mit
herium was 222 endo punkte ausdauer punkte bringt
mal kurz sagen aber welchem anbieter würde es am erst eine die e domain
kaufen ja nicht mal cloudflare leider weil cloudflare keine de domains hat
Okay, jetzt habe ich dir gesagt, wo ich sie nicht kaufen würde
Das bringt dir wahrscheinlich nichts, oder?
Ich habe noch ein paar Domains
Bei Pork Bun
Und eine DE-Domain habe ich tatsächlich noch
Bei Nitrado, aber da würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
Das nur für Domains
Bei Pork Bun
Habe ich ein paar Domains
Die haben auch DE-Domains, ansonsten auch alles
Muss mal kurz eine Runde
Group-Heal casten.
Au.
Nicht verrecken, Leute.
Genau, das hier unten ist
mein, quasi mein
Mini-Raid-Frame, mein Gruppenfenster.
Das sind die Leute aus meiner Gruppe.
Ach, das ist der Rift-Encounter.
Genau, easy.
Im Prinzip müssen wir einfach nur alles weg.
By the way, Epilepsy-Warnung.
Daok aus Ego-Perspektive ist wild, wie man so schön sagt heute.
Also, ich mein...
Wer da nicht durchblickt, was gerade los ist, weiß nicht.
also ich habe bei borg bahn ja
wir haben auch nur die dns api für letzten clip zertifikat bei denen habe ich ein paar
domains
sag uns mal wenn da ein mob ist ich erkenne nichts ich dachte da hier hier ist ein mob hier hier hier
hier oh da hinter uns der irgendwie keiner den keiner killt da guck hier da da da war
einer hast du gesehen hier da ist noch einer da sind da sind zwei mobs hier da guck hier
hier die hässlichen viecher die gehen sind sterben weil gefühlt ich guck mal kurz ich
guck mal wie viele leute in der raid group drin sind ich muss danach unbedingt cube eins und die
leisten beim heil also ich muss den heiler ordentlich specken und die leisten ordentlich
machen ich habe die ganzen spells nicht auf buttons wo ich wo ich gewohnt bin ich habe
die einfach random drauf gezogen während dem level gestern aber bg count bg count wir haben
Oh fuck, das ging zu schnell.
What the hell?
100, 153. Moment, was?
Habe ich das gerade richtig gesehen?
Leute sind hier. Ach du
Scheiße, man.
154 Leute sind das gerade.
Kein Wunder, dass die Mobs platzen.
Guck mal.
Gegner, tot.
normalerweise ist es hier dann schnell
ausgelegt für 8 bis 16 leute und mit
154 ja es gibt übrigens in dem spiel
das wie gesagt das ist old school
es gibt keine ins also stimmt so nicht
ganz es gibt kaum instanzen also der
ganze graf das ganze spiel ist es ist
Open World.
Ohne Instanzen.
Oh, fuck.
Au, au, au, au, au, au, au, au.
Leute, Leute. Ah.
Siehst du mal, ich klicke noch leist.
Mal wieder letzte Kack-Noob.
Ich habe alles meine Sachen
noch nicht gemappt.
By the way, warum sind wir eigentlich gerade verreckt?
Ich weiß nicht.
Egal ich warte einfach mal bis der Charme mich retzt
Übrigens das hier ist ein Dungeon der ist mit 16 Leuten einfacher teilweise als mit 150 weil keiner richtig guckt mit 150
Starting Fresh Level Group 1 bis 10 da will ich mitmachen
Aber ich kann auch nicht. Shit wir brauchen noch wir brauchen noch ein okay, den typ muss ich an
Moment.
Wie heißt der Dude?
Alter!
Ich bin gerade zu doof zu whispern.
Das ist weh.
Warte mal, was war das?
Was war das? Cent?
Wie heißt der Dude?
Ach ja.
Okay, ich hab ne Levelgruppe
für nen Skald am Start. Nice.
Ach, wir sind fertig!
Wir haben ne Levelgruppe am Start.
Nice.
Guck mal, Quest abgeben. Das war doch mal smooth hier.
PvE-Raid,
Levelgruppe für nen Skald am Start.
Ähm.
Da muss ich mir nachher mal angucken, was ich hier für einen Heiler am besten nehme als Quest-Reward.
Ich logge um.
GG.
Thanks for Grip.
Die machen jetzt SH, da mach ich nicht mit.
Ich logge jetzt erstmal.
Also.
So.
Jetzt erstmal ein bisschen geordnet.
Und langsam.
Das war mir gerade für mein Boomer-Hirn zu viel.
Gruppe
organisieren für Level 1 Chars.
Mit dem
Heiler heilen. Gucken, dass
ich dabei bleibe. Plus mit euch reden. Das war mir
zu viel hier. Skalde an Start.
Bester, bester Char.
So, wir fangen jetzt neuen Char an.
Bei Level 1 habe ich in Season 1 und Season 2
schon gespielt. Der Skalde ist
glaube ich knapp vor RR9.
Ich glaube 8 L7 oder so.
Bringt aber eh nichts, während man levelt.
Oh.
Achso, da fehlen ja die Leute noch.
Aber guck mal, wir haben schon mal
einen Heiler für die Gruppe.
Ähm.
Ein Shami.
Was?
Was so was?
Wollen die mich verarschen?
Alter.
Die wollen nicht leveln.
Was ist das, Mann?
Dann mach ich jetzt mit dem Heiler
mach ich mit dem Heiler doch halt hier mit
noch einen anderen Raid
schnell mit. Das ist geil.
Schreibt in Chat, suche Leute für
Level 1 Group.
Ich schreib, ich komm nach dem Raid.
So, logge um und er sagt
ach, ich geh doch wieder mit dem anderen Charme.
What the fuck?
Okay, wo gehen die hin?
Okay.
Moment, jetzt muss ich mich mal kurz beeilen.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was die machen,
aber ich muss sie erstmal rausporten.
Ne, ne, ne, Moment, Moment.
Wir machen mal kurz...
Was nehme ich denn hier als...
Healer looking for group.
moin patrick hat man das endung müssen nämlich glaube ich das glaube ich am sinnigsten hier na
erst mal sehr voll braucht keine power power power 15 power rack ist für heiler glaub auch
ganz gut wenn man ein bisschen pv macht aber ich nehme erst mal ganz ehrlich nehmen das endo plus
zwei.
Ups.
Okay.
Und jetzt porten wir mal schnell raus.
Endo plus zwei.
Excellent.
Jetzt sind wir Level 49.
Jetzt porte ich rüber
zu dem anderen Raid. Den machen wir
schnell noch. Dann bin ich Level
50.
Und dann machen wir die Epic.
Ja. Wir machen
was anderes als so rum zu rennen. Wir rennen jetzt gleich rum.
Wir rennen jetzt zum Porter.
Oh, fuck. Wo bin ich denn
gebeindet?
Irgendwo am Arsch der Welt,
glaube ich.
Ich muss mich beeilen.
Die sind schon unterwegs.
Egal. Ach, hier bin ich.
Für die Quest. Na gut.
Mein Problem ist, ich habe auch
kein Endo-Pot oder sonst was.
Ich habe gestern erst frisch angefangen zu leveln.
Okay.
Ich hoffe, wir kommen noch rechtzeitig.
Bis es losgeht.
So.
Ja, normalerweise würde ich Power nehmen,
aber ich habe jetzt erstmal Endu genommen,
weil ich hab halt nix. Ich hab keine Endopods oder sonst was.
Für alles, was ich mehr sprinten kann, ist grad...
ist grad gut.
So, äh, schnell
zum Buff, NPC.
Sind die...
sind die schon drinne?
Sind die schon...
Oh, die sind schon drinne.
Okay, dann müssen wir uns
beeilen.
Äh, warte mal.
Bin ich... Sekunde, hier ging's lang, oder?
Ne,
ja doch.
ich hoffe ich werde nicht abgefahren auf dem weg aber ich habe aber die
eisbeine ist am start die gilde dann die darf kann uns nichts passieren
bei der wei kleiner trick einfach immer immer ich hoffe ich schaffe es dann noch
rechtzeitig rein bis losgeht ok way that entrance sagt er das ist gut dann schaffen wir es
ok ich glaube wir haben es rechtzeitig geschafft so dass das jetzt so stressig wird hätte ich
nicht gedacht aber das hier ist easy also hier ist wirklich brain brain afk brain ausschalten
wenn wir es rechtzeitig geschafft haben ja als hier sind wir okay die sind auch noch da sehr
gut quest annehmen übrigens dieser dungeon hier ist recycleware fällt einem wahrscheinlich nicht
auf wenn man das spiel nicht gespielt hat aber wobei doch fällt wahrscheinlich jedem auf auch
wenn man es das früher nicht gespielt hat das ist aus einem alp dungeon einfach räume aneinander
gesetzt und immer wieder die gleichen räume da hat irgend ein typ sich mittags mal gedacht ey
wir brauchen einen neuen Dungeon.
Aber Mist, wir haben gerade keine Leute da für neue Dungeons.
Egal, Copy-Paste.
Und dann kommt Passage of Conflict raus.
Früher gab es einen anderen Dungeon hier im PvP-Gebiet.
Der war individueller designt.
Man sieht übrigens eine schöne Sache, die man hier sieht, ist,
das ist ein unterirdischer Dungeon im Grenzgebiet.
Hier kann man von Midgard nach Albion oder von Midgard nach Hibernia
unterirdisch laufen, also quasi in die anderen Reiche, wenn man nicht Boot fahren möchte
oder rennen möchte, kann man hier unterirdisch durch.
Eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Es ist auch relativ beliebt für Relikt-Raids, die dann beispielsweise nach Hibernia gehen
oder nach Albion, dort ein Relikt holen und das zurückbringen unterirdisch.
Du hast dann quasi, das ist dann so eine taktische Frage, wo du lang gehst, dass die dich nicht
abfangen können.
Du hast ja mehrere Varianten.
Du kannst mit dem Boot zurückfahren.
Du kannst hier unterirdisch rennen.
Oder du kannst überirdisch rennen.
Oder halt Boot fahren.
Ich renne jetzt hier einfach mal durch,
in der Hoffnung nicht zu sterben.
Okay, passt. Nice.
Was sagst du zu Hostinger für Domains?
Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Wird noch neuer Content für das Spiel von der Community gemacht?
Ja.
Also das hier ist ein Free-Shot.
Eden Dark.
und die haben so unglaublich viel gemacht, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Also die haben mehr gemacht in den drei Seasons, die jetzt quasi hier über die letzten zweieinhalb, drei Jahre gelaufen sind,
die letzten drei Jahre, haben die mehr gemacht als der offizielle Besitzer von Dark Edge of Camelot die letzten zehn.
Letzten fünfzehn, naja, nee, letzten zehn.
Also die haben wirklich saumäßig viel gemacht.
Was natürlich ein bisschen schwierig ist für einen Freeshot, ist grafischer Content.
Also neue Gebiete und neue Klassen und sowas.
Das ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Oder neue Models.
Wobei sie sogar das hingekriegt haben.
Also theoretisch kann man auch, weil das ist so eine uralte Engine.
Übrigens, by the way, das ist die gleiche Engine, also die Base-Engine unter Dark.
ist die gleiche wie unter Fallout.
Oder unter...
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob
irgendein entfernter Ableger davon
auch unter Skyrim drunter ist.
Und diese Bethesda Engine.
Das ist Gamebüro, oder wie
das heißt. Ich glaube, das gibt es gar nicht
mehr. Aber da ist die Fallout
Engine mal draus entstanden.
Letztendlich ist es aber egal.
Also es ist wie bei Unreal
oder unity du siehst einem spiel wenn es gescheit gemacht ist nicht unbedingt an
welche engine das untendrunter verwendet haben unity erkennst du vielleicht
manchmal so an der standard physik oder den standard schatten dürfen und so was
oder
zum großen teil kannst du das an dem spiel nicht nicht direkt ansehen
außer es ist halt der 08 15 asset flip weil man schon 50 mal gesehen hat
wäre einfach ins instanz stirbt man habe ich ein rätsel auf der leiste wie gesagt
ich habe einfach random alles auf die leiste gezogen ich habe null quick
balance oder irgendwelche makros oder sonst was wir müssen den heiler gleich
wenn wir 50 sind nach dem raid hier sind wir 50 müssen wir den heiler ums becken
ich habe noch wie gesagt ich habe noch 500 oder 600 skill point übrig
Und dann mache ich auch
die ganzen Leisten und alles.
Aktuell typisches
Dark PvE. Hinterherrennen.
Hinterherrennen. Alles wegziehen.
Das hier ist übrigens ein PvP-Dungeon.
Wir sind, ich gucke mal kurz wie viele Leute wir sind,
226!
Aber wir machen mal das Game ein bisschen hübscher.
Ja.
226!
Season 3 ist gestartet, ja gestern
gestern um 13 Uhr
Warte mal kurz hier
Ich frag den mal, ob die Level 1 Gruppe starten wollen nach SH.
Moment, sind wir jetzt schon drin hier?
Ich hoffe, meine Crew fightet nicht.
Ja, nice.
By the way, jemand, der wissen wollte,
wenn man mal einen Mob sieht,
hier, hier, hier ist ein Boss.
Den sieht man da.
Der wird aber leider nicht lange da stehen gleich.
Der wird umgezerrt von 226 Leuten.
Hier passiert, 226 Leute machen Content für 16 Leute.
Geh mir, guck mal, guckt euch die Lebensbalken an.
Guckt euch die Lebensbalken an.
Content für 16 mit...
Bam.
Content für 16 mit 226.
Oh shit, Alps, komm.
Das hier ist ein...
Leute, lasst mich doch raus.
Fightet nicht, ich muss durch das Tor.
Wenn die Gruppe im Fight ist, darf man das Portal nicht benutzen.
Wie viele Spieler sind auf dem Server?
100%ig weiß man es nicht
Aber ich tipp mal so auf 3500
Meine Güte Leute
Hört doch mal auf in Combat zu sein
Guck mal die laufen jetzt schon weiter
Ich hasse es wenn die alle so planlos sind
Hör auf, Mobs zu hauen.
Wir müssen das Portal benutzen.
Ich raste aus, wenn ich jetzt den Encounter nicht kriege,
weil unsere Leute nicht aufhören können, Mobs zu hauen.
Das Problem ist, die Mobs respawnen saumäßig schnell hier drinnen.
Jetzt.
Okay.
Muss man es beeilen.
Das Schöne ist, die stehen gerade ohne Heiler beim nächsten Boss
und verrecken sie halt, wenn er ein bisschen AE macht.
Selbst schuld.
Dass überhaupt noch Leute
leben, die das damals gespielt haben, ja,
ist erstaunlich, gell?
Ich glaube, die hatten
letztes Season irgendwas
um 20, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das gelesen
habe oder mir das einbilde, irgendwas
um 20.000 Spieler?
Aber natürlich nicht gleichzeitig, ne? Logisch.
Oder noch mehr?
Okay. Oh, die haben schon gepullt.
Jetzt kommen wir gerade nochmal rechtzeitig.
Einer fehlt uns dann aber noch.
Guck mal, ich hab noch nicht mal solche
Heal gemappt. Ich muss das jetzt machen, wie die letzte
Kacknot mit Leisten klicken.
Ja.
Ja, 10 Stunden Kreisel-Crimestream
ist angesagt jetzt.
Übrigens, guckt euch das mal an.
Auch wieder 16 Mann
content mit 226 der bosch kann einfach nichts killen der ist einfach instant instant dead
ja ach so ja ich mach was man sieht bloß nicht guck ich mache manchmal crewpeel
manchmal mache ich, ich drücke eine Taste
ab und zu manchmal, so hier, guck, Group Heal
und ich könnte noch
wenn es mir danach ist, Attack Speed casten
oder, oh jetzt kann ich tatsächlich
mal was sinnvolles machen, ich könnte
ähm, wo hab ich den Knopf dafür da
ist wirklich schlimm
wenn man nicht mit seiner normalen
ersten Layout spielt
könnte denen was heilen
ja und ich könnte, wenn ich wirklich, wenn ich richtig
High Utility raushauen will
könnte ich Attack Speed casten
Wow, Alter, lag.
Und ich könnte alternativ auch Seuche heilen.
Also hier unten ist ein Group-Fenster.
In Dark sind die Gruppen 8 Spieler groß.
Und manchmal verändern sich die Farben.
Wenn die orange werden, dann haben sie Seuche drauf.
Dann 50% weniger Heals.
und wenn die so blau sind dann sind sie verzaubert und dann muss man sie aufwecken
aber macht euch da nicht so viele gedanken drüber wenn ich den level 1 charge starte gleich dann
danach hoffe ich mal dass der danach level 1 coup machen will da können wir uns das mit dem
Skalde alles in Ruhe angucken.
So Level 50 Content
random, wenn man das Spiel nicht kennt, ist
ein bisschen schwierig.
Aber es ist easy. Also
der PvE-Anteil von Dark ist wirklich
einfach. Das kann
der 80-jährige Opa,
der nur noch auf einem
Auge was sieht und nur noch
eine Hand richtig bewegen kann, kann Dark
PvE-Content machen.
Zumindest den
meisten. Das, wo wir gerade
beim Content sind von Eden,
Eden hat in der Richtung auch jede Menge gemacht, nämlich die haben zusätzliche
Dungeons kreiert. Das sind tatsächlich Instanzen.
Die können also auch sprich mehrere Gruppen gleichzeitig machen. Das ist
strikte Acht-Mann-Content. Da gibt es glaube ich aktuell zwei oder drei
instanzen es gibt so bekannt es gibt anders city gibt es noch irgendwas ein
lager wollen ja ich war eine weile nicht mehr und aber ich bin nicht so dass er
wieder auf das da ich kann es nicht versprechen deswegen haltet euch mit
subscript schützt und sowas zurück aber ich habe eines meiner probleme gefixt
Nice.
Wir waren zu spät. Top.
Wir können die Quest nicht beenden.
Fucking shit.
Oder um es mit Pilzworten zu sagen.
You play like shit.
Ich glaube,
habe ich schon gesehen im Chat.
Stick, Stick, Stick. Okay, wir gehen wieder raus.
Wo ist denn unser
Raid-Leader-Guy?
Hier, irgendwo, da.
Da bewegt sich was.
Achso, der ist noch nicht
respawned, der Mob.
Wollt ihr mal
lachen? Wollt ihr mal
einen Ausraster von einem der BG-Leader
hören? Der ist aber von letzter Season.
Hat einer
ein Video aufgenommen?
Weil man ein bisschen ausgeflipst ist.
Was ist das?
Warum kann ich ihn hier nicht rein?
Die fighten schon.
Na gut.
Wir sollten den Encounter kriegen,
wenn wir hier davor stehen.
Wir sollten den Encounter...
Ah, wir haben den Encounter bekommen hier.
Kill Summoner.
Sehr gut.
dann fehlt uns jetzt eigentlich nur noch
äh
Samana Kuno Vinda
und da können wir uns
was können wir uns dann eigentlich abholen hier
ja unser Level 50 können wir uns abholen
easy
ja und ich, wenn das hier durch ist
wenn wir den letzten Boss gekillt haben
dann ähm zeige ich euch das mal
Ich muss das Video mal suchen.
Das heißt irgendwas Pilz Meltdown oder so auf YouTube.
Durchscrollen.
Also Pilz ist der
BG
beziehungsweise
PvP Leader von Hibernia.
Einer.
Aber der der eigentlich immer 24-7
am Start ist.
Wenn er nicht Hearthstone spielt.
Die haben schon direkt gepullt.
Ich hau da jetzt mal mit drauf.
Weil ich will, dass wir Damage gemacht haben.
Ja, okay, wir haben Damage gemacht.
Wir haben den Encounter safe.
Gut.
Gut, dann haben wir es.
Nice.
Jetzt können wir uns Level 50 abholen.
Hat sich auch gelohnt.
Ich frag den Typen mal, ob er jetzt...
Ob er jetzt Level 1 Group starten will?
Dragon? Oh ne.
Oder ne, Dragon habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Dragon Raid ist absolut pepega shit.
Ähm, sind wir überhaupt richtig?
Hier sind wir doch gar...
Ja doch, hier sind wir richtig.
Gibt es Artefakte im Els oder ist das Eden?
Das ist Eden.
Aber, und das finde ich eigentlich mega nice, die haben es auf Eden mittlerweile so gemacht, dass Thor-Content optional ist.
Also du kannst den ganzen Thor-Content machen, aber das einzige was du kriegst ist Artefakt-Skins und Rüstungsskins.
Was eigentlich ziemlich cool ist, weil das Spiel hat ja relativ vielfältige Rüstungen und Waffen und Skins und alles mögliche.
Aber die ganzen Klassik-Server haben das bisher nicht benutzt.
Ist das Spiel nicht broken, wenn man nach zwei Tagen max level ist?
Naja, erstens spielst du nicht nur einen Char.
Und zweitens ist eigentlich das PvP-Sandbox-Endgame das, wofür man das spielt.
Nicht so sehr für Leveln.
Es gibt Leute, die machen den ganzen Tag PvE?
Äh, was ist hier eigentlich?
Ach, die wollen viben oder was?
Wollen die viben?
Oder was ist der Plan? Ich verstehe es gerade nicht so genau.
Was ist der Plan?
Wollen die vipern oder was haben die vor?
Ich habe keinen Plan
Eigentlich wollte ich jetzt raus
Und meine Quest abgeben
Okay die machen Dragon
Komm wir machen Dragon schnell mit
Es scheint ja halbwegs schnell zu gehen
Ne, achso, MLs gibt's nicht
Nein, MLs gibt's nicht
Das finde ich aber auch gut
Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen
Tor an sich war eine coole Sache
Gerade weil es das Spiel eben ein bisschen
Gestreckt hat, sodass du da auch
Mehr zu tun hattest
Aber was ich nie mochte
War der übermäßige
Use von MLs
Also sprich auch, dass eine Speedtrap
An jeder Ecke steht und sowas
dass da habe ich anfälle bekommen ich glaube ich gebe mir mein instant ok
nice ich will mir aber jetzt unbedingt noch mal level 50 abholen bevor wir
train rate machen bin mir nicht sicher machen wir train rate oder ich frage
den mal ob der level 1 group machen will der andere weil ich wie gesagt ich muss
Ich muss noch mein Shami, mein Skalde und mein Runi leveln.
Und dann noch zwei Chars auf Alp und einen auf Hipp.
Also ich habe die nächsten Tage echt genug zu tun.
Frag den mal.
Wenn er jetzt nicht antwortet, schreibe ich nicht nochmal.
und ich muss unbedingt meine quickbars ordentlich machen
aber dann noch ein bisschen mehr ein bisschen mehr hin so wie es aussieht
also was ich überhaupt ja die unterwassergebiete und sowas das kannst du alles machen auf eben du
kannst artefakt encounter machen du bekommst dann halt beispielsweise ein
3 los oracles staff dass da kriegst du dann nicht den staff sondern kriegst
quasi das skin pattern was du dann auf einen anderen staff
verbleiben kannst kannst quasi jeden beliebigen staff nehmen und der sieht
dann aus wie traurig zum beispiel das haben die zusammen die zu haben die gut
gemacht du kannst die du kannst die also wie ist der kram noch mal nicht clm ml 10 und so kannst
du machen gibt es auch ganz gute drops du kannst du kannst quasi allen allen tor content machen
das was es halt nicht gibt sind mls und also ml fähigkeiten und artefakte artefakt fähigkeiten
das finde ich auch gut und es hoffe ich dass sie es auch nicht machen so hier ist egal was
wir nehmen. Leute, wir sind Level 50.
Easy. Okay, 49,9
sind wir. Also, wenn
wir einen Mob killen, sind wir 50.
Okay.
Ja, komm, wenn die Dragon Raid machen,
machen wir Dragon mit. Currencies
brauchen wir eh.
Dann habe ich
vielleicht mal kurz fünf minuten was ist das zu erzählen wie viel kostet das spiel nix ganz
auf jeden tag ob es in der ort kannst du kostenlos spielen ist halt einen free start dementsprechend
von fans im endeffekt gemacht aber das ist halt eine bessere version als auf live und
dementsprechend, es gibt eigentlich gar keine Frage, wo man spielt, finde ich.
Ja.
So, jetzt nochmal vielleicht kurz zur Erklärung, warum es sich trotzdem lohnt, auch mit Level 50,
oder was heißt, warum es sich lohnt?
Es ist viel mehr los, live ist tot, hier sind 3500 Leute, sag ich jetzt.
Sie sagen keine genauen Zahlen, aber ich, sie haben gesagt, so viele Leute wie gestern,
beim Launch von Season 3, waren noch nie auf dem Server.
und daraus, nachdem ich die Zahlen
von Season 1 und Season 2 am Anfang
kenne, leite ich daraus ab
es müssen so 3500
Leute oder so gewesen sein
das wird jetzt die nächsten Tage
ungefähr ein bisschen so bleiben
und dann ein bisschen runter gehen, aber es pendelt
sich dann meistens so um 2000, 1500
Leute ein
ja
ok, ähm
dann porten wir mal in
die Dragon Zone.
Also,
warum es sich nicht nur lohnt,
beziehungsweise eigentlich Pflicht ist, auch mit 50
die ganzen
PvE-Sachen zu machen ist,
man möchte später mal seinen Charakter
ordentlich ausrüsten können. Ordentlich ausrüsten
in Dark heißt,
man braucht
Equipment.
Hastener, ja, Hastener gehen wir mal hin.
man braucht equipment und equipment bekommt man von unterschiedlichen pcs
gegen währung das ist auch eine sache das haben die in eden eingeführt
ich laufe mal immer alleine als heiler zum drache laufen ist halt selbstmord
Das mach ich nicht
Ich warte bis die Leute da sind
Und einen Teleport aufmachen
Das ist mir gerade
Zu gefährlich hier durch die Zone
als heiler solo zu rennen so was sehr cool wäre wenn ich jetzt 50 wäre dann könnte ich jetzt
nämlich schnell respecten man kauft sich rüstung kein kräfter notwendig da muss ich jetzt aber ein
bisschen zu ausholen ich muss nur gucken ob irgendeiner port aufmacht von meinen leuten
ich gehe mal kurz zum teleporter 3 und 5 machen port auf also spricht der schami und der huni
da schauen wir mal
also da muss ich ein bisschen ausholen ich zeig dir ich zeig dir wie das funktioniert
während wir warten bis er bis der drachen raid anfängt beziehungsweise bis die einen
teleport aufmachen ohne irgendeiner hat die die npcs angegriffen das sind die sind zwar
freundlich, aber das sind trotzdem
Gegner, die man angreifen kann.
Also Mobs, die man angreifen kann.
Und das ist halt ein bisschen blöd, mitten in dem Dorf die anzugreifen,
weil dann ist man dead.
Port in Mulan. Okay.
Bangs.
Ich zeig dir wieder das Funst.
Mit Equipment.
Äh, Mulan.
Also.
Ähm.
Sehr gut.
Genau.
So, hier warten wir jetzt, bis Dragon Raid losgeht.
Ich stick den mal, dass ich es nicht verpasse.
Buff mich schnell.
Wuni ist am Start, der kriegt was.
Rests müssen wir mal gucken dann.
Also, was ist das?
Das ist Dark Age of Camelot, ein 20 Jahre altes MMO.
Und wir machen Braindead PvE Content, um Currency zu farmen.
Das gibt's noch.
Ich spiele das Ganze auf Eden Dark.
Das ist ein Free-Shot.
Kannst du kostenlos spielen.
Live gibt es auch noch.
Aber Live ist eine schlechtere Version als Eden.
Ich halte mich mal an unseren Huni.
der rennt hoffentlich nicht los ohne ohne sinn und verstand ja also um jetzt
mal das ganze zu ende zu führen was ich jetzt 580 mal schon versucht haben
anzufangen während wir warten dass losgeht also warum es sinn macht auch
mit level 50 wir sind ja 50 im endeffekt muss auch ein mob killen dann ist die
grafik so naja das spiel ist 20 jahre alt
Und ich habe die Grafik schon etwas enhanced, normalerweise sieht es ein bisschen plasser aus.
Du kannst neue Models verwenden, das war es dann aber auch.
Also warum es nicht nur Sinn macht, sondern eigentlich fast Pflicht ist, wenn man Level 50 ist,
ab und zu ein bisschen PvE-Content mitzumachen,
ist, man bekommt
bei den
unterschiedlichen Raids
unterschiedliche Währungen. Also wir haben beispielsweise
eben Summoners Hall gemacht.
Das war das letzte, was wir gemacht haben.
Da gibt es so Buchseiten.
Dann vorher haben wir...
Ah ne, stimmt. Haben wir nicht.
Haben wir nicht gemacht.
Trollheim, was wir vorher gemacht haben, gibt es keine
Währung. Deswegen wird das auch relativ selten gemacht.
er kann das spiel einfach so spielen naja du musst dir keine zehn stunden tutorials angucken
du solltest ihr ein bisschen zeit lassen mit leveln und eine klasse lernen und da kommt man
rein es ist aber halt ein spiel was relativ schwierig vom einstieg ist weil es einem nichts
erklärt kannst mich fragen wenn du willst du kannst aber auch in game fragen es gibt
nicht weiß chat slash advice kannst du fragen und die meisten leute sind relativ hilfsbereit
Lasst euch nicht, es gibt halt wie so oft in so alten Games wieder so die selbsternannte Elite,
die sich über alles lustig machen muss.
Also wenn ihr dann zum Beispiel fragt, so, beste Klasse, ich stelle euch vor, ihr seid ein Noob
und würdet gerne Bone Dancer spielen oder Knochentänzer auf Deutsch.
Das ist glaube ich eine Klasse, die finden viele ganz cool.
Ja und sie gehen dann in Advice Chat und sagen so, ah, was, Leute, könnt ihr mir sagen,
was die beste Rasse ist für Bone Dancer?
dann gibt es dann die Leute, die in Advice schreiben
Ah, Go Troll!
Troll Best Bone Dancer
und sowas.
Aber
die meisten Leute, die in dem Chat
im Advice-Chat schreiben, sind
keine noob-hassende
Elite-Leute, die sich
selbst zu geil finden, sondern
die schreiben dann das Richtige rein.
Also darf man sich nicht davon abschrecken lassen.
Es gibt, wie so oft bei so alten
Games, so ein paar Leute, die
aus dem Altersheim spielen, noch älter sind
wie ich und das ultra krass
übertrieben hyper ernst nehmen.
Alles. Ich meine, ihr kennt mich.
Ich spiele auch gerne Optimized.
Ich spiele auch gerne
Optimized und ich mache mich auch gerne lustig,
wenn einer irgendwie
Leisten klickt anstatt Knöppel und
was auch immer. Aber
ganz ehrlich,
man muss einfach damit klarkommen,
dass nicht jeder
auf dem gleichen
Kenntnisstand ist, was das Spiel
ist.
Und ich finde das überhaupt nicht schlimm.
Also ich helfe, sofern es geht,
immer Noobs im Advice-Chat
oder auch in der Gruppe.
Und ich glaube,
das Spiel hat auf jeden einen ganz brauchbaren
Einstieg. Aber das wirft dann halt
in die Welt und man muss sich erstmal selbst
ein bisschen orientieren, was man machen
muss. Am besten
ist, man erstellt sich einen Chart, der sich so anhört
wie, als möchte man ihn spielen.
in einem Reich, wie es so aussieht,
als möchte man es spielen und macht mal
das Level 1 bis 10 Tutorial
und chattet ein bisschen im Groupchat
mit den Leuten und fragt einfach Leute.
Das ist ein Oldschool-MMO, das heißt,
es ist relativ social.
Es ist sinnvoll, mit Leuten im Groupchat zu
schreiben, es ist sinnvoll, sich eine Gilde zu suchen
und
spätestens, wenn man eine gescheite Gilde hat,
dann hat man eigentlich immer Leute, die einem helfen
bei Quests, bei irgendwelchen
Tasks, wenn man
nicht weiß, was man skillen soll
was man irgendwie spielen soll da hat man immer was wo man wo man ansprechpartner hat und es gibt
auch jede menge gilden die explizit sagen hier sie sind quasi so level noob gilden da kann man
einfach reinschreien hat von anfang 10 prozent xp boost muss ich übrigens machen hier gc baff xp
Yes
WTF
Hatte keinen XP Boost an
Was ist denn hier los
Oh come back please
Okay
Das ist halt ein Spiel
Aller Schule nicht so wie heutig
Wo alles super easy
Ich muss noch selbst nachdenken
Ja das stimmt
Das stimmt schon
Daug ist
Also es ist wirklich nicht sonderlich
Selbsterklärend
Aber es lohnt sich
Also ich finde
Es gibt kein Spiel
Was so eine krasse Langzeitmotivation hat
Wie Daug
Ich spiele das seit 2001
Müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen
Also
natürlich immer mal wieder
immer mal wieder
Pausen dazwischen und so, aber ich spiele es mehr oder weniger
ich spiele auch jede Eason Season, Monate, Monate
durch, also kaum so ein Spiel
dadurch, weil es im Endeffekt
ein PvP Sandbox Game ist
im Endgame
ja, aber ich wollte
ja eigentlich was zu Equipment und sowas
erzählen
also
vorher wollte ich euch noch vorher gibt es noch was zum lachen wartet mal wartet mal
und das ist der
daug pilz meltdown ist dieses video doch jetzt meldet also das ist das ist ein video hat er
aufgenommen pvp hier belagerung von diesem turm und der der bg lieder flippt
hier am ende ein bisschen aus dann wird es lustig
Ich kann mir das immer wieder anhören.
You play like shit.
Also manchmal
schlagen die Bogen halt hoch her.
Weiß nicht, ob man es gehört hat.
Ich kann mir das immer wieder anhören.
You play like shit.
Ja, wenn man anfängt,
blickt man erstmal nicht durch.
Ja, und
das will ich gar nicht verstehen,
dass man...
Ja was? Spread out? Das geht noch gar nicht los.
Das will ich gar nicht verstehen, dass manche Leute
keinen Bock auf PvP mit Discord haben.
Aber in der Regel ist das relativ gesittet.
Das war jetzt Endgame Sandbox PvP.
Und auch nicht auf Mid, sondern auf Hip-Seite.
Play like shit.
Äh.
Moment.
Ich bekomme Mini-Dragon-Quests?
Warum?
Warum bekomme ich Mini-Tragon-Quests?
Ich...
By the way, wo sind die überhaupt
alle hin jetzt gerade?
Die sind doch noch hier, oder?
What the fuck?
Moment.
Machen die jetzt Pre-Tragon-Quests, oder was?
Oh.
Das dauert ja wieder ewig.
Egal, solange ich die
Credits dafür kriege, soll mir recht sein.
Wird das Game noch weiterentwickelt? Ja.
Es gibt jeden, also auf Eden.
Auf Eden wird das weiterentwickelt.
Es gibt super viele neue Sachen.
Nicht nur von Season zu Season,
sondern auch von
während der Season.
Ich geh mal kurz da oben
mit hin, in der Hoffnung, ich sterb jetzt nicht
auf dem Weg. Und leeche
mal kurz den Encounter, den die da oben
gerade machen.
Also auf Eden passiert
saumäßig viel.
Oh shit.
Äh.
Ich hoffe, ich hab nix gepullt.
Um das jetzt nochmal fertig
zu werden, was
ich ursprünglich eigentlich
sagen wollte. Also Dark ist ein Spiel,
es hat sehr viele verschiedene Klassen.
und es ist für jeden was dabei aber es ist ein oldschool MMO das heißt man hat
Klassen die kriegen alleine nichts auf die Reihe
die sind essentiell für Groups für eine Gruppe das Game kostet gar nichts du kannst
auf Eden kostenlos spielen Eden-daorg.net glaube ich oder suche einfach
Eden daorg auf google das ist ein privater freeshart und du kannst dich
connecten mit deinem Discord-Account und spielen.
Okay, machen wir den
Encounter hier. Ja, zum Beispiel, guckt euch
meine Klasse an. Ich spiele Heiler.
Heiler ist ein, auf den
ersten Blick zumindest,
ein reiner Supporter.
Du kannst nix killen
selbst und du stirbst
an so ziemlich allem, was es bis zu dir
hinschafft.
Ja, das ist ein
Freeshot. Und der Start von Season 3 war
erst gestern. Also, wenn überhaupt
ein guter Einstieg ist dann jetzt.
Weil jetzt sind alle noch
am leveln, alle machen noch die ganzen
Daily-Geschichten und sowas.
Also ich kann alleine
nix als Heiler.
Du kannst als Heiler eigentlich nur eine Sache alleine
machen und das ist die Gegner vielleicht betäuben und
wegrennen. Das war's. Mehr kannst du nicht machen.
Auf der anderen Seite
kannst du das Spiel
nicht spielen in Gruppe ohne Heiler.
Heiler ist, also
sag ich jetzt einfach mal so,
oh fuck.
Sekunde, ich muss mal kurz hier weg und heilen.
Tatsächlich, ab und zu muss man noch heilen.
Ihr habt es gesehen, die Gruppe wäre komplett gewiped ohne mich.
Das ist die Lebensanzeige von Leuten in der Group.
Ich stick mal kurz.
ja
und du kannst halt ohne Supporter
nicht spielen, jedes Reich
also wie gesagt, nochmal zur Erinnerung, es gibt 3 Reiche
Hibernia
Midgard Albion, jedes Reich
hat 2
es ist ein bisschen Grauzone, wir können uns gleich nochmal
die Klassen angucken, hat 2
Haupt-Support-Klassen
Hips hat gefühlt irgendwie
eh, die Hälfte der Klassen
sind ja irgendwie Support, aber jedes
Reich hat 2 Haupt-Support-Klassen
in Midgard ist das Heiler und Schamane
in Albion ist das
Kleriker und Ordensbruder
ich hoffe ich krieg die Dinge auf Deutsch
überhaupt noch hin
und in Hip ist das Druide und Bade
wobei in Hip ist das ein bisschen
blurry, da gibt's
doch mehr eigentlich
in Hip kann eh gefühlt
die halbe oder dreiviertel der Gruppe heilen
und
ne Gruppe besteht aus 8 Leuten
Aktuell sind wir nur sieben.
Und wenn du nicht mindestens zwei Supporter in der Gruppe hast, kannst du es eigentlich vergessen, überhaupt aus der Tür zu gehen.
Am besten hast du drei Supporter.
In Midgard zumindest hast du zwei Heiler und einen Schamane dabei.
Wird man respected als Heiler?
Ja.
Heiler ist, meiner Meinung nach,
zumindest in Pack- und Treespec-Skillung
ist die schwerste und beste Klasse im Spiel.
Und das, obwohl du nichts killen kannst.
Wir specken auch gleich um
und ich mache dann irgendwann noch meine Leisten aus,
so wie ich es gewohnt bin.
Da kann ich euch vielleicht ein bisschen was zu erklären.
Aus meiner Sicht ist Heiler die beste Klasse,
die es gibt im Spiel.
Zweitbeste kann man sich
Zweitbeste kann man sich vielleicht drüber streiten
Aber Heiler ist aus meiner Sicht
Die beste Klasse, die es gibt
Und das obwohl er Supporter ist
Das ist super kompliziert
Wenn man neu einsteigt
Deswegen, wenn man neu anfängt
Ist das Beste, was man machen kann
Wir gucken uns gleich die unterschiedlichen Reiche
Und so an
und Klassen. Ich hab ja Chance, in allen
Reichen können wir mal kurz das Startgebiet uns angucken
oder so.
Ähm.
Wir können uns das Startgebiet in den allen drei Reichen mal
angucken und ich sag was kurz zu den Klassen.
Das
Beste, wie man starten kann,
aus meiner Sicht, ist,
sich ein Reich aussuchen, auf das man Bock hat.
Also wenn man beispielsweise auf Wikinger
und Schnee und sowas steht,
dann ist bei Midgard richtig,
wenn man eher so auf klassische Sachen
so König Arthus, England
und Ritter und Plattenrüstung steht.
Ist die Welt immer so foggy?
Ne, das ist die Zone hier.
Die Zone ist so foggy.
Wollen wir nicht
jetzt den Drache vielleicht killen?
Wir könnten,
die Minis bringen uns doch eh nix.
Ohne die
FZ-Minis. Weiß gar nicht, was wir jetzt hier machen.
Okay, ich bin 50, easy.
Nice.
Soll mir recht sein.
Ne, wenn du in Hibernia spielst, ist das Game viel grüner und bunter.
Midgard ist grau und Schnee.
Und ich hab das hier, wie du siehst, schon etwas...
reshaded.
Okay, Viech ist kaputt.
Next, please.
Also, am besten ist,
ihr sucht euch einen Startrealm aus,
wie gesagt, Midgard Albion,
und Hibernia ist für alle,
die es keltisch und grün mögen.
Ich glaube, offiziell ist es so,
wobei das nicht richtig stimmt,
also zumindest früher hat man so gesagt,
Hibernia ist so das Reich der Magie,
ganz viele Karsa und Grün
und alle haben sich lieb.
Midgard ist eher so nahkampforientiert und Wikinger-Style und Albion ist König Arthus, England und Ritter in Plattenrüstung und sowas in der Richtung.
Man muss sagen, da ist auch schon ein bisschen was dran. Der Spielstil ist schon sehr unterschiedlich in allen drei Reichen, denn, und das ist das, wie ich es auch sonst aus keinem anderen Spiel kenne, alle drei Reiche haben komplett unterschiedliche Klassen.
Also, Midgard hat 8 Klassen
Ich sag jetzt mal 8, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es wirklich genau 8 sind
Midgard hat 8 verschiedene Klassen
Albion hat 8 verschiedene Klassen
Und die Bär hat 8 verschiedene Klassen
Das sind komplett unterschiedliche Klassen
Es gibt keine Klasse
Die die gleiche ist
In allen 3 Reichen
In der späteren Expansion gab es eine
Aber die gibt es hier auf Eden nicht
Und die hat auch gesagt
So, können wir jetzt please den Dragon Raid machen
Und dann hier weg
Wir gucken uns da mal
Die drei Startgebiete an
Und ich erzähl auch mal kurz was
Zu den
Den ganzen Klassen
Also
Am besten ist tatsächlich
Man sucht sich ein Reich raus, was man spielen will
Also eins von den drei. Und dann eine Starterklasse, die, sagen wir mal, recht einsteigerfreundlich ist.
Es macht immer Sinn, das zu wählen, worauf man Bock hat, klar.
Aber gerade in Dark ist es so, dass die Klassen doch schon sehr unterschiedlich im Skill-Level sind.
Also, du kannst zum Beispiel Heiler spielen oder sagen wir mal Puck-Triesbeck-Heiler spielen,
was so ziemlich die beste und schwerste Klasse im Spiel ist.
Moin Natti. Alles klar.
Oder du kannst Feuer Wizard spielen.
Und einen Button drücken.
Attack, Attack, Attack, Attack, Attack, Attack.
Ne, du kannst alle drei gleichzeitig spielen.
Ich hab auch alle...
Das ist auch ein Unterschied zu Live.
Auf Live konnte man nur ein Reich spielen.
Gleichzeitig.
Ja, auf einem Server.
Und auf Eden kannst du alle drei spielen.
Also kannst du auf allen drei gleichzeitig Charakter haben.
Aber du hast, wenn du PvP gemacht hast, hast du einen Umlock-Timer.
Dass du jetzt nicht, sagen wir mal, ins PvP-Gebiet gehen kannst, siehst,
oh, für meinen Realm läuft es gerade scheiße und lockst Winning Team um.
Das geht nicht. Ich glaube, du hast einen 2-Stunden-Timer.
Und ich glaube, bis du volle RPs bekommst, also Punkte für PvP, sind es, glaube ich, sogar 6 Stunden.
Es kann auch sein, dass ich jetzt gerade total Mist erzähle, aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht so easy zu sagen,
oh, ich logge jetzt um, weil es gerade scheiße läuft.
Also das haben die ziemlich gut gemacht, meiner Sicht.
Also es gibt einen ziemlich großen Unterschied von Skill-Leveln, sagen wir mal,
welche Klasse easy zu spielen ist oder welche Klasse das Potenzial entfaltet,
auch ohne dass man hier übelst tryhardet oder nicht.
Kann ich mit einem Freund vom anderen Reich zusammen... Ne, kannst du nicht.
also du kannst gruppen kannst du nur formen mit leuten aus dem eigenen reich
ja also deswegen würde ich empfehlen wenn ihr anfangen wollt sucht euch ein reich aus was euch
gefällt wir gucken uns gleich die straße die startgebiete man das ist da geht's auf kameron
20 jahre altes mmo und ich warte jetzt eigentlich drauf bis bis der drachen endlich los geht dann
muss ich auch noch was zu templates und allem erzählen ja es ist alt genau ja
und es gibt in jedem bereich so ein paar klassen wo ich der meinung bin die sind
ganz sinnvoll zum zum starten zum beispiel ich hatte doch hier irgendwo
mal ich habe so viele fenster auf
Dark, Glasses, ja genau da gibt es eine Übersicht. Also nehmen wir mal Midgard zum Beispiel. Wenn ihr sagt, ihr wollt in Midgard anfangen, also das hier Reich, in dem ich auch spiele, wenn ihr also quasi auf Wikinger und Nordisch und Schnee und sowas steht, auch wenn die sich da ein bisschen trist drumherum aus, passend halt zum Gebiet,
dann kann ich euch empfehlen als einstiegsklasse schon mal nicht tanks also keine nahkampfklasse
das ist ich weiß das ist ein bisschen bisschen kontra dem weil viele leute die wikinger und mit
grad spielen wollen stehen auf nahkampfklasse und spielen auch ganz gerne donner krieger weil
weil tor und blitze und sowas aber ich bin der meinung als einstieg ist ein mini charakter nicht
gut weil du musst die spielmechanics relativ gut checken dass du nicht laufen stirbst als
nahkampf also du brauchst also gerade pvp pvm ist da auch easy also wenn ihr wenn ihr sagt
wenn ihr sagt ihr wollt nur pvp erst mal spielen um das spiel kennenzulernen dann macht euch
irgendein nahkämpfer eurer wahl ist egal pvp kannst du in dark bis auf die paar high end
Sachen, die es gibt, eigentlich auf der halben Arschbacke
erledigen. Das ist wirklich nicht schwierig.
Aber wenn man jetzt mal von PvP spricht,
was ja, wie gesagt, Sandbox
PvP ist der Kern von
Dark. Also, wer
das nicht mag,
du kannst zwar auch nur craften
und nur PvM machen und da auch
24-7 reinsuchten,
aber so wirklich das volle Potenzial
entfaltet das Spiel eigentlich nur, wenn man eben
seinen Sandbox...
Sag mal!
Wo rennen wir denn jetzt schon wieder hin?
was haben wir wollen seit 30 minuten track rate machen und ich bin eh nur hier für die
currency wie viele spieler hat das game noch die dritte season ging gestern los ich würde
sagen so meiner einschätzung nach 3500 aktuell so ich kann das nur ableiten aus dem schweren
von Season 1 und Season 2 und das sie gestern geschrieben haben, so viele waren noch nie online.
Also würde ich sagen 3500.
Also um mal zu den Klassen zu kommen, während wir hier laufen, muss ich ja nicht zugucken.
Also ich kann euch nicht unbedingt einen Nahkämpfer empfehlen, wenn ihr wirklich einsteigen wollt in das Spiel in Midgard,
weil gerade PvP ist Nahkämpfer eine Klasse, da musst du ein bisschen den Flow, nenne ich es mal, von Dark drin haben.
Du musst wissen, wann kannst du reinpushen und du musst wissen, wenn du zu weit drin bist und dich zurückziehst.
Und das am besten so, dass du nie tief in gegnerischer Caster-Range bist und wieder rausrennen kannst, bevor die dir Cross-Damage machen.
Weil eins muss man sagen in Dark, Caster machen Brutals-Damage.
Wenn du Caster frei hast, gut ausgestatteter Caster, der nuked dich in ein paar Sekunden weg.
also wenn du wenn du als nahkämpfer zwischen drei cast ansteht und die kommt zum kasten platzt du
instant gerade gerade gegen hips hitze die bar von 2 bmw platzt du platzt so schnell dass ich
kaum eine heilen kann wo ist meine skill bar hier oben die super random weil ich einfach beim
leveln draufgezogen habe und ich muss auch ums becken ich hab ich hab noch 700 punkte
ich muss komplett respekte ja in dark ist das das ist das beste sandbox pvp was man sich vorstellen
kann ja und da bist du als tank im prinzip beziehungsweise als nahkampf war ich immer
tot wenn du pvp spielst und nicht so diesen diesen flow drauf hast also sagen wir du würdest jetzt
sagen wir mal jemand kummer beispielsweise ich weiß leute die mit gerade anfangen die spielen
gerne Donnerkrieger. Weil
Tor und Blitze und sowas.
Donnerkrieger ist ein Caster
Nahkampf-Hybrid, der geht
als Einstiegs-Char noch irgendwie.
Ja? Weil alles, wo ein bisschen Caster
mit drin ist, geht. Aber ganz ehrlich,
ich finde, es ist kein guter Einstiegs-Char.
Weil du musst, allein schon, was du dich entscheiden musst,
wann gehst du Nahkampf, wann castest
du, du musst aufpassen, dass du
nicht zu weit reinrennst, du musst gucken, dass du nicht
aus der Heal-Range läufst und
ich finde, es ist kein guter
Einstieg. Meiner Meinung nach,
was ein guter Einstiegs-Char in Midgard
ist, ist
wenn ihr Caster spielen wollt,
könnt ihr Spiritmaster oder RuneMaster
spielen.
Sind die zwei einzigen.
BoneDancer ist auch gut zum
Einstieg.
Aber da hat man das Pet-Handling noch ein bisschen
dabei. Also ich würde sagen RuneMaster
und Spiritmaster
ist ganz gut, wenn man Caster
mag. Also wenn man gerne
zaubert. Oder
Aber meiner Meinung nach ist Shami auch eine gute Einstiegsklasse, weil es ist Support, aber es ist eine ziemliche Low-Skill.
Oh, fuck. Moment, ich muss mal kurz heilen.
Boah, wir verrecken.
Also du kannst als Shami effektiv sein, ohne dass du viel machen musst oder viel wissen musst über das Game.
Du kannst trotzdem ein bisschen was rausholen, gerade später, wenn du ein bisschen mit rootest und ein bisschen mit Seuche machst, Buff schierst und sowas. Das sind advancedere Sachen. Du kannst als Charmy auch relativ aktiv spielen und du kannst als Charmy ultra mega nervig sein für Gegner, aber du kannst als Charmy auch einfach nur buffen und...
By the way, wer sich fragt, warum ich jetzt hier draufklicke, ich habe Control bei mir anders gemappt und kann keine Shortcuts hören.
Also den Shami kann ich wirklich als Einstiegsklasse empfehlen, weil als Shami bist du die hauptsächliche Buffklasse in Midgard.
Also du verstärkst quasi deine, du verbesserst quasi die Stats von deinen Groupmates.
und das ist eine rein passive Geschichte, du klickst die an, suchst dir einen Buff aus, klickst den Buff an
und dann buffst du deine Gruppe durch und da hast du als Shami schon mal 70% deiner Pflicht erledigt,
wenn alle Leute die richtigen Buffs haben, dann machst du noch Endu an, Endu Buff, hier das da,
das regeneriert bei allen in der Gruppe Ausdauer, so und wenn du diese zwei Sachen machst, als Shami,
deine Leute buffen in der Gruppe
und Endu an, hast du schon
80% deines Jobs erledigt.
Und das kriegt man auch als Einsteiger
gut hin. Deswegen, ich finde,
als Support ist Shammy
richtig gute Einstiegsklasse in Midgard,
weil du kannst dich auf das Spiel
konzentrieren. Du musst dich nicht so sehr auf deine Klasse
konzentrieren und gucken, dass du nicht was vergisst
und nicht vergisst, was hier zu drücken und da irgendwas zu machen.
Als Schamane gehst du in die Gruppe,
buffst deine Leute, wenn einer stirbt,
rebuffst du den, machst Endu an
und lässt
das Spiel erstmal auf die schwierigen Levels
in Ruhe. Nach 50 machst du dich mit
den Mechanics vertraut und lernst das Game.
Ja, du kannst als Schammy auch heilen,
sogar relativ gut, wenn du ordentlich speckst.
Und
das ist gut, da hast du eine super Support-Klasse,
die extrem gefragt ist.
Also ich würde sagen, Schammy ist fast noch
mehr gefragt als Heiler,
weil es gibt in der Regel weniger Schammys als
Heiler.
also als Schammy findest du immer eine Gruppe
egal ob PvE, PvM
Raids, irgendwelche
Schammy, du gehst in die
Gruppe rein, sagst Schammy LFG
Bam, Instant Invite, noch schneller als
beim Heiler, beim Heiler auch, aber beim Schammy
Instant, also ich finde, wenn man gerne
Support spielt, ist Schammy
im Midgard das Beste für
einen Einsteiger, Heiler ist zu komplex
wird auch zu viel
erwartet von, ja
und steht und fällt auch irgendwie eine Gruppe mit zwei guten Heilern.
Shami nicht so sehr.
Shami verzeiht auch, wenn du ein bisschen Scheiße baust.
Also wenn du nicht gerade stirbst instant,
weil dann sind alle Buffs weg.
Aber ganz ehrlich, Shami verzeiht relativ viel.
Selbst wenn du neu bist und du läufst einfach nur rum in der Nähe der Gruppe
und versuchst im PvP am Leben zu bleiben,
hast du 80% deines Shami-Shops erfüllt.
Nämlich, die Leute haben weiter Buffs und Endu.
Hast du wieder cute Animes geschaut?
Laufen natürlich.
Also Shammy ist eine gute Einstiegsklasse
in Midgard, wenn man Supporter mag.
Wenn ihr gerne Caster spielt,
würde ich sagen, Spiritmaster oder RuneMaster
ist gut, Bone Dancer ist zum Einstieg nicht so gut.
Ja, und wenn ihr unbedingt Tank spielen
wollt als Einsteigschar,
dann würde ich tatsächlich sagen, dann spielt halt
Donnerkrieger.
Da bist du wenigstens noch ein bisschen Hybrid unterwegs.
Aber ich finde,
Einsteiger-Militars ist nix.
Ich hoffe, wir haben es bald hier.
So.
Ja, wir sind fertig.
also leute wenn der drachen raid nicht innerhalb der nächsten fünf bis zehn minuten losgeht es
wird sich auf den skylern fangen den auf 55 zu leveln weil ich meine ich brauche vier chance
ich spiele in der regel spiele ich skalde als main heiler schammi rudi und bd zum fahren ja
in Midgard und
Hexe Clary in Alb
und Bade in Hipp.
Also ich habe noch
genug hier zu machen,
wenn die nicht immer zu Potte kommen.
Aber machen wir mal kurz an der Stelle weiter.
Also Midgard, wie gesagt,
Skald ist übrigens auch ein guter Einstiegs-Char.
Hab ich ganz vergessen.
Also wenn es wirklich ein Melee-Char sein soll,
dann spielt Skald.
Vergesst, was ich gesagt habe.
Wenn ihr einen Nahkampf-Char spielen wollt,
unbedingt als ersten Char nehmt Skald.
Skald ist auch immer gebraucht und verzeiht auch noch am meisten eigentlich, dank Speed.
Aber ich würde euch empfehlen, wenn ihr wirklich neu seid, Midgard anfangen wollt, ein bisschen das Spiel kennenlernen wollt, mit einem Supporter zu starten ist gar nicht verkehrt.
Da finde ich ist Shami der Beste, weil halt, man muss nicht viel machen.
So, wenn ihr denkt, euch ist eher nach König Arthus und Ritter und Ritterrüstung, da gibt es ein bisschen mehr zur Auswahl.
wenn ihr gerne Caster spielt,
eindeutig Ice Wizard.
Ice Wizard wird auch immer gebraucht,
ist ein super Char.
Und man kann ihn später immer noch
auf Range Damage umspecken.
Und ansonsten in Albion,
in Albion kann man wirklich viel spielen
als Einstiegs-Char.
Aber ansonsten würde ich sagen,
Orns Bruder ist bestimmt auch,
krass, wo ist er denn hier? Ist auch ein ganz guter
Einstiegs-Char oder Clary. Clary ist auch gut
als Support,
weil du bist hauptsächlich fürs Heilen und
Buffen zuständig.
Und
Nahkampf würde ich in Albion gar nicht starten
als neuer Spieler.
Und in Hip ist eigentlich fast alles
OP.
Könnt ihr nichts falsch machen.
In Hip als Einstiegs-Char, also ich würde
euch auf jeden Fall von einem abraten und das ist Bade.
als einstiegs in hip bade ist nix zum einstieg ansonsten gibt es zum einstieg
truide als supporter ist es gut ist gut als einstiegs auf hip ein bisschen
gewöhnungsbedürftig eltern ist auch ganz okay worden kann man so als mele
support hybrid auch spielen als einstiegs ja aber wie gesagt ich würde
wieder absehen davon nahkampf nahkampf zu spielen
als einstiegs die leute gucken wie sie eigentlich sind so blöd wie sie rein
werden und wie die mobs pullen
jetzt muss ich in die grenze ich mache keine nein nein nein nein ich mache
Keine Mini-Dragon-Quest in Frontiers, oder?
Please.
Ich will einfach nur die Currency vom Dragon Raid haben und sonst nicht.
Mini-Dragons im Grenzgebiet habe ich jetzt wirklich kein Neff drauf.
Please, no.
Dann bin ich weg.
Frontiers ist noch deaktiviert?
Nee, nee.
Ich war gestern schon in Frontiers, hab Killtask gemacht.
Das ist alles da.
Ja.
So.
Ahem.
Ah.
Da sucht einer.
Moment, da muss ich mal gucken.
Da sucht einer Leute für Level Group.
ich habe eine level gruppe für skaldat
nice wir machen jetzt kein drachen raid es dauert mir zu lang
wir leveln jetzt in skalde endlich richtig bock drauf
ich log jetzt einfach hier aus mitten im gebiet lul ich habe keine ahnung was
was die hier treiben. Die rennen die ganze Zeit im Kreis nur.
Welches Level ist das? 1!
Ich habe gestern mit dem Heiler
angefangen, den eben gerade noch
auf 50 schnell gemacht.
Natti, wenn du mitmachen willst, ich glaube, die suchen
noch Leute für die Level-Group hier.
Hat sie nicht einen Bersi?
Okay, jetzt muss ich erstmal alles wegklicken hier,
weil ich nur übrig habe.
Okay.
So, ich hoffe, ich habe den...
Moment, ich muss mal meine Chatbox ein bisschen anders schieben.
So? So? Hä?
So kann ich die schieben, oder?
Ja, genau.
Pappen wir das da oben hin.
Und gehen wir ins Tutorial-Gebiet.
Wo ist Tutorial?
Da ist Tutorial.
Würdest du mit dem Runi kommen?
Ich frag den mal kurz.
Ich frag den mal, ob du mit dem Runi kommen kannst.
Das wird jetzt zu entspannt, die Musik gerade.
Also das hier ist das Startgebiet in Midgard.
Wenn ihr euch einen neuen Char erstellt, kommt ihr wahrscheinlich hier raus.
Wenn ihr quasi startet.
Okay, der will kein Runi, der will nur Nahkampf.
Keine Ahnung, das ist Hyper-Optimized Level Group hier, wie es aussieht.
Also er meint, er wird Melee preferen.
Also wenn du Bersi spielen willst, kannst du glaube ich joinen, ansonsten mag er nicht.
Also das ist die Startzone.
Jetzt können wir das mal wirklich so durchmachen, wie wenn ihr starten würdet.
Weil es ist auch egal, ob ich eher 8 oder 9 bin oder 1.
Also wie gesagt, Huni mag er nicht.
Was sagen sie zu der vorgeschlagenen Umfrage?
Was denn?
Was fällt ihr am meisten an?
Die Gaming-Story, wie sieht die Nerd-Streams-Maus sein?
Für seine Lebensweise?
Na, da müssen wir keine Umfrage machen.
Eindeutig für die Lebensweisheiten.
Logisch.
Kann die Banshee auf Eden durch Wände casten?
Ja, teilweise.
Also in jedem der drei Reiche startet man so ein Tutorialgebiet und das ganze geht von
1 bis 10.
So, jetzt müssen wir eigentlich nur noch warten,
bis wir den letzten Spot voll haben
in der Gruppe.
Machst du mir Leonie?
Nee, der mag nicht.
Ich weiß auch nicht.
Ich fände einen Caster dabei, ehrlich gesagt,
nicht schlecht, aber er mag nicht.
Okay, erstmal die ganzen
Campl hier löschen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich hier noch alles auf der Leiste habe vom letzten Mal.
Ja, ich nehme schon mal die Questern
und
sticke hier.
bis wir
einen achten Mann gefunden haben.
Genau.
Und zwar, was ich euch noch erzählen wollte,
hat ja vorhin auch einer gefragt,
wie das mit Endgame und Equipment
und sowas ist. Da habe ich schon angefangen zu sagen,
es macht ja Sinn, auch als
50er
die PVE
Geschichten mitzumachen, also die
Raids mitzumachen, regelmäßig Sachen zu
grinden und sowas, weil, erstens
gibt es Geld,
also hier platin zweitens gibt's drops die man selber stehen kann wer dir gleich noch sehen ich
habe hier meine trade skills da kann man quasi rüstung zerlegen in materialien und verkaufen
und es gibt währungen es gibt glaube ich mal gucken ob ich das richtig und kommt vier verschiedene
Währung, glaube ich. Es gibt
Buchseiten,
Eis,
was gibt es denn sonst noch?
Was gibt es? Die TG-Währung,
die Dragon Scales
und
habe ich noch was vergessen?
Egal.
Man bekommt verschiedene Währungen,
für die man sich Items kaufen kann.
Tora Class
gibt es noch und diese
diese Luna-Coins
gibt es noch. Gibt sogar 5 Währungen.
Ist aber auch wurscht. Also es gibt
Währungen, die kriegt man von
PvE-Encountern.
Und
davon kann man sich Items kaufen.
In Dark ist es so,
im Endgame
verwendet man als sein Equipment,
aktuell ist das übrigens ein nackter Level 1 Char.
hier also und df siegel gibt es noch als noch als währung genau habe ich vergessen
legion raid jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen hier die mit wir starten wie ich starte lieber den
char mit zum mit zum leveln so und in der ist es so man verwendet als endgame equipment eine
mischung aus gekauften items also für währungen gekaufte items aus gecraftet items aus verzaubert
also gecraftet plus verzauberten items und aus ein paar gecraftet in use bild so tränken und
sowas das heißt das spiel hat eine relativ gute crafting economy könnte man sagen das hat auch
ein housing system da kann man sich ein händler hinstellen und items reinpacken zum verkaufen
aber man braucht am ende quasi kräfter die für allen sachen kräften beziehungsweise sachen
verzaubern und man braucht währung um sich equipment zu kaufen und um euch jetzt komplett
zu überfordern ich zeige euch das mal schnell steam es gibt ein crafting programm bei der
wahl warum funktioniert man jolo maus eigentlich nicht ich wundere mich schon die ganze zeit warum
Warum sieht mein Mauszeiger so komisch aus?
Warum funktioniert YOLO-Maus nicht?
Warum funktioniert...
Was ist denn das?
Moment.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, normalerweise habe ich nämlich
einen pinken Maus-Cursor, dass man den besser sieht.
macht das jetzt was?
Ja, okay.
Passwort, YOLO-Maus.
Ah!
Ja, schon.
Jetzt erkenne ich meine Mauszeiger wenigstens wieder.
Ich dachte mir die ganze Zeit so,
irgendwas fehlt hier doch.
Ja, irgendwas fehlt hier doch.
Jetzt weiß ich es, was fehlt.
So, kurz den Chat ein bisschen größer machen.
Okay.
Genau.
So.
Und um euch jetzt nochmal komplett zu verwirren,
zeige ich euch jetzt mal ein Programm,
womit man sein Endgame-Equipment plant.
Da gibt es unter anderem Zendcraft für.
Und wenn man Zendcraft startet,
kriegt man hier eine Auswahl für alle Items,
die es gibt.
und nehmen wir mal beispielsweise das Template für meinen Heiler,
dann hat man hier im Vorfeld alles durchgeplant, was man, ich muss mal gucken, dass ich nichts verpasse,
was man wie wo anzieht.
Also hier sieht, ja ja, hier sieht man seine Stat, kann man das übrigens auch mal nicht in Fullscreen packen vielleicht?
Warum ist denn das Fullscreen? Das war doch früher nie Fullscreen.
Okay, mittlerweile ist das Fullscreen, whatever.
Options?
Ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung.
Ja, und dann plant man im Prinzip wirklich alles mögliche durch an Items. Und ihr seht, es gibt Items, die grünen, die sind Player-Crafted und Player-Verzaubert und der Rest sind Items, die ich für Währung gekauft habe oder aber für Quest-Belohnung bekommen habe.
Also jetzt sind wahrscheinlich alle geistig ausgestiegen
Aber so plant man sein Endgame-Equipment in Dark
Es gibt ein extra Programm dafür
Es ist nicht ganz so krass wie Path of Exile, ja
Wo man für das ganze Spielen ein eigenes Programm braucht
Damit man es überhaupt gescheit spielen kann
Aber Template-Building ist eine Wissenschaft für sich in Dark
Weil es gibt auch noch
Für wirklich richtig gute High-End-Templates
Kann man auch Random-Drops einbauen
Also gerade spätere, schwerere PVE-Gegner droppen Random-Items, die besser sein können als alles Crafted und besser sein können als alles, was man so kaufen kann.
Aber die sind halt random, das heißt, es muss dann wirklich ein Customizedes Template sein.
So. Ja, und wenn man anfängt, startet man im Tutorial-Gebiet, so wie hier.
und was man als Melee-Charakter machen sollte,
als erstes ins Inventar gehen
und
seine Trainingswaffe anlegen
und den Level 1 Style
auf die Leiste ziehen,
damit man noch was angreifen kann.
Wir machen jetzt mal ein bisschen so,
wie nennt man das so schön?
Guided Playthrough.
Also das wird jetzt denke ich so
5-6 Stunden dauern,
dass wir 45 plus sind.
dann hat man alles wichtige gesehen aber wir wollen glaube ich stimmt ich
sollte vielleicht mal meine meine xp leiste einblenden level xp was war so
questgeber reden zum nächsten questgeber gehen wenn ihr neu seid würde ich das tatsächlich
empfehlen durchzulesen weil ihr kriegt man bisschen was erklärt an eine rüstung und alles
mögliche ich werde das jetzt einfach nur durch klicken mit j macht ihr quest journal auf und
jetzt haben wir diese auf ich glaube ich habe vergessen die quest anzunehmen
so viel gelabert 0
trainer und als galde immer speed trainieren was ich jetzt gerade verkackt
habe ich glaube speed gibt es auf level 2 oder level 3
Deswegen ist Skalda auch so beliebt, weil man Runspeed hat.
Battle Songs.
Jawohl, nice.
Ich muss mal gucken, wie ich die leisten hatte.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ich pack's jetzt einfach mal hier so drauf.
Eine Neuerung, by the way.
In Season.
In Season 3 ist Skaldon und Minnesänger und Baden können jetzt bis zu 8 Songs gleichzeitig spielen.
Wie auch immer das Roleplay technisch funktionieren soll, dass ein Sänger 8 Songs zusammen singt oder 8 Instrumente gleichzeitig spielt, whatever.
Du kannst jetzt 8 Songs gleichzeitig spielen.
Was heißt, ich kann meinen Speed Song und meinen Heilsong gleichzeitig anmachen.
Bam, bam.
Also, letzte Season waren es nur zwei Songs.
Meiner Meinung nach, ganz ehrlich, finde ich das sogar schon zu OP,
weil Skalde ist eines der besten Klassen im Spiel, gerade für Solo-Play.
Also, ich würde sogar sagen, Skalde ist die beste Solo-Klasse im Spiel.
manch einer würde jetzt sagen, irgendwelche Schleicher
und sonst wie, aber Schleicher ist eine extra
Kategorie für sich, aber auch besser als das
also meiner Meinung nach ist Skalde
die beste Solo-Klasse, die es gibt
und
die war schon
mehr oder weniger die beste Solo-Klasse
letzte Season
und da konnte sie nur zwei Songs
gleichzeitig spielen und jetzt kannst du
acht Songs gleichzeitig spielen
das heißt, du kannst alles abhaben
du kannst
Speed abhaben, Heal abhaben,
Endo Reduce abhaben, Resis
abhaben, Power, Mana, Song
abhaben. Du kannst alles abhaben. Das ist eigentlich
OP as fuck, wenn ihr mich fragt.
Weil Skalde war eh schon krass.
Aber gut, ich will mich mal als Skalden
Main nicht beschweren,
dass das so ist.
Weil, ne, warum sollte ich mich über OP
für meine eigene Klasse beschweren?
Ist ja nicht blöd.
Ziehen wir mal hier euch an.
Kopf.
Nicht wundern, dass alle so gleich aussehen.
Das liegt daran, weil das Level Rüstung ist im Endeffekt.
Level Rüstung sieht immer gleich aus.
Auf Level 50 kann man relativ gut individualisieren.
Gerade wenn man sich die Skins in Thor besorgt.
Da sieht jeder ein bisschen anders aus.
Quest next, zack. Boah, die gehen aber gut ab hier.
Zack, neue Axt. Wir werden übrigens nicht Axt specken.
So.
Schuhe, Arme, ich brauche noch Handschuhe und Beine brauche ich noch.
Craywolf sollen wir killen, okay.
Easy.
Geh, Bim.
So.
Und das ist auch ein weiterer Punkt,
warum Skald eine gute Einstiegsklasse ist.
Skald hat nicht allzu viel zu skillen.
Ja, guckt, man hat im Prinzip nur zwei Möglichkeiten, was man speckt.
Realistisch betrachtet.
Und zwar, ich trainiere mal.
Im Prinzip hat man Battle Songs.
Das hat man gefälligst fast immer auf Level zu halten als Skalde.
Man darf es nur mal zwischenzeitlich vernachlässigen, ein bisschen in Waffe zu specken.
Aber ansonsten sollte das immer so hoch wie möglich sein.
Battle Songs und dann sucht man sich eine Waffe aus, die man spielen will.
Und zwar Waffen kann man sich aussuchen, möchte man gerne Axt, Hammer oder Schwert spielen.
Nachdem wir in Midgard sind, hat das den Vorteil, dass es nur eine Skill-Linie gibt an Waffen für Einhand und Zweihand.
Das heißt, wenn ich Axt specke, kann ich sowohl einhändige Äxte als auch zweihändige Äxte gleich gut verwenden.
Genauso wie mit Hammer.
Ich sag mal, die Meta-Skull-Skillung, das was die Leute spielen, die Optimize spielen wollen, die skillen Hammer.
die skillen 50 skill punkte auf songs und 39 auf hammer den rest auf parieren
das ist so die so soll die die meta skillung
habe ich jetzt was vergessen ach nee das ist für den typ der die quest vergessen
hat okay ich wollte gerade sagen wir sind doch eigentlich schon durch
Hab ich irgendwie was hier?
Ja.
Ja, und ein weiterer Vorteil, wenn man ein bisschen seine Craft-Skills gelevelt hat, ist,
ich kann jetzt hergehen und Equipment, was ich nicht brauche,
Kann ich salvagen.
Das kann ich in Einzelteile zerlegen.
Was sehr nice ist, weil es mir Gold gibt, wenn ich die Einzelteile verkaufe.
Bei Low-Level-Rüstung ist es...
Moment, Handschuhe brauche ich noch.
Bei Low-Level-Rüstung ist es egal, ehrlich.
Die paar Kupfer, die man von Low-Level-Rüstung kriegt, ich zeige es euch jetzt einfach nur, ist das wurscht.
Ob ich jetzt hier das salvage oder nicht, das ist vollkommen irrelevant.
Die paar Kupfer.
aber ich mache das jetzt einfach mal, dass das Inventar ein bisschen leerer ist.
Man bekommt auch, wenn man neu ist mit seinem Char,
kriegt man hier so einen Personal Bindstone, der kann zwei Sachen.
Der kann einmal ein Portal erstellen und einmal,
also einmal sich zum Bindestern teleportieren und einmal ein Townportal erstellen.
Das ist im Prinzip wie man es aus Diablo kennt.
Man kann rein zum Bindestern und dann wieder zurück, wo man herkommt.
Und ihr seht, ich habe noch kaum Spells oder irgendwas.
Ja.
Das Wichtigste,
also was ihr immer machen müsst,
egal mit welchem Char. Und das ist jetzt eine Sache,
das unterscheidet jemand, der ganz
neu ist, zu jemand, der ein bisschen
Ahnung von Daokat ist.
Das erste, was ihr macht, auf Level
5, wenn wir schon Level 5 sind,
wir sind noch nicht Level 5, das erste, was ihr macht,
sobald ihr Level 5 werdet,
ist folgendes.
Zeige ich euch jetzt,
sobald ich die Quest abgegeben habe.
Sobald wir stehen, zeige ich euch das, was ihr machen müsst.
So.
Stehen noch nicht.
Aber Shani ist gut.
Shani weiß, wie es geht.
Also, es ist unschätzbarer Vorteil,
wenn man einen Heiler in der Gruppe hat,
der erstens den Charge spielen kann
und zweitens gerne vorläuft.
Da kann man gerade ein bisschen
gerade ein bisschen Kopf
abschalten.
Und jetzt kommt das, was ihr
unbedingt machen müsst, sobald ihr Level 5 seid.
Ihr geht rein,
schreibt slash train in den Chat.
Dann geht das Trainier-
Fenster auf und dann,
ihr könnt skillen, aber was ihr machen müsst, ist,
ihr geht auf RAs und dann geht ihr
runter, bis dann da
Longwind kommt irgendwo.
Longwind.
Und das skillt ihr auf 1.
ihr kriegt nämlich mit level 5 ein realm point und das wird gespeckt das sorgt dafür dass ihr
20 prozent weniger endo braucht beim sprinten das ist legit das wichtigste was ihr in den
ersten paar level machen müsst level 5 instant longwind trainieren weil guck ich kann jetzt
viel länger sprinten schon seht ihr viel länger das ist das ist wichtig longwind trainieren
der heiler macht macht hektik aber es ist gut dann geht es wenigstens vorwärts weil
ansonsten dieses rum ewig lange rum gegeben bekam ich auch nicht ab so beine hier zack
Ich würde sagen, wir nehmen jetzt das Town-Portal und geben...
...geben Quests ab.
Oder?
Berg hoch.
Quests abgeben.
Und jetzt fehlt uns ein Level.
Oder?
Ja.
Uns fehlt ein bisschen XP.
Für Level 7.
Guck, wir sind Level 6.
Wir sind Level 6 und
ja, quasi 90%.
Ja.
ja da sieht sehr nach rumrennen aus ich weiß meine mutter hat früher mal gesagt
dass ich das gespielt habe wie gesagt spiel ist ein über 20 jahren hat immer
gesagt rennst du wieder durch die gegend als sie mich da spielen hat sehen
ok level 7 und wieder zurück
oh ne jetzt hat er gepullt. Okay was muss man noch killen?
Welches Spiel hat meine Mutter am meisten gehasst als ich es gespielt habe?
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ich vermute mal unausgesprochenerweise super
nintendo spiele mit nervigem soundtrack weil ich hatte halt war in dem
wohnzimmer den fden den fernseher an da gab es ja schon ein paar spiele die
nervige sich wiederholen des sounds hatten jemand davon aus dass wir die am
meisten gast haben
ansonsten
Ich weiß nicht, das ist eine gute Frage.
Also ich muss sagen, die fand das eigentlich nie schlimm, dass ich lange vorm Computer gesessen habe.
Zumindest solange ich in der Schule nicht komplett verschissen habe.
Ich würde sagen, also neben dem Spiel mit nervigen Soundtracks...
Ich glaube, Darok fand die an sich nicht gut.
Weil ich da manchmal halt
Samstag nachts
um 3 Uhr aufgestanden bin, um zu raiden.
Das fand die nicht gut an sich.
Aber ansonsten muss ich sagen,
hatte ich da nie
großartig Probleme mit meiner Mutter, dass wir uns irgendwie
gestritten hätten wegen irgendwelchen Spielen.
und unsachen ja
das ging ging gut klar
kann man nichts sagen
ich spiele
so über den commander der eier da drüben auf dem berg irgendwo rum
Oder nie da vorne aber auf dem berg auch whatever da ist ich muss mich erst mal umgewöhnt da ich jetzt nicht hier klicken muss und heilen
Habe ich schon protect für unsere heiler
Wenn du kippst sommermann von mir noch was dann noch group leader und second i don't kick randall people
So
Ja, das richtig optimiste Level Group, Alter
Ich glaube, wir sind sehr zackig heute
Ich hoffe, wir kriegen ein bisschen gute BG-PVP-Action
Gleich noch
So, finish
Next Quest
Jetzt muss ich den Albion Commander killen.
Genau.
Wo ist Shunny?
Da ist Shunny.
So, danach müssen wir kurz skillen.
Kann man trainieren, während man im Boot sitzt?
Das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
oder wahrscheinlich habe ich schon ausprobiert aber vergessen glaube es geht nicht glaubt man
kann nicht trainieren während man im boot setzt also nicht so lange sich das boot bewegt so lange
es einfach nur steht und wartet geht das glaube ich aber hier optimist train battle songs also
ich brauche auf level 6 gibt es in town okay it's the best game ever
es ist nicht nur ein random streamed titel ich fühle mich wirklich, dass es das beste Spiel je
zumindest das beste mmo je, vielleicht nicht das beste Spiel je, aber das beste mmo-rpg aller Zeiten
Ich denke, das Spiel hat eine gewonnen, wie das beste PvP-Spiel des Jahrhunderts oder so etwas.
Und es ist verdient.
das game das leute auch schon seit 30 jahren spielen noch nicht max gill rank sind also
seit 30 jahren oder 20 jahren durchgängig und immer noch nicht max gill haben und so was ich
habe letztens mal was drüber gelesen ja classic classic runescape er never played ultima online
Ich habe den World of Warcraft-Klassiker gespielt.
last year and i must say it's world of warcraft the world and the pve group content it's nice
and all but my heart is in dark age of camelot and will remain in dark age of camelot
also ich glaube wir haben es wir müssen die quest abgeben so passt
so jetzt haben wir das tutorial gebiet fertig
jetzt gehen wir aus dem tutorial gebiet raus und lassen uns unser level 10 quest
reward geben ja quest nochmal buffs nochmal anklicken porten nach mulan
was mit your first time no i started on albion
ich denke dann ging ich zu hip und der letzte realm ich gespielt habe war mit aber jetzt ist es
Main Limit.
So, wo ist der Quest-Dude?
Hier.
Weiß.
Oh, wir gehen gleich.
Wir gehen gleich ins BG.
Okay, nice.
Das geht ja gut.
Alter, ich brauche eine Waffe.
Ich habe nämlich meine Waffe.
Sekunde.
Moment.
Ich habe nicht meine Waffe gekauft.
Battlecrowns.
Also ich brauche auf jeden Fall.
Okay, ich...
Leute, das, was ihr jetzt hier macht, solltet ihr mit Skalde übrigens nicht machen.
Ich gehe auf Schwert, weil es den niedrigsten Torn-Style hat.
Äh, Schwert ist nicht gut für...
Für Skalde.
Nur so. Nur so angemerkt.
Äh, Hammer ist die beste Speck.
Yeah, I don't like the new models.
Ich denke die alten Modelle haben mehr Charakter.
Äh, Moment.
Ein Übungs-PVP-Gebiet.
Und das ist immer super besucht.
Auch jetzt.
Gerade jetzt.
Während Season Start.
Weil es gibt nicht nur massig XP für PvP-Kills.
sondern es gibt auch noch die Möglichkeit hier kleine PvP- äh, PvM-Tasks, so PvP-PvM-Tasks zu erledigen.
Und das gibt richtig krass XP.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall, wir müssen auf jeden Fall jetzt ein bisschen was killen, denn ich brauch Bounty Points.
Wenn man Gegner killt, soll ich vielleicht auch noch erzählen, ihr merkt, das Game hat Mechanics und es hört einfach nicht auf, bekommt man...
Wie geht's denn überhaupt?
Weiß nicht.
man bekommt punkte für gegner killen man bekommt rain points und man bekommt bekommt bounty points
von bounty points kann man sich equipment kaufen gerade beim leveln ist das gut und später so ein
paar kleinigkeiten und von von rain points kann man sich fähigkeiten kaufen mit das sind teilweise
mit die besten skills die sie im spiel gibt hier das ist das wo wir uns auch freund longwind 1
geholt haben von dem von dem ersten rand point den wir bekommen haben mit level 5 normalerweise
kriegt man points nur im pvp aber level 5 gibt es gibt es eine ausnahme bekommt man einen und
davon haben uns longwind gekauft das reduziert wie viel wir beim sprinten an endo verbrauchen
das ist für alle nahkämpfer und generell für jeden für jede klasse deswegen merkt euch falls
ihr anfangt auf level 5 immer longwind 1 becken immer egal welche klasse egal ob nahkampf support
cast immer noch mit 1 danach mehr braucht man aber nicht mehr brauchen wir nicht so aber von
weiteren points kann man sich alles mögliche kaufen es gibt die richtig gute fähigkeiten
zum beispiel als gal kann ich speed of sound skill irgendwo da steht das da speed of sound
das, okay, super komplizierte
Beschreibung,
whatever, kostet 5 Punkte
und macht 10 Sekunden immun, die gesamte
Gruppe, die gesamte Gruppe
immun gegen jeglichen CC.
Solange man
nicht selber angreift.
Also, sprich, man ist komplett immun gegen
Sleeps, gegen Stunts,
gegen Roots, gegen alles für 10 Sekunden.
Das ist eines
der OP-sten Fähigkeiten, die es gibt.
By the way, Leute,
ist der Stream hell genug?
Ich habe vorher ein bisschen
heller gemacht hier.
Ah, nee.
Habe ich nicht. Jetzt habe ich ein bisschen
heller gemacht. Sag doch was. Jetzt ist besser, oder?
Jetzt sieht man wenigstens was.
Jetzt ist auch gerade Nacht.
Aber ich glaube, so ist es ganz brauchbar.
Jetzt erkennt man wenigstens was.
Ich guck mir das gerade im Vorschau an.
Ich glaube, das ist okay so.
RF-Programmer, was sagst du?
Noch ein Ticken heller?
Weil es ist Nacht.
Oder ist so jetzt okay?
Also sind anscheinend keine Gegner.
Doch, hier oben sind Gegner.
10% mehr?
Okay.
Da.
Ich brauche unbedingt ein Schwert.
Ich habe ja nichts.
Ich habe meine Einhandstarterwaffe.
Keck, wait, man.
Und die anderen habe ich gesalvaged.
Sehr schlau von mir.
Hyper IQ Play.
Aber ist egal, nach den ersten paar Punkten
Kann ich mir eine Waffe kaufen
Kaufe ich mir ein zweihändler Schwert
So wie das sein muss
Habe ich schon ein Protect für die Heiler?
Wow, wow, what the fuck
Alter
MonkaS
Was für ein Spielhaus gewesen gerade
Habt ihr das auch gehabt gerade?
What the hell
Ich hab mal die Grafik-Enhancers
ausgeschaltet.
Was war das denn gerade?
What the fuck?
Okay, das macht's gerade ziemlich kaputt.
Okay.
Na, whatever.
Keine Ahnung, was da gerade kaputt war.
Aber ich könnte, ich könnte ein Schwert echt gebrauchen, ne?
So ein Schwert wäre nice.
Hammer is the way to go.
Das ist richtig, aber Hammer hat erst später einen Town-Style.
Also Town brauchst du, falls irgendwas auf deine Heiler haut, dass du es wegkriegst davon.
Low-Level finde ich Schwert ganz gut. Außerdem bin ich Schwert-Fanboy.
Ich bin, glaube ich, der einzige High-ER-Skull auf dem Server, der Schwert spielt.
Ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt nicht, warum.
Außer, dass es mir optisch gut gefällt.
Okay, anscheinend gehen wir auf den hier.
Außer, dass es mir optisch ganz gut gefällt.
weil hammer hat eindeutig die besten styles axt hat die zweitbesten styles
und den besten damage also schwert hat eigentlich gar nichts wo haut jetzt
eigentlich drauf da den da oder welchen welchen machen die jetzt eigentlich
den da pull out ok pull out kein problem
renne jetzt einfach weg oder wie oder wie ist pull out gedacht
also ich kann ja out pullen das ist kein problem ich renne jetzt mit speed weg
Ich renne jetzt mit Speed ein bisschen um euch drum herum
So, fertig
Okay
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie lange ich in der Gruppe drinne bin
Unser Heiler ist super elitär drauf, Alter.
Ich meine, ich finde es gut, dass es zack, zack geht.
Ja, aber jetzt quasi zu drohen, die Group zu disbanden,
bloß weil es ein paar Leute im Low-Level verkackt haben.
Also das ist wirklich schon...
Man darf nicht vergessen, gerade wenn hier...
Wenn hier Low-Level-Group ist,
die Leute haben auch angefangen, erst das Spiel zu spielen.
Oftmals ist das ja nicht.
Übertreibt halt mal nicht.
ja das ist manchmal so ein bisschen die schatten seite da habe ich kann ich
irgendwas trainieren nächste nächste gibt's man das soll unter wasser atmen
buff das gut
Ja, dass sie da eben rein Aeoid haben, war halt ziemlich bescheuert, ne?
Also die haben ja alles angehittet und rausgehauen.
Normalerweise ist das Easy Mode.
So ein paar Low-Level-Mobs hier.
Aha.
Ich hab einen Umhang.
Also ich spiele das schon lange nicht mehr so, als geht es da um mein Leben bei.
also bis gegen bisschen optimist habe ich ja nix aber muss der level
group nicht die leute raus schmeißen weil sie meinen falschen mob angeklickt haben
aber gibt es gibt es halt manchmal so
Ich kann es in gewisser Weise schon verstehen.
Gerade wenn man es einfach nur schnell hinter sich bringen will.
Ich habe mich auch teilweise
früher übertrieben aufgeregt.
Oh, guck mal, wir haben einen Chami,
der ziziert.
Hock Champ, Alter.
Habe ich eigentlich mittlerweile
ein Schwert irgendwo?
Schwert-Drop?
als vorbringende waffe klar
wir mit kein damage machen das ding stirbt nicht
Na endlich!
Deadge!
So, nice!
Sagt next!
Ja, ähm...
Großartige XP macht man
eigentlich in Battlecrowns nicht
durch das Killen von Mobs,
sondern... Ah, guck mal, ich hab zumindest
mal ne andere Axt!
Eine Zweihand-Axt, noch besser!
Auf alle Fall, aber was geht mit der Musik ab gerade?
dürfte auch mal wieder tag werden man sieht so wenig max wieder am streamen ja
haben wir mal kurz das ist das ist markt aus dem
Riven oder wer? Wer will hier Riven? Ober Assister Man sein.
Haben wir Tokens? Wir haben Tokens. Wollen keine Tokens.
Hyped auf das neue Battlefield.
ähm
Ja
Ich ich ich ich halte mich ich halte mich zurück halb zu sein weil
Ich war auch auf battlefield 20 42 halbt und was ist am ende rausgekommen ja
Es hat sich überhaupt nicht gelohnt darauf halb zu sein ich finde die leaks das sieht ganz vielversprechend aus gerade dass es mal wieder nach
einen ordentlichen, normalen Battlefield
aussieht, ja, ohne Operator
und ohne abgedrehtem Future-Shit und
Wingsuits und
hast du nicht gesehen.
Aber trotzdem,
diesmal
warte ich. Ich warte,
bis das
raus ist.
Ich warte, bis das raus ist.
Oh, please, ich brauche ein Schwert, Leute.
Ich habe nicht mal Axt gespeckt.
Du bist genauso gehypt wie von neuen Indiana Jones.
Also gar nicht, ne?
Hey, hat jemand von euch
das letzte Indiana Jones Spiel gespielt?
The Great Circle oder so, gell?
Das habe ich mir ernsthaft überlegt,
ob ich mir das kaufen soll,
weil das sah schon cool aus.
Das hatte was, ja.
Das hatte was.
Ich mochte auch,
dass es weniger Shooter ist,
sondern mehr
Stels und Adventure.
das fand ich gut das kann man anziehen
ich muss mal ganz kurz was checken während wir hier laufen in den schar plan muss auch
kurz kurz ob speed gibt es auf level 13 es kalte und ingame gucken dass ich nichts verpasse
Ach übrigens, es gibt einen Bug.
By the way, wenn ihr ganz fiese Bug-Abuser sein wollt,
dann lauft ihr seitlich im Wasser und sprintet dabei.
Guckt mal.
Ich bin viel schneller seitlich wie vorwärts.
Okay, Quade.
Warum das so ist, das können euch nur die Daok-Götter sagen.
Man weiß es nicht.
easy easy hackermans
splixxer reich für den sub
Wir machen also null Damage.
Wir hätten doch einen Huni mitnehmen sollen noch.
In dem BG ist anscheinend nichts los gerade.
Ich sehe nur Mids.
Keine Gegner oder sonst was.
Ah, guck mal.
Der sucht auch ein Armenschwert.
Ja, ich auch.
Ich habe ein Schild.
Geil.
Das ist das Einzige, was man als Skalde eigentlich erstmal nicht braucht.
Beste.
Oh ja.
Hör mich mal nicht beschweren.
Ich kaufe mir gleich
ein Bounty-Point-Schwert.
Aber guck mal, es hat sich schon gelohnt.
Wir haben den kleinen Endu-Chunt.
Ich habe Long Wind.
Wir können eine ganze Ecke sprinten.
bevor mir die Puste ausgeht.
Wenn ich jetzt gleich nochmal ein End Reduce bekomme,
dann können wir noch länger sprinten.
Ich glaube, wir wollen die Surters machen,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ich glaube, wir wollen die Surters machen.
Zehn Stück.
Wenn man super optimist ist,
wenn man super optimist sein will,
Deserter-Quests sind zwischen Battle-Crowns gültig.
Also sprich, ich kann Deserters hier killen und im nächsten Battle-Crown die Quest abgeben.
So kann man quasi eine Quest mitnehmen von einem ins nächste Battle-Crown.
Und hat ein bisschen XP, aber das ist halt so ein Ding, wo man sagen muss,
das macht es jetzt nicht fett.
Müssen wir die killen überhaupt?
Ah ja, müssen wir.
Ich zeige euch nochmal das seitliche
Strafe.
Guck mal. So, also. Normalerweise,
wenn ich vorwärts laufe, bin ich so...
Ja, auf.
Wenn ich vorwärts laufe, bin ich so schnell hier.
Und guck mal, wenn ich seitwärts laufe...
Ja, also ihr kennt hier so versus so.
Und man kann sogar
seitlich strafen, vorwärts laufen.
Sieht dann so aus.
Sieht halt ein bisschen
Bein amputiert aus, aber es funktioniert
Und guck mal, ich bin schneller als alle
Die vormals laufen
Bugabuser
Zu meiner Verteidigung
Kann ich aber nur sagen
Das ist im späteren Game nahezu irrelevant
Weil es kaum noch solche
Halbtiefen Gewässer gibt
wo das zum Tragen kommt, die Mechanics.
Max wieder am Cheaten.
Fuck. Live on Stream,
Leute.
Live on Stream.
Überführt.
Ja, so ein Zweihänderschwert
wäre schon eine coole Sache.
Guckt, Leute. Passt mal auf.
ich würde nicht mal sagen dass das eigentlich back das ist das ist so weird weirde dark
mechanics einfach nur ich musste mal reloggen dass ich mein ja es ist irgendwie kaputt weil
man grafik enhancement zeug hat irgendwie den geist aufgegeben ja ans trinken erinnern stimmt
mache ich gerade musste nicht über die man eigentlich dachte wollte die stadt
auf der rechten seite hier die kommen direkt auf uns zu recht sind
gegner da vor uns eigentlich gerade hier jetzt da an die diese ort ist viel zu
viele viel zu viele und high level nennen da machen wir nichts
wer sie jetzt übrigens vielleicht fragt woher ich das weiß dass die gegner
High Level sind. Das ist auch so eine Dark
Mechanic, die nirgendwo erklärt wird.
Wenn ihr den Gegner anklickt
und der gelb ist, dann ist
der ungefähr auf eurem Level.
Wenn der orange ist,
das gilt übrigens für Mobs genauso.
Und es gilt auch für Keeps
und sowas.
Also das ist ein High Level Keep.
Das hat schon ein bisschen hochgelevelt.
Also in der Regel, gelb ist immer so
ungefähr auf eurem Level. Orange ist
ein bisschen über eurem Level.
Rot
ist deutlich über eurem Level
und lila ist
sehr hoch über eurem Level.
Das gleiche gibt es auch noch mit blau.
Bisschen unter eurem Level.
Und grün
weit unter eurem Level und grau
so weit unter eurem Level, dass ihr nicht mehr mehr
XP für kriegt.
Guck, die sind rot hier, die Mobs.
Die sind, die sind, die sind, also
rote und
rot-lila rote mobs mit ein paar lila mobs dazwischen sind meistens wenn man klassische
xp gruppen macht so das beste für für achter group gibt gut xp für achter group ja und da wie
es vielleicht auch schon gesehen habt im vergleich zu vielen moderne rennmo ich glaube bei final
Fantasy sind es sogar nur
Vierergruppen. Kann das sein?
Xiv?
Final Fantasy Xiv?
Also was ist 14?
Das sind sogar nur
Vierergruppen in Dungeons, gell? Und bei Raids
8er oder wie war das? Ich kann mich da dunkel dran erinnern.
Vierergruppen. Du hast einen Support,
einen Tank, zwei DDs.
Oder?
Weiß nicht. In World of Warcraft sind es Fünfergruppen.
angeblich sind die entwicklung da sind als aber rote guckt die sind jetzt sie sind über uns hier
die sind und gerade leute in niedrigen levels muss man sagen in niedrigen levels macht macht
level unterschied im pvp einiges aus später später auch noch aber ich sag mal ob man jetzt 47 gegen
49, dann hat der schon
auch einen Vorteil, aber nicht mehr so krass.
Aber 5 gegen 9
oder so, oder 5 gegen 6, oder
Level, lass es übertrieben sein, Level 1
gegen Level 2, das ist halt
ein Riesenunterschied. Ich glaube, die Fighten, kann das sein?
Fighten die da vorne?
Ne, das sind nur, das sind nur
Mids.
Man muss ja immer ein bisschen gucken, wir darf es nicht vergessen, wir sind in einem
Battleground, also sprich, hier gibt es wirklich Gegner
und man kann auch PvP-mäßig
gekillt werden
da vorne gelbe alp und rote alp aber nicht so viele da gehen wir jetzt drauf
oder gibts ihn in your face
ob du machst nix ja ja es dann mich ruhig ich gehe auf den klärer erklärt
Ah, der Clary wird schon interrupted.
Okay.
Aber wir machen den Clary down.
Clary killen ist nie verkehrt.
Wer heilt den denn noch?
Ach, der Ordi.
Ist das ein Ordi?
Ja, der Ordi hat den geheilt.
Okay.
Nicht ganz sicher.
Ja, und so killt man ein paar Gegner.
Und wenn man fies ist als Galde,
dann, das mach ich jetzt nicht,
dann leech mal mit
seinen DDS alle Kills ab.
Und mach den letzten Hit, dass man
im Battle-Log auftaucht.
Best Game ever!
Yes.
At least best MMO ever.
Also das, was ihr gerade gesehen habt, waren keine Mobs.
Das waren echte Spieler und Gegner.
Ich hoffe, dass ich jetzt genug Bounty Points habe,
mir eine Waffe zu kaufen.
Wo stehen die Bounty Points?
Hier.
Ein fucking Bounty Point hat das Ganze gegeben.
What the f...
Davon kriege ich aber keine.
Davon kriege ich aber kein Schwert.
Level 12!
So, kriege ich jetzt einen neuen
Speed?
Ne, aber Endo-Reduce.
Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Bounty Merge 3 kostet das.
Fuck, so viel habe ich nicht.
so also jetzt gehen wir erst mal hier hin und packen uns die restlichen darauf endo reviews
battle moment ich habe es gemacht so richtig
best game ever
Ja, also ein Schwert wäre extrem nice.
Weil aktuell kann ich nicht wirklich Damage machen, nahkampftechnisch.
Ich meine, ich habe eine Level 1 Style und eine Kack-Axt.
Ja, du willst sie machen.
Wir können übrigens jetzt fast schon endlos sprinten.
Ich habe mein Endo-Reduce an, wir haben vom Schammy Endo und ich habe Longwind, das ich weniger brauche zum Sprinten.
Geben wir unsere Tickets jetzt ab.
Machen wir.
In jedem BG droppen von Gegnern und Mobs, droppen so Tokens.
Die Tokens kann man bei den Zelten eintauschen.
und wenn genug Leute
Tokens eingetauscht haben,
dann spawnt ein großer Mob,
der einem hilft, das Festungstor aufzuhauen.
Und
wenn man eine Festung
erobert in einem Battleground,
dann gibt es
ein komplettes Level für.
Wir könnten eigentlich die Deserter
jetzt schnell machen. Wow!
Alter, sind hier viele mit.
The fuck?
Hält er gar nicht mehr auf
Ach, das ist ein Hip Keep
Ja, dann killt doch nicht den Albion Siege
Leute, seid ihr blöd?
Don't, nein, killt doch nicht den Siege Giant
Ihr Kanknoobs
Also, der schlägt normalerweise aufs Tor
Und hilft uns das Tor aufzumachen
Es ist jetzt, okay
Kurz zur Erklärung, es gibt ja drei Reiche
Ja, so
Das Keep gehört Hibernia.
Wir sind Midgard.
Und die Leute aus Albion haben so einen Siege-Giant beschworen.
Das ist natürlich für uns ein Mob, den wir angreifen können.
Aber wir sind ja blöde, den anzugreifen.
Weil der schlägt ja auch das Tor von einem Hibernia-Keep auf.
Das ist unserer.
Also es ist total dumm, den zu killen.
Aber die sehen...
Ha! Anklickbar!
Damage, Damage, Damage, Damage!
Das ist richtig blöd!
Wenn die den einfach nicht killen,
zieht der mobs auf sich und hilft uns vom zweiten tor aber nope low brain am
start am start
jetzt kennen wir den ort in jedem kieb also in der festung gibt es den ort als
Boss, wenn man den killt. Zack.
Jeder kriegt ein Level.
You've reached
Level 13. Nice.
Nächster Speed.
Excellent.
Rush out, kill. Oh,
Laps am Start. Aber ich renne da nicht
als erstes rein. Ich warte, bis
Pamits rauskommen. Und jetzt
gib ihm in your
face. Okay,
Clary, der will einfach sterben.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Ich rush da nicht
rein.
Das haben die doch alles von Guild Wars 2 geklaut.
Guild Wars 2 war später, aber ich weiß,
Tucci Bates nur, ne?
Tucci Bates, wo hab ich mein Metz eigentlich gerade
geklickt? Ich hab den auf Mausbutton.
Stehen bleiben!
Boah, ist das geil, dass ich
8 Chance gleichzeitig haben kann, man.
Das ist ja richtig, das ist richtig
Spock!
Du bleibst hier.
Du bleibst auch hier.
Gucken, ob ich noch mehr kriege.
Oh.
Okay.
Ich geh mal mit unserem Heiler,
dass unser Heiler Speed hat.
Wenn ihr neu in dem Game seid
und eine Sache
beachten wollt, was PvP angeht,
guckt, wo euer Gruppenleader ist
oder am besten, besten Fall ist es der Heiler.
Guckt nach eurem Heiler
und supportet euren Heiler, wenn es geht.
Also sprich, wenn euer Heiler Speed braucht
zum Wegrennen als Skalde, guckt, dass ihr in Range seid.
Wenn ihr nicht gerade mit Interrupten vorne
irgendwie beschäftigt.
Was ist mit dem Dude los?
Und schaut
auf eurem Map.
Ihr seht ja hier, jeder von der Gruppe hat
eine Zahl, hat so einen Kreis mit einer Zahl,
dass es nicht zu weit auseinander geht.
Guckt, dass ihr als Skalde Leute wieder ranbringt
mit Speed und sowas. Schaut, dass ihr immer
nach Möglichkeit dafür sorgt, dass eure Gruppe
gut zusammen agieren kann.
Das kann jeder machen.
Jeder kann darauf gucken. Und dadurch
werden auch Random-Gruppen viel, viel besser.
Du hast als Random-Gruppe immer noch keine Chance
gegen eine gut eingespielte Gruppe.
Sehr schwierig. Aber trotzdem.
Da kommt mal ein Char.
Achtung, an den klitschen wir uns jetzt ran.
guck dir die gucke
oh ne
ach ne wir sollen sticken und sprinten ok
Okay.
Würdest du sagen, das ist dein Maingame, wo du meist Stunden reingesteckt hast im Jahr?
Naja, also, ich spiele es seit 20 Jahren und ich spiele es auch immer wieder zu jeder neuen Eden-Season und suchte da rein.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass es mein Maingame ist.
Von Stunden, die ich insgesamt in meinem Leben da drin versenkt habe.
Definitiv.
Gibt es kein Game, not even close.
Haben wir Dessertas fertig?
Zwei Stück.
Not even close.
Zwei Dessertas brauchen wir noch für die Quest.
Also ich spiele das jedes Season und dann wird durchgesuchtet für drei, vier Monate.
Und dann ein bisschen weniger.
Ich spiele nicht unbedingt jedes Season immer komplett bis zum Schluss, aber immer so die Hälfte und dann immer volle Suchtattacke.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn du mal so mein Lebens-Main-Game suchst, wo ich die meisten Stunden ever immer ein ganzes Leben drin verbracht habe, dann ist es eindeutig Dark.
Ha, ein Schwert.
Okay, es ist ein...
es ist zwar nur ein blaues schwert aber egal so dass der brauner achst juckt mich
schild und so juckt mich halt null das kann ich sogar ausziehen
wobei ich lasse es mal so alibi mäßig an so
man könnte das jetzt selbst aber das machen wir nicht weil low level zeug bringt eh so gut wie
nichts an an geld chat hat noch irgendjemand im kopf wie das sell makro
ist move move item
aber eben muss weitem ja muss einem sellback worden
Das meine ich ja das habe ich gesucht hoch hoch du machst nichts hier
Und im bade schnell gemetzter der bade muss auf jeden fall sterben
Okay ich helfe meinem bär sie den typ dazu kennen oder nicht was denn jetzt darauf wird
Wir haben es.
Der Bersi wollte unbedingt den
den Shield Tank.
Alter, das ist kill.
Wäre vielleicht gar nicht so eine schlechte Idee.
Der war blau.
Der ist normalerweise ein paar Hits weg.
Aber baden darfst du nicht freikasten lassen.
Also solltet ihr mal in einem BG spielen
und einen Bade sehen,
der muss
interrupted werden, sonst fickt er euch.
Ihr müsst natürlich erstmal erkennen, dass es ein Bade ist.
Das verstehe ich, das ist nicht so einfach.
Da Dark ist ein Spieler, brauchst du relativ
viel, so generell, so Knowledge.
Man erkennt es aber relativ easy mit der Zeit.
Okay, turnen wir das jetzt in.
Okay
Kann ich, ja jetzt brauche ich auch kein Schwert mehr
Jetzt habe ich ja schon eins, oder?
Ne, ich kaufe nächsten BG
Kaufe ich ein Schwert
So, jetzt gehen wir nochmal die Surters holen
Denke ich mal
Hm, äh, Helm?
Irgendwas anderes
Das haben wir schon. Ich brauche noch Hose und Füße und wieder neue Handschuhe.
Große Füße und Handschuhe. Seht ihr irgendwas?
Große Füße, Handschuhe. Nö. Okay.
Ist auch Flow-Level nicht so wild.
Aber zumindest sollten wir jetzt schon ein bisschen Punkte gesammelt haben.
Ja, jetzt habe ich 26 Bounty Points.
Wenn wir noch ein bisschen was killen, kann ich mir nächstes BG volles Equipment kaufen.
Das haben die übrigens auf Eden auch sehr cool gemacht im Vergleich zu live.
Also wenn ihr levelt und gerade wenn ihr in Battle Crowns levelt, könnt ihr in jedem
neuen Battle Crown von Bounty Points, die ihr für das Killen von Gegnern bekommen habt,
könnt ihr euch Equipment kaufen und das Equipment ist immer gerade gut genug, dass ihr die wichtigsten
Punkte auf Max für euer jeweiliges Level habt.
Verstehst die Sorgwirkung?
Ich glaube, es gibt kein Game,
wo
krasse
Freude und Niederlage
so extrem beieinander liegen.
Doch Overwatch rankt vielleicht.
Aber
wenn man
Gegner wegrubbelt,
wie man das früher bei uns genannt hat,
auch wenn es
ein Fight ist, wo die Gegner was taugen,
fühlt man sich danach richtig geil.
Wenn man
zum zwölften Mal gekillt wird
oder chancenlos weggesnackt wird,
fühlt sich das richtig
nach Geflame.
Da ist man
immer kurz davor, alles und jeden
zu flamen.
Sind wir nicht aus dem BG eigentlich raus jetzt?
ist es wohl ein bisschen welches bg das jeden tag
jeden tag warm up hills of claret 14 inklusive 14 aber das sind gegner gegner bleibst du stehen
Okay, Moment. Ich muss mal kurz
seitwärts rennen, weil wir müssen
ja schneller sein.
Ja, ja.
Kaste mich ruhig an. Kaste mich. Ist gut.
Kaste mich ruhig an. Ist gut.
Er weiß es. Er weiß es.
Aber denkt dran.
Nicht overextenden, Leute.
Nicht overextenden. Seht ihr?
Seht ihr?
Zurück.
nicht overextenden.
Und das ist das, weswegen
reiner Nahkampf in Daok gar nicht so schwer ist.
Äh, sorry,
als Neue, ich vergesse den Satz.
Deswegen, warum Nahkämpfer in Daok
als Neueinsteiger gar nicht so einfach ist.
Ihr braucht ein gewisses Gefühl dafür,
wenn ihr gerade overextendet.
Also quasi, zu weit
in die Gegner lauft.
Nennt man overextenden in Daok, weil es für jeden Mist
irgendeinen Namen gibt.
und ich habe gerade krassover extended ich habe es aber glücklicherweise
rechtzeitig noch gemerkt was wo tatsächlich von der seite von der seite
wir brauchen speed ich brauche erstmal speed
achten jetzt müssen wir aufpassen hier die gegner ist da drüben wir müssen
gutes wir müssen auf jeden fall guten dass der bade der bade muss auf einer
leute leute leute leute leute ok bade steht sehr gut jetzt bin ich gestand
wird ich muss weg ich muss weg wie er sich kann nicht alleine in kasten
reinstellen auf jeden fall mal kurz fokussiert der mitmachen den ihr
interruppen der bade der bade der darf nicht frei sein und du darfst nicht
ich karsten kollege fragt ich kann ich habe die styles falsch rum verteilt
das ist ein heiler der will heil heilstellens machen darfst du aber nicht
darfst du nicht ob darfst du nicht du sollst gefällig stehen bleiben oder
der Bader. Ich muss rauslaufen.
Nice. Oh, wir... Alter!
Warum? The fuck? No!
Okay.
Ich geh mal zurück.
Okay. Gut.
Das ging gerade noch gut,
weil noch ein bisschen mehr Mids gekommen sind.
So, warte mal. Das muss auf 3.
Das muss da hin.
So.
Ich hab die ganze Zeit nicht angegriffen.
Weil ich hab den
Axtangriff mit einem Schwert
verwendet.
Ich wundere mich die ganze Zeit, warum macht es kein Damage?
Aber so ist gut.
Ich finde das mega nice, dass ich jetzt acht Sachen gleichzeitig anhaben kann.
So, habe ich noch irgendwas, was wir brauchen?
Battle Songs, Chant.
Ah, den Wasserbuff.
Ach, guck mal, da sind Albs.
Die wollen wieder gekillt werden.
Gibt es die?
Ich muss gucken, dass die Hexe...
Oh, das sind ganz schön viele.
Da kann ich nicht rein.
Also wir dürfen uns nicht
Sandwichen lassen und nicht
Nicht wegziehen lassen
Wie sonst was
Der wird gesnared
Und der wird abgestellt
Och nicht raushauen Leute
Da kommen noch mehr wir müssen zum Keep
Gucken was unsere Leute machen
Wir werden
Wir werden gesandwiched kann das sein
komm den kriegen wir schnell tot kauf noch hier auch leute auch einmal drauf
der wird sonst geheilt hallo ich habe keine ende mehr als geile
erstmal unseren typ hier supporten gucken dass schalke speed kriegt
charlie braucht speed dass die wieder hinten hin kommt
ja es ist immer schwierig im fight irgendwas zu erklären aber ich probiere es okay
Turn in Tokens.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das können wir machen.
Ja, wir haben wieder jede Menge Tokens
bekommen.
Tokens.
15.
Okay, wir sind
fertig.
Wir sind fertig mit dem BG.
Next, please.
Jetzt können wir uns eigentlich
weitmen und ins nächste BG.
Helm brauche ich nicht.
Genau.
Jetzt, okay, wir sehen, okay,
der Typ ist HighIQ, unser
Heiler. Der kennt den Deserter-Quest-Trick.
Wir haben jetzt die
Deserter-Quest gemacht. Also das waren diese Mobs,
die wir da unten hier am Wasser gekillt haben.
Da steht jetzt, dass wir die Quest abgeben können.
Aber, obwohl
da dran steht, das ist die Quest für den
10 bis 14er BG.
Deserter Quests sind BG-übergreifend.
Battleground-übergreifend.
Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt hier die
Quest zurückgeben würden,
dann kriegen wir keine XP, weil wir Level 5
sind im Level 14 Battleground.
Aber die
Quest geht rüber in den
nächsten BG.
Ah komm, wir killen nochmal was auf dem Weg.
Ah, der Bade.
Bade wird jetzt
weggeklatscht.
immer
okay den den one shot ich jetzt mal kurz den dude
das war sehr gut da kam jetzt auch zig zig mit nach willst du mal so wie viele
viele. Ah, Protect.
Sehr gut.
Komm mal, Shani hier.
Haben wir wie viele
Bounty Points?
Haben wir 44. Davon kann ich mir jetzt
richtig schönes Gear im nächsten Battleground
kaufen.
Genau. Und wie gesagt,
diese Deserter-Quest,
die gilt für alle Battlegrounds. Also auch wenn wir
die hier abgeschlossen haben, können wir die im nächsten
quasi abgeben. Das gibt ein bisschen
quasi minimal mehr XP.
Weil hier können wir sie nicht abgeben.
Hier bringt sie keine XP mehr.
Im nächsten Battleground zählt die immer noch.
Ihr werdet es sehen.
Das ist schon so Micro-Optimization.
Man braucht es nicht wirklich.
Battlegrounds.
Zack.
Next.
Okay.
So, jetzt kommt Battleground 15-19. Das ist killer low. Ich reloge mal schnell.
Ich reloge mal schnell, bin gleich wieder da.
So.
Relock.
Ich hoffe, dass das tut jetzt.
Ich hoffe, das reicht jetzt, wenn man da mal raus und wieder reingeht.
Sind Buffbots noch üblich?
Nein.
Auf Eden nicht.
Auf Eden sind Buffbots auch nicht mehr erlaubt.
Du darfst nur ein Account eingeloggt haben.
Beziehungsweise nur ein Spieler gleichzeitig ein Account.
Du darfst aus dem gleichen Haushalt mit deiner Frau spielen.
das ist kein problem also in game oder whatever nicht falsch stehen also darfst dich einloggen
ja mit mehreren pcs gleichzeitig das ist okay aber nicht quasi ohne zu spielen und brauchst
du nicht mal als buff npcs gibt ach wir machen kurz pause da kann ich ja trainieren also du
kannst dir einen account machen kostet nichts auf jeden das ist ein free schatz nicht live kann sein
account machen jeden tag hier jeden tag was seine count und kann so auslegen barth bots brauchst du
nicht weil es gibt überall solche enhancement npcs kannst du den kriegst ein set an bars die
bach sind natürlich ein bisschen schlechter wie gut gespeckte heiler barth so gut gespeckte shami
buffs ja klar sonst macht er die klassen quasi useless aber auch so nicht mehr und du bekommst
items mit charges also wenn ihr beispielsweise in den capt dex quick buff wichtig ist kannst
du ein item holen mit charges drauf brauchst keine bar spots mehr es heißt alles was du hier siehst
sind echte Spieler.
So. Okay.
Jetzt hol ich mir erstmal gutes, gutes, gutes
Equipment. Wie war das Ganze nochmal?
Move Item.
Eben Dark.
Äh, Move Item.
Move Item.
Okay, ich muss mir jetzt mal ein Cell-Makro machen.
Makro Cell.
Move Item.
Cell.
Und jetzt?
Bag 1.
Gab es nicht sowas wie All Bags?
Oder sowas?
Moment, das muss ich mal ausprobieren hier.
Mir irgendeinen Mist eingeben.
Move Item.
All Bags.
Okay, Makro Sell.
Move Item.
Sell.
All Bags.
Wobei ich da aufpassen muss, wenn ich später
Tränke und so habe, dann
ist das keine allzu gute Idee.
Okay, habe ich jetzt noch irgendwelche Sachen,
die ich hier behalten will? Nope.
Hier will ich nichts von behalten. Alles weg.
Sell.
Hä? Wie?
Dem kann man nichts verkaufen, dem Dude?
Kann man dem hier was verkaufen?
Dem kann man seinen ganzen Krempel verkaufen.
Okay, Tinder-Boxes.
Dick.
Tokens können wir löschen.
Okay.
So, dann kaufe ich mir mal hier ordentliche, ordentliche Rüsten.
Als erstes, wichtigste ist mal eine gescheite Waffe.
Long Sword, Great Sword.
Jawohl, gib ihm.
Bam.
Zack.
Können wir zerstören.
Dann kaufen wir noch...
Habe ich jetzt genug?
ich habe wie viele pointy points 37 da guck mal wie viel für wie viel das
reicht ich brauche auf jeden fall schuhe dings
Okay, ich kann mir alles kaufen bis...
Bis das Chest Piece...
Nice.
Chest Piece ist gelb, das passt.
So, endlich ordentliches Equip.
kann man den kram eigentlich das kammer selvischen gut das sind die an die kammer
alles selbst braucht man halt nicht weil dieses low level zeug das bringt nichts
an kohle aber wir sind diesen start schade
okay
Let's go, nächstes BG!
Also, Train sollten wir vielleicht noch machen.
wollte das gerade nicht egal ich habe zu viel gespeckt ich war noch ein level dann geht das
trainieren kann man übrigens in eden im vergleich zu live immer mit slash train
immer slash train solange man still steht und man kann auch respekte
solange man levelt, immer kostenlos.
Finde ich das echt ganz gut gemacht.
Die haben generell, muss man denen echt mal zugutehalten,
viel Quality of Life
in Eden eingebaut,
die sich nicht als Easy Mode anfühlt,
sondern quasi
die Sachen, die nervig waren,
verbessert.
Dementsprechend ist das richtig gut.
Also ich bin der Meinung, Eden ist mit Abstand die beste Dark-Version, die es je gegeben hat.
Und in Season 3 noch besser.
Ich wollte mir mit euch ja nochmal die Patch-Notes angucken, weil ich habe ja selbst die zweite Hälfte von Season 2, oder sagen wir mindestens das letzte Drittel von Season 2 nicht mal gespielt.
Und es hat sich noch so viel getan.
und und da wäre übrigens nicht da wenn das nicht ein spezielles system hätte wie man es gilt man
bekommt unterschiedlich viele skill points je nachdem welches level man erreicht also
die einfachste Variante ist,
man bekommt
einmal
Skill Points, das heißt, man bekommt immer so viele
Skill Points wie Level,
was man gerade erreicht hat, also Level 1 auf Level 2,
2 Skill Points, Level 3, 3 Skill Points und so weiter.
Aber die Klassen, um die
ein bisschen besser zu balancen,
bekommen unterschiedliche Klassen,
unterschiedliche Multiplier an Skill Points.
Also ich glaube, das Höchste, was es gibt,
ist mal 2,5, das heißt,
es gibt Klassen, die bekommen
Level mal 2,5 Skill Points.
Und können dementsprechend mehr specken.
Das sind meistens irgendwelche Hybridklassen,
die halt dann sonst nicht gut genug wären.
Und ab Level 40
bekommt man
bei jedem halben Level nochmal Skillpunkte.
Das heißt, ab 40 kriegt man eigentlich die meisten
Skillpunkte, um dann so
seine endgültige Skillung
reinzuhauen.
Und wenn man sich jetzt beispielsweise mal den Charplaner anguckt, wollte ich ja hier mal machen, Skalde zum Beispiel, man kann das ja alles schon im Browser lernen, wenn man das will.
Ja, Skalde speckt man 50 Battlesongs, das Skalde ist so ziemlich das einfachste zu skillen überhaupt, 50 Battlesongs und sagen wir mal hier, ich nehme Schwert, auch wenn das nicht beliebt ist, 39 Schwert und Rest parieren, das heißt das ist meine 50er Skillung.
das fühlt sich irgendwie wie bei Return of Reckoning an.
Ja, Return of Reckoning ist ja auch vom gleichen Hersteller.
Das ist das Spiel, was sie nachdauernd gemacht haben.
Nur, dass in EA da enorm viel reingeredet hat.
Zum Beispiel, dass es nur zwei Realms anstatt drei gibt und sowas.
Also, das Warhammer-Game hätte echt Potenzial gehabt.
Noch mehr Potenzial gehabt.
Aber, ja, das ist abgefahren.
Äh, kommen da Gegner?
Gegner.
Ink, ink, ink, ink.
Wo ist der Bade?
Hier ist der Bade.
Das ist der Bade.
Bade wird gemetzt.
Jawoll.
Du wirst geslowt.
Du wirst interrupted.
Du wirst auch interrupted.
Ich muss auf den Bade gucken.
Der Bade darf auf jeden Fall...
Bade ist free.
Shit, shit, shit, shit, shit.
Ich hab nix, um den Bade zu interupten.
Oh, der Bade muss sterben.
Please.
Jawohl, Bade ist tot.
Haben wir gewonnen.
Wo ist Shani?
Ach, Shani hat den Typ hinten dran.
Ah, fuck.
Der hat resisted.
Fuck.
Shit.
Shani, lauf doch zu uns.
Okay, Shani ist weg. Nice.
Wir haben es.
Und das, obwohl die ein bisschen höheres Level waren.
War doch gar nicht schlecht.
Nice Fight.
Okay.
Mega chaotisch. Ich versuche mal halbwegs zu erklären,
was passiert ist.
Gegnerische Gruppe aus Hibernia
ist uns entgegengekommen.
hat, ähm,
so, und das erste, was man
machen muss, sobald man
auf eine Gruppe Hips trifft, ist zu gucken,
wer ist der Bade?
Und der Bade ist der
mit einer Harfe in der Hand.
Und den mit der Harfe in der Hand, den habe ich instant CC'et.
Damit hier.
Das Ding ist, das ist aber nur Low Level, deswegen hält das nicht so lang.
Ich kann das erkennen, ja ja.
Das ist ein Übungssatz, das erkennt ihr auch mit der Zeit.
Wenn eine Harfe in der Hand ist.
Ich habe da einen Blick für.
Ich kann euch das innerhalb von einer halben Sekunde sagen.
Also, wenn da jetzt eine Gruppe kommt, ich gucke so hin, kann ich euch sagen, instant Valor Barres.
Bei Alps ist das wieder was anderes.
Da musst du auf was anderes gucken.
Von hinten ist irgendwo...
Ne, ne, ist in mids.
Also eines deiner Hauptjobs als Galde ist eigentlich erstmal zu gucken, dass die Gegner
nichts machen können also du bist du mit haupt interrupter in der mit gruppe du
musst du musst gucken dass der bade nicht dazu kommt deine supporter zu
ficken und du musst gucken dass da möglichkeit auch kein caster irgendwie
deine leute drei schottet ich bin ja gut ich bin immer der wo die kamera in der
mitte ist ich gucke mal kann man seinen eigenen namen vielleicht ist es eine
gute sache ist kann man seinen eigenen namen vielleicht irgendwie your name
geht nicht kann man nicht anzeigen lassen
hier erkenne ich auch nicht ja ja das erkenne ich auch nicht immer
ehrlich gesagt im geplänkel wichtig ist dass man den gegner sieht wo man selbst
ist eigentlich so wichtig weil man weiß dass man halt in der mitte ist vom
screen okay ich erkenne es ja auch jetzt nicht unbedingt direkt jetzt schon jetzt
wahnsinnig so viele
also wenn hips am start sind immer gucken was da bade macht bade darf nie
frei sein bei alps immer gucken am anfang gerade als als galde dass man die
hexe findet und die hexe vielleicht ins c10 wenn es der heiler nicht nicht vorher schon gemacht hat
und danach nach möglichkeit wenn deine tanks beziehungsweise deine mele dps gerade an dir
vorbei rennen zufälligerweise kannst mal kurz mit drauf mal kurz mit drauf kloppen
für ein bisschen mehr burst damage ansonsten bist du als galde zum größten teil eigentlich
gesplittet von deinem
Melee-DPS.
Okay.
Krieg einen Umhang.
Danke.
Jetzt habe ich einen Level 5 Umhang gekriegt, der schlechter ist
als mein...
Okay.
Danke.
Hätte ich jetzt nicht gebraucht, aber why not?
Ach, guck mal, ein Kälte.
Da können wir uns aber
in den Bade, da kommen wir nicht hinterher.
Lass mal wieder in einen Dungeon mit 200 Leute gehen.
Ne, ich muss jetzt den Skalde erstmal leveln.
Aber spätestens
bei Level 40
mache ich dann
noch ein paar Raids,
weil da gibt es immer einen Free Level.
Brauche ich hier irgendwas von?
Schrott.
Alles verkaufen, klar.
Mitz
Ihr mal seht, er hat damals auf Dartmoor Albion gespielt
Dartmoor hab ich mit
Oh, guck mal, da sind Mitz
Wo ist der Bade? Bade? Da hinten, das ist der Bade
Seht ihr, seht ihr das?
Seht ihr das?
Der hat eine Harfe in der Hand
Habt ihr das gesehen? Guck da
Da, Harfe, hier
da müsst ihr drauf gucken das ist euer primärer job bei einem anfang von einem fight als geile
zu gucken dass der bade nichts machen kann und danach dass keine caster groß dps machen gucken
dass die anderen supporter nichts machen und so weiter aber bade der bade gerade in battle
crowns wo die spells noch so stark sind vom bade und noch stärker als später der darf nichts machen
Der muss das Gefühl haben, er will das Spiel aninstallen, wenn ihr euren Job richtig macht.
Also ihr seid als Geile dafür zuständig, dass der Bade gleich aninstallt.
Dann habt ihr es richtig gemacht.
So, okay, jetzt kann ich mir noch ein Chesspiece kaufen, klar.
Ach, guck, wir haben Permasprint schon.
Sehr gut. Guckt, und deswegen
sollen wir wieder dabei,
was ich euch gesagt habe, auf Level 5
Longwinds backen. Weil
ich habe meinen Endo-Reduce-Chant.
Das heißt, wir verbrauchen eh schon weniger
Ausdauer beim Rennen.
Der Schammy hat seine Endo-Regeneration
an. Und wir haben
20% weniger Endo-Verbrauch wegen Longwind.
Gehen wir da rein?
Gehen wir rein? Ich glaube, wir gehen rein.
Wo ist der Bade? Leute,
sagt mir, wo der Bade ist.
Guck, da ist er.
Da ist er.
Guck, und euer Job ist jetzt,
der Typ soll aninstallen, der Bade.
Der soll aninstallen.
Aber ihr dürft euch auch nicht so weit reinziehen lassen.
Also hier ist es zum Beispiel schlecht,
sich weiter reinziehen lassen.
Aber das ist gut, der Bade ist dead.
Wo ist Shani?
Shani ist da.
Gucken, wo der Heiler ist.
Heiler braucht Speed.
Oh, du rennst nicht weg.
Du rennst auch nicht weg.
Oh, zack.
Nicht so weit.
Immer gucken, dass man nicht overextendet.
Gucken, wo der Heiler ist.
Shani ist da.
Shani kriegt Speed, dass Shani wieder bei davor rennen kann.
So, Shani hat einen Speed-Tick bekommen.
Sehr viele Hips, da gehen wir nicht rein.
Viel zu viele.
Da ist jetzt nicht overextend, nicht in die Gegner reinrennen, nicht sinnlos sterben.
Gucken, dass Shani nicht stirbt, weil ohne Heile hat man gelitten.
Gucken, dass man als Gruppe movet.
Da hinten ist ein Ba... ne, wo ist der Bade?
Leute, mein Job Bade muss uninstallen. Da ist der Bade.
Da ist er, guck hier.
Uninstall.
Ich hab ihn geslowt.
Uninstall, du sollst uninstallen
Genau
Also Leute, ich glaube ihr habt gelernt
Was ist euer Job als Skalde
Gerade im WG
Ihr wisst es jetzt
Uninstall, Bade muss uninstallen
Das ist übrigens nicht immer der gleiche Bade
Ich weiß nicht, habt ihr das erkannt?
Jetzt mal wirklich eine Frage
Ich weiß, dass nicht viele da sind, die das Spiel
noch nicht gespielt haben
Hat man erkannt, als jemand, der das nicht spielt
dass das unterschiedliche Baden waren
Das eine war ein weiblicher Kälte
und das andere war ein männlicher Kältebade
Ich glaube, die haben zwei
zwei Kältinnenbaden
Bardinnen, zwei Kelten-Bardinnen
und ein Kelten-Barde.
Hat man nicht erkannt, okay. Aber hat man
wenigstens das Musikinstrument jetzt erkannt,
nachdem ich es erzählt habe?
Hat man erkannt, dass die eine Harfe
in der Hand hatten immer?
Also die, die aninstallen sollen, ja?
Die haben immer eine Harfe in der Hand.
Wohlgemerkt, immer nur Kelten
mit einer Harfe.
Highlander oder Bretonen mit einer Harfe? Nicht.
Nur Kelten mit einer
harfe weil nur keltenbader werden können getont und highlander mit harfe sind
männer sänger die sind nicht unbedingt direkt für das target mit viel fantasie
okay immerhin wir lernen wir selbst ich spreche euch das schon bei oder oben ist
was
die gruppe ist gut kann sich sagen normalerweise sterben die immer die
leute sind bei bei fights das liegt auch daran dass wir gescheiten heiler haben
also schade macht es gut sein gegner schande macht es gut du musst als heiler
die Leute manchmal ein bisschen flamen.
Das ist einfach so. Ich fand's
übertrieben am Anfang, dass er gleich disbanden wollte.
Aber du musst, wenn es die Leute
nicht hinbekommen,
so die obvious Dinger zu machen,
äh, ist das ein Gegner?
Nee. Dann musst du als Heiler,
weil du bist letztendlich für alles verantwortlich
als Heiler irgendwo, dass die Leute nicht sterben,
dass die Gegner nichts machen können.
Dann musst du die manchmal auch ein bisschen zurechtweilen.
Dann musst du sagen, Leute, hier,
ihr müsst nur einen Knopf drücken und DPS machen,
also jetzt kriegt mal euren Shit together.
Also Heiler ist so ein Ding, da muss man den feinen Grad zwischen Toxic Flamen und Gruppe am Leben halten finden.
Ich meine, Shani hat nur wirklich eine fiese Position.
Er ist Group Leader, der muss sich um die Leute kümmern, der muss heilen, der muss gucken, dass die Gegner nichts machen können.
Der muss uns sagen, wo wir hinrennen, der läuft vor, also er macht alles quasi.
Deswegen ist ein bisschen Flame auch erlaubt.
Oh, ich muss meinen Helm absetzen.
Der Helm sieht so hässlich aus.
So, viel besser.
Was wir jetzt haben ist, wir haben so ein Relikt
Am Start
Das heißt, ihr seht es hier
Wir werden auf der Karte angezeigt
Alle Gegner in dem Battleground
Sehen uns jetzt auf der Karte
Das heißt, es ist eigentlich nur eine Frage von Minuten
Oder Sekunden, bis welche um die Ecke
kommen und uns killen wollen.
Das kann man aber mit einer guten Group machen,
weil oftmals kommen die Gegner
sehr gestückelt und nur einzeln.
Das heißt, du lockst die zu dir,
um sie im Endeffekt wegzusnacken.
Das kann richtig gut gehen
und viel XP bringen und RP
und Bounty Points und alles.
Kann aber auch in die Hose gehen, wenn jetzt
auf einmal zwei Gruppen um die Ecke kommen.
Ich level Elons Account.
Elon sollte unbedingt Dark spielen auf Eden.
Ja.
Dann level ich auch sein Account.
Ich glaube, die Leute werden nicht schlecht bezahlt,
die sein Account leveln, oder? Was meint ihr?
Die kriegen bestimmt ordentlich,
ordentlich Asche dafür.
West west west aller der quest quest
Except
Sie abholen zack
Let's go ready
Ich muss mal kurz meine Trinkets sortieren. Hier haben wir 100 Trinkets zum eintauschen.
Und mehr haben wir nicht. Hier sind Trinkets.
Seine Tochter meinte er war Bronze Torbjörnman in Overwatch.
Nicht sicher, ob
das legit ist,
deine Infos, aber ich könnte mir das gut vorstellen.
Achso, ich sollte vielleicht mal trainieren.
Ah, neuer DD und jetzt ein bisschen schwer.
Damage!
So.
Also, Battlesongs haben wir was Neues gekriegt.
Ne, ist schon richtig.
Alles passt.
Alles richtig.
Passt auch alles.
Neue Songs haben wir nicht.
Ach, Mana-Song habe ich ja ganz vergessen.
Kann ich auch noch anschmeißen.
Das ist so krass, dass man jetzt 8 Dinge anmachen kann.
Ist das gut oder schlecht?
Das ist ziemlich schlecht.
Also Torbjörn Main war schon schlecht.
und Bronze ist das schlechteste, was es gibt.
So, jetzt können wir uns gleich nochmal
einen Makro basteln danach.
Ist aus dem Interview.
Ernsthaft?
die hat gesagt, der war
Bronze-Thorbjörn-Made.
Ja, passt irgendwie.
Ich glaube, wir haben gleich Stickloss da hinten, der dicke.
Der ist gleich weg.
Edgelord, moin, danke für den Sub.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wie oft ich online bin
in nächster Zeit. Ein großes Problem von mir,
warum ich nicht da war, hat sich ja schon gelöst.
So ein paar Kleinigkeiten, bis sich
alles wieder normalisiert hat. Dann bin ich
auch wieder regelmäßig am Start.
also viel im stream und auch wieder youtube technisch was elon musk daughter claims he
was doch wieder da war was ist kids to boost top top top main bei der way
irgendwie passt torbjörn oh wir machen ck alles klar
ich glaube wir machen das keep
Alps, gib ihm
Oh fuck, Sandwich Time
Leute, uninstall, wo ist der Bade?
Hier sind Alps
Aber da gehe ich jetzt nicht rein
Wir sollten uns eh auf... Da ist der Bade
Shit, ich habe den Bade rausgehauen aus dem CC
Ich kack noob
Oh oh
Da, noch ein Bade. Doppelt Bade.
Das aber.
Moment, Moment.
Die müssen aninstallen.
Wir stehen halt ziemlich fies hier gerade
und werden gebasht gleich,
wenn nicht noch mehr Mids kommen.
Ja, wir sterben gleich.
Ich kann nicht sticken
und ich kann nicht sprinten. Okay, weg.
Ist das unser Keep?
Ich glaube nicht, oder?
Oder doch?
Erkennt man das irgendwie?
Ich sehe die Flaggen nicht.
Slash, Slash Realm, sieht man das doch, oder?
Haben wir?
Oh, shit.
Haben wir das Keep?
Sekunde.
Warmap?
Kill a Low.
Nein, Alps.
Gibt es den Friseur noch? Ja, den gibt es noch.
Wo sind die Alp-Streamer?
Weiß nicht.
Ah, jetzt wird's
wieder reingepusht.
Jetzt putscht die Mids rein.
Wir müssen warten, bis unser Heiler hier rauskommt.
Und dann...
rushen wir wahrscheinlich rein.
So.
Ja gut.
so wird das nix.
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall mithelfen,
sonst wird das nix.
Wir müssen die von der Seite ein bisschen auseinanderziehen.
Dann klappt das vielleicht.
Schön zezet werden.
Wo ist der Bade?
Bade, fick dich, jawoll.
Der wird, der, guck, das passiert, wenn man als Noob Melee-Charts spielt.
Man stirbt, weil man total in die Gegner rein-chartst, blind.
Oh fuck, da kann ich nicht rein.
Wenn ich da reingehe, bin ich dead.
Okay, jetzt bin ich wahrscheinlich auch dead.
Shunny, da oben.
Ich komm nicht raus.
Ich stehe noch 4 Sekunden, 5 Sekunden.
Jawohl, nuke mich raus.
Nice, danke.
Ich gehe da nicht rein.
Wenn ich reingehe, bin ich dead.
Shani braucht auf jeden Fall Speed.
Deswegen bleibe ich hinten.
Das sind auf jeden Fall zu viele Hips, dass wir da gerade direkt reinchargen können.
Ja, ich bin 40.
Der Frasier auch.
Krass, oder? Kann man sich nicht vorstellen.
Habt ihr es eben gesehen?
Der reingechargt ist in uns.
So sieht das aus, wenn Noobs Melee-Charakter spielen.
Deswegen habe ich euch davon abgeraten, Melee-Character als ersten Chart zu spielen.
Weil du musst genau wissen, wann du rein kannst, wann du zu tief drin bist und sonst was.
Der war halt einfach instant dead.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass ich immer perfekt stehe oder so. Das auch nicht.
Aber so dieses, ein Gegner, charge, kill him, dead.
und du hältst als tankt du hast zwar so dass als mini charakter in in dark schon mehr treffer
punkte als kasten oder supporter aber es ist jetzt nicht so als hat man in den supporter
2000 10.000 oder so auch immer wie kriegen das gibt vielleicht gleich müssen aber gucken wenn
Wenn die Hips hier pushen, müssen wir das Tor defenden.
Die haben es glaube ich noch nicht gecheckt.
Hoffen wir mal, dass keiner Stream guckt, Kickweight.
Ich gehe mal kurz oben drauf.
Ich zeige euch mal das Keep ein bisschen.
Da kann man nämlich hier oben auf die Brüstung drauf und runter gucken.
Und man sieht, dass man nichts sieht.
Wie es da ist.
Da kommt was.
Sind aber
sind aber mit auf der Seite.
Hier kann ich jetzt nicht durch, weil das nicht unser Keep ist.
Aber es ist bald unser Keep.
32 Prozent.
Alps, okay.
Versuch gerade da raus zu gucken.
Ne, ne, da gehe ich nicht mit raus.
Kurz gucken, was da geht.
Nichts, wofür es sich lohnen würde, hier raus zu gehen, weil gleich gibt es ein Free Level.
Ist das Permadeath? Nein, ist nicht Permadeath.
Du hast mich doch schon ein paar Mal sterben sehen, oder?
Oder nicht?
Bin ich heute schon mal gestorben? Ja, garantiert, oder?
In die Permadeath ist das wäre zu krass.
Lordkillen.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Sneaky Turtle.
Daog HC Realm.
Ich glaube das ist nicht gut.
Ich weiß nicht, Daog ist ein Game, gerade durch den Grund, dass es so viel Spiel gibt,
durch den kronen pvp fokus da kommt ja keiner über level 10 so oder oder
umgedreht die ersten level 50 erwerben op es würde keiner quasi dann raus pvp
machen ich glaube durch das pvp das traut sich dann keiner richtig und
deswegen glaubt klappt hat sie nicht glaube hc ist da auch das gegner erst
erstmal schön dds drauf gesperrt aber gab ein paar punkte
one ramp point immerhin doch so viel
das ist da geht's auf cameron auf eden sie sind drei ist erst gestern gestartet
das sind 20 jahre alt das mmo eigentlich zum größten teil send box pvp
MMO.
Okay.
Mal gucken. Was ist das da? Aha!
Hips.
Okay, Leute.
Ich glaube, wir haben gleich einen Fight.
Ihr wisst, was unser Job ist, ne?
Ihr erinnert euch noch, korrekt?
Den mit der Harfe suchen, Leute.
Den mit der Harfe.
Wo ist der mit der Harfe? Ich sehe den mit der Harfe
nicht.
Nice.
Guck! Ha! Er uninstalled gleich.
Ich sag's euch, er uninstalled.
Er konnte nix machen!
Er ist stehen geblieben, wollte casten.
Bam!
Badefarmen, genau.
Das ist unser Job.
Excellent.
Noch mehr, Ink?
Wirklich?
Wo ist der Pax Zerker?
Oh, boah, Alter!
Was hat der alles auf sich drauf gehabt?
Hat irgendwie ein Halb-Biberne auf sich drauf gehabt, der Pax Zerker.
Oh, jetzt müssen wir aufpassen.
Da ist der Bade.
Ich habe keine Spells ready, um den zu interruppen.
Ich brauche auf jeden Fall Speed.
Ich muss mal kurz ein Stückchen zurück,
dass ich wieder ein Speed-Tag kriege.
Und dann geht es rein.
Okay, der Bade wird schon.
Der Bade wird schon gebasht.
Ich versuche mal ein bisschen die Heiler zu interagieren.
Du bleibst stehen.
Also ich bleibe auf jeden Fall auf dem Bade drauf.
Gucken wir mal,
Wer als erstes anfängt zu casten, stirbt.
Okay.
Oh, da kommen Albs von hinten.
Ich hab vergessen zu sprinten.
Da ist der Bade, ich hab nix zum Interrupten.
noch keine endung mehr zum sprinten
und
gib mir auf den keks das fähig übrigens pets die auf einem drauf sind ist es
nicht immer sinnvoll die gleich zu killen weil die heim die hauen aus ein
einen auch ganz gerne mal aus CC raus.
Deswegen, schade das gar nicht mal so sehr,
wenn die auf einem rumhauen.
So, haben wir wieder einiges gekillt.
Und noch ein Schwert.
Ne, unser Schwert ist besser.
7,5 DPS zu 7,2 DPS.
Und danach wird auf jeden Fall wieder gespeckt.
Schnell die Surtrs farmen.
Alles mal anhitten.
Oh, Ink, ihr Albs am Start.
Ich glaube, du machst nichts.
Der Wizard will sterben.
Der Palla wird gesnared, dass er unsere Leute nicht nervt.
Oh, dead.
Er ist auch gleich tot.
Haben wir noch irgendwas?
Da vorne rennt noch was weg gerade.
Alles dead.
Das ist eine gute Gruppe.
Wir wissen zum größten Teil, was wir machen.
Das ist gut.
Shiny macht das auch gut.
Wir haben auch ein gutes Setup.
Das ist jetzt mal so Dark-Meta-Erklärung so ein bisschen.
Das ist auch ein gutes Gruppen-Setup, was wir haben.
Wir haben 1, 2 Heiler.
Wir haben einen Shummy für Buffs.
Und wir haben ein ziemlich nahkampflastiges Setup.
Aber dank Skalde, Walküre und Donnerkrieger mit relativ vielen Instant Interrupts,
sodass wir auch als Nahkämpfer relativ gut in gegnerische Caster rein können
und die interrupten, ohne dass wir instant sterben.
das ist jetzt vielleicht nichts was ich in diesem setup so im großen rvr
unbedingt jeden tag spielen müsste ja und dann haben wir immer noch zweimal
zwei persis für melee dps für richtgras das ist die hexe
ha hexe zu lahm kek wait warum hausten du den raus
na geil ist gut die hexe hat mich single cc ist in ordnung jetzt muss sie nur noch
irgendeiner interruppen jawohl die hexe stirbt klar unser bär sie ist drauf wer
sie in bär form jawohl machen platt ich stehe noch zehn
sekunden rum ich kann auch zehn sekunden nichts machen
sobald ich wieder da bin ist easy mode da ist der zweite clary auflass mich
raus ist die hexe ist die hexe eigentlich gestorben ja hex ist dauer
oh oh hips hips hips
okay ich muss da raus
okay okay okay wir dürfen auf jeden fall nicht stehen bleiben wir müssen die
restlichen alps zwischen uns und die hips bringen gibt es kein counter cc
noch nicht auf dem level ab 23 glaube ich
glaube ab 23
okay die hips die werden wir jetzt nicht mit die wir haben nur noch vier leute
das wird nichts die kriegen wir nicht tot aber wir können nur zum kipp hoch
kommt man da unten ja der truide keck weit wollte gerade ins kieb rennen doch mit 23
gibt's counter cc level 19 geister beschwörer level 23 heiler glaube
wenn ich jetzt richtig im kopf habe was mit dir los
kommst du noch mal hoch kommen noch mal hoch
sind wir auch wir sind schon aus dem bg rausgelevelt das ging aber schnell jetzt
weiß
So ich denke mal wir gehen jetzt hier raus.
und ins nächste haben wir noch die sorter fürs nächste haben sogar direkt nächste bg
also mit cc gibt es in der eigentlich drei formen also cc ist online online mmo speak
für crowd control es gibt es gibt im großen und ganzen gibt es drei cc formen in der es gibt ein
sleep das nennt sich metz in der rock aber das was man allgemein immer muss lieb nennt
kassel so offenen tage habe ich hier auch ein und er kann 15 sekunden nichts machen
50 sekunden außer er bekommt der match das heißt du kannst ziele oder leider nicht abgeben nicht
abgeben nicht abgeben nicht abgeben
jetzt fast fast fast fast abgegeben
haben wir hier irgendwas?
Merchant.
Also wir holen uns auf jeden Fall gleich wieder
ein neues Schwert, weil Schwert ist das,
womit wir Damage machen.
15, jawohl.
Zack.
Der Rest kann erstmal warten.
Wer fehlt denn? Ist jemand weg?
Äh
Der zweite Bersi
Falk
Der Schammi
Ah, der zweite Heiler ist raus
Wie hieß der? Irgendwas mit F
Irgendwas mit F
Äh
Ah, wird schon wieder kommen
Okay, es gibt Pinkelpause, Leute
Schachs ist am Start
Mein Schachs
Okay, Pinkelpause, Leute
Ich bin mal ganz kurz auf dem Klo pinkeln
Und dann kaufe ich auch schnell
Neues Gear
Gleich wieder am Start
Dann erzähle ich euch den Rest
Was ich gerade vorhin erzählen wollte
Mit dem CC
Gleich wieder da
Okay.
Amen.
Wieder am Start.
Kann ich mit...
Also, CC in the Ark.
Erst nochmal kurz hier was kaufen.
Und alles sellen, was hier noch drin ist.
Alles sellen.
Sell.
Bam.
kann man das salvagen geht das löschen
löschen frau nicht mehr aber nicht mehr wir sind jetzt nicht in killer lau mehr
schon löschen hier alles schön clean bounty points so wir haben uns naja da
holen wir uns doch mal ein chest piece und dann halt so den rest der so passt noch nur rot und
komplett neues equipment set sehr gut zack zack zack zack brauchen wir noch irgendwas quickness
quickness könnten wir noch ein bisschen uns aber noch vielleicht ein schmuckstück was quickness
bringt decks ja das ist so eine stelle für das in kastra items perry dex
quickness ja
klug klug und gürtel
ja
die cloak
ja alles kappt das game hat mädchen zwei weibs naja welchen zwei ist noch ist es mehr pvp vor
gegrinde so jetzt noch trainieren das habe ich ganz vergessen und zwar auf level 20 battles
songs gibt es neue sachen und schwert für die frage die jetzt eventuell kommt wenn leute sich
auskennen mit dem game warum schwert schwert ist die schlechteste skill in dem bin ich mir bewusst
ich mag das aber fürs level finde ich gut weil es den town am frühesten gibt und insgesamt mag ich
den Style von Schwert einfach. Besser ist definitiv Hammer, beste Skill-Linie.
Aber ist jetzt nicht so, als müsste man da auch so ultra optimisen, gerade schon beim Leveln,
dass das jetzt irgendwie einen großen Unterschied macht.
falls jetzt neu anfangen würde woher bekommt man bis 50 die rüstung also was mehrere möglichkeiten
du kannst entweder hast du es gerade gesehen bei dem npc wo ich war in jedem battle ground
hast du level appropriate gear wenn du das ist das ist eben da auch das ist nicht offizielles
server free start kostet nichts kannst umsonst spielen und ist mit abstand meiner meinung die
beste da auch was johannis gegeben hat nicht die skater rechts rechts rechts
rechts rechts ist inc und ich muss mal kurz konzentrieren sorry leute ich
komme darauf zurück ich muss die hexe weg weg es jam fight perfekt
komm komm
ach komm schon jetzt stehe ich ewig ob die hexe nicht gesehen die alps sind gut
das merkst du das merkst schon wie die wir wie die rauskeiten
da merkst du die alps taugen was also wie gesagt kein offizieller server hier
ich bleibe einfach stehen ich bin etc
kannst du kostenlos account erstellen
Ja, CC ist übrigens saulang in Dark, aber man kann es countern. Kommen wir gleich noch dazu.
Wo ist Shani? Shani braucht auf jeden Fall Speed von mir, dass er wieder hinterher kommt.
Lass es hier mal stehen.
Ich warte erstmal auf den nächsten Speed-Tick.
Das ist auch so ein Ding. Als Speed-Klasse immer auf den nächsten Speed-Tick warten, bevor man zu Caster reinchargt.
rein schadet weil es war einfach
schneller wieder drin
schön laufen dass alle von der gruppe speed abkriegen
Wo ist der Clary? Irgendwo steht der Clary frei.
Ist der unter Wasser?
Okay, jetzt muss ich auf jeden Fall weg.
Sonst gibt es aufs Maul...
Also die Alps taugen, das merke ich gleich.
Die kiten schön und so.
Wo ist Shani?
Shani ist da oben.
Oh shit.
Jetzt dürfen wir uns bloß nichts erzählen lassen.
Die Hexe, die Hexe steht da halt frei.
Jawoll, Hexe weg.
Excellent.
Ah, okay, jetzt werden die
S-Jammed von den anderen mit.
Ja.
Aber die Alms merkst du gleich.
Du merkst gleich, ob Leute spielen können oder nicht.
Das ist, weil du...
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Die gegnerischen Tanks, die sind halt nicht reingerannt,
stur auf einen von uns drauf gehauen
und gewartet, bis sie sterben,
sondern die sind immer vor und zurück.
Also ich hab's ja auch, du musst rein,
du musst gucken, ob du was
wegbusten kannst, ob du was killen kannst, ob du was interrupten kannst,
aber du darfst nie so tief
reinpushen, dass du jetzt
gleich von drei, vier Seiten Damage bekommst,
weil da kann dich keiner heilen dagegen.
Wie gesagt, deswegen würde ich halt auch für Einsteiger
keinen Melee-Char empfehlen.
Ja, und als Speedklassen...
...als Speedklassen, so wie Skalde und so, ist immer sinnvoll, wenn man Caster-Engagen will.
Wenn man draufgehauen hat, verliert man nämlich seinen Speed.
Ich habe hier diesen Speed-Song.
Der wird gebrochen, sobald man Damage macht.
Das heißt, wenn man eh schon zurückläuft, ist es besser, man bleibt noch mal 2-3 Sekunden weiter zurück.
Bis...
Ja, das hab ich auch gesehen.
Bis er wieder den Speed-Tick hat, weil
der gegnerische Caster kann ja erst
auf dich casten, wenn du in Range bist
und der hat 2-3 Sekunden Cast-Time.
Und in der Zeit bist du schon halt bei ihm.
Du bist zumindest in tausender Range,
um ihn zu CC'en.
Naja.
Es ist ein bisschen ein Gefühl, wie man
Dark spielt. Das ist einfach,
wenn ihr den ersten Chao 50 gelevelt habt,
dann habt ihr da schon ganz gutes Gefühl für.
Okay, manche haben nach 20 Jahren immer noch nicht das Gefühl.
Aber die meisten haben es, man kriegt das relativ schnell raus.
Ja, und jetzt zu der Frage, falls ich jetzt noch anfangen würde, woher bekommt man die Rüstung?
Also, du hast eben im Keep den NPC gesehen, oder?
Wo ich meine Ausrüstung gekauft habe.
also in jedem Battleground findest du
einen NPC
der dir Gear verkauft
also Rüstung, Waffen
und Schmuck
bei Level 50 sieht das Ganze ein bisschen anders aus
aber zum Leveln
ich weiß du fragst mit Level 50
aber mal die ganze Sache zu erzählen
also
ansonsten kannst du auch
dir mit Gold bei Händlern was kaufen
das ist kein Ding, gibt es in der Grenzfestung
gibt es dann Gear
Also beim Leveln bist du eigentlich wirklich mehr als versorgt mit Gear.
Mehr brauchst du eigentlich nicht an Gear.
Just kill, we need XP.
Das ist wie gesagt kein offizieller Surfer.
So, und bei 50 sieht das anders aus.
Bei 50 musst du dir erstmal überlegen, was ist dein Ziel an Gear.
Also was möchtest du haben?
Dafür gibt es ein Programm, wie zum Beispiel...
Ich fange anders an. Ich mache es nicht so kompliziert.
Mit Level 45 kannst du eine Epic-Quest machen, die dir ein komplettes Rüstungsset gibt.
Das ist erstmal mit frisch auf... Machen wir nachher auch noch mit dem Heiler.
Das ist erstmal frisch auf 50 vollkommen okay.
Das Beste, was du frisch auf 50 haben kannst.
Mach deine Epic-Quest, dauert zwei Stunden und dann ist gut.
Dann hast du fresh Level 50 erstmal genug Rüstung.
so und danach musste die überlegen was willst du haben also ein bisschen so
nach deiner skillung wie du gehen willst und dann suchst du dir ein set an
rüstung raus es gibt ein programm bei steam nennt sich
zent kraft das kann ich nachher vielleicht noch mal zeigen
da kannst du deine ausrüstung planen und die haben auch eine datenbank online von
anderen spielern mit fertigen rüstungssets
Rüstung setzen sich in Dark auf Level 50 zusammen aus gekauften Items von NPCs.
Da musst du Endgame Währung farmen für, Endgame Raids machen und Zeug.
Geht aber relativ easy, es ist nicht so, dass es jetzt irgendwie drei Wochen Grind braucht oder so.
Rüstung kaufen bei NPCs und Crafted Rüstung, die verzaubert wird von Craftern.
Das ist eigentlich dein Endgame Gear.
Dann brauchst du noch ein paar Tränke von Craftern.
Aber wenn du frisch 50 bist oder 45, mit 45 macht deine Epic-Quest, da kriegst du einen Level 50 Armor-Set.
Was auch ganz cool aussieht.
Und du kannst sogar oftmals die Epic-Teile später noch weiterverwenden teilweise für selbst den fertigen Level 50 Equipments.
Da immer noch manchmal ein paar Epic-Teile dabei.
Oh, irgendwo Gegner?
Oh shit!
Oh, oh, oh, ja der Minion ist gut, sie ist so klein.
Die Turkpads sind so krass in BG.
Ich rell und kommt jetzt einfach schnell wieder hin.
da wieder da die alps sind gut merkte gleich die wissen was spielt
turk petz in abfacke in battleground
Noch mehr Ink
Oh, noch mehr
Da hinten ist eine Hexe frei
Also diese Cast-Animation da
Das ist so ein typischer Zork-Cast
Sieht man gleich, da muss man weg von
dieses dieses rosa rosa geflimmer hat jetzt gerade gesehen von dem in kono das
und typische hexen cast haben wir den sieht muss man und ray of range bleiben
kann dann range
will da nicht rein wenn ich da rein pushe bin ich dead kann er nicht alleine
rein pushen
Nehmen, da kann ich vielleicht reinpushen.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Erstmal die Heiler freimachen.
Das ist immer das Wichtigste.
Heiler, die nicht casten können, sind useless.
Dementsprechend immer schön...
Alter, er ist Champ.
Bade.
Du weißt, was mein Job ist, ne?
Der will, ob ich Sides tilen will, Alter.
Ja, das ist natürlich jetzt...
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, der Bade steht.
Da gehen wir jetzt ran.
Immerhin, immerhin die Hips gekillt.
Der ist scharf auf mich, der Typ.
Guckt ihn euch an.
Ist die Realm-Verteilung ausgeklickt?
Ich glaube, die ist relativ gut, ja.
Der Wellen ist schon eh selbst dahin.
Bist du der einzige in deiner Gilde?
Nö, wir sind gerade 10 Leute.
Boah, Alter, da rennt ja gerade...
Was ist denn das? Habt ihr das gesehen?
Da rennen gerade drei Gruppen oder so los.
Okay, let's go.
Also, um das nochmal zu
vervollständigen.
In Daok CC.
Es gibt Sleep.
Aber es ist das gleiche. Es gibt Stun und es gibt Root.
Hier kann man
nichts machen.
Man ist komplett außer
Ich muss mal gucken, dass ich hier nichts verpasse.
gefecht gesetzt wenn man gespielt ist aber damit spricht das ganze das heißt
man kann ziele die dort beispielsweise drauf haben die permanent damage geben
kann man nicht lieben egal als selbst selbst wenn es nur einen
einen punkt schaden macht es egal
Es gibt auch Sachen, die das brechen, die keinen Schaden machen.
Ansonsten ist das aber die beste Form von CC, weil die längste.
Und wir reden hier wirklich von lang.
Es gibt Sachen, die halten über eine Minute.
Dagegen kann man aber was machen.
Zwei Klassen pro Realm
bekommen einen Anti-Sleep-Spell.
Oh, wo sind... Ah, guck mal da.
Ein Bade.
Na, dann wollen wir doch mal unseren Job
ausführen, würde ich sagen, oder?
PewDiePie ist Linux-Gamer.
Hab ich irgendwo gelesen? Ja, hab ich irgendwo
gelesen.
So, zwei Klassen pro Realm können Sleep removen und es gibt auch Realm-Abilities, die Sleep
removen.
Resistenzen verringern die Dauer und es gibt noch ein paar andere Fähigkeiten, die es
verringern.
Das heißt, am Ende steht man nicht so lang, wie es jetzt aussieht.
Man kann relativ viel dagegen machen.
Die nächste Form, die es gibt, ist Stun.
Gegen Stun kannst du nichts machen, außer eine Realm-Ability gibt es dagegen.
Der hält aber nicht lang.
resistenzen gehen auch auf stanz halten höchsten ich glaube der längste stand im
spiel ist elf sekunden und er ist vom heiler der held aber mit resis maximal
fünf oder 56 sekunden sekunde leute sogar nichts
ich habe mich noch mal gestand hat der unterschied ist ein cast barra stamm wie
der vom heiler auf den wirken resistenzen ein nahkampf dann wie beispielsweise einen slam mit
dem schild der hält immer die volle zeit generell kann man sagen nahkampf cc hält immer volle zeit
egal wie viele resistenzen hat casting cc hält immer weniger lang dank resistenzen da kannst du
ging es dann kannst du nichts machen damit spricht denn auch nichts du bist zehn sekunden lang ziemlich
im arsch oder 9 besser gesagt mit einem schild wenn ihr wenn ihr einen schild
slam gibt bis zu neun sekunden außer gefecht du kannst nichts dagegen machen
außer eine realm ability gibt es die dagegen wirkt ansonsten wobei man die
dafür raus raushauen möchte ist fragwürdig gegen den nachkampf slam hast
du neun sekunden lang gelitten und neun sekunden heißt du stehst kann sie nicht
bewegen kann es keine fähigkeiten benutzen und sie können so viel damage
auf dich machen wie sie wollen aber eine neko nekanik und scout nach der
sneko mit dem pet leute der ganze fanny sache es gibt eine klasse die heißt
totenbeschwörer necromancer bei uns wurde das immer neko abgekürzt ja und
Ich hab mal mit ein paar... Oh, irgendein... Moment.
Fight. Fight. Oh, das sind ziemlich viele.
Oh, fuck. Da können wir nicht rein.
Jetzt müssen wir aufpassen. Die Alps sind gut.
Die Alps wissen, was sie machen.
Och, Aida, doch da nicht rein, Leute!
Aida, doch nicht rein.
Oh, Mann.
Wir müssen unseren Heiler clear machen.
Ich muss da raus, sonst bin ich dead.
Okay, den können wir vielleicht umbürsten schnell.
Der ist fast tot.
Nice.
Der da vielleicht jetzt noch als nächstes.
Ich meine, eigentlich killt man keine Tanks, aber der ist fast down.
Oh, mach die tot, Hanno14!
Die Albs trauen sich auch nicht so richtig.
Ich muss mal kurz Endu raken kurz.
Oh der kriegt gleich Damage da vorne.
Erzähl das gleich weiter
Habt ihr gesehen, die standen am Anfang
Die waren alle gesleept am Anfang
Für 30 plus Sekunden
Und irgendeiner hat Area Damage reingehauen
Was das wieder gebrochen hat
Das ist halt richtig Noobkacke
Wir hätten die so gefickt
Das war perfekt am Anfang.
Das hat der Heiler wirklich gut gemacht.
Aber gleich irgendeiner
AE reingehauen, alle waren wieder raus.
Das ist halt
ziemlich Schrott.
Die Alps sind noch da. Ich glaube, die sind im Wasser.
Wir recruiten jetzt und
hitten uns gleich.
Die eine Alp-Group mit dem
Heretic, die mit diesen Feuerbällen
da immer rausschießt, die sind echt nicht schlecht.
Welche Klasse macht da E-Mads?
Heiler, Bade und Hexe.
Es gibt noch ein paar kleinere Sachen,
aber das sind die primären Main-CC-Characters.
Clary hat noch eine Instant-Mads.
Totenbeschwörer hat noch was.
Nee, nicht Totenbeschwörer.
Geisterbeschwörer hat noch was.
Und Menta. Menta hat, glaube ich, auch noch was.
Aber ehrlich, die drei Main-CC-Klassen sind Heiler, Bade und Hexe.
also jeder bart sorceress sorg was ist der männliche sorceress und sorcerer oder ja
hexe macht mich mega spaß ist mein lieblings char in albion und bade ist der einzige hip
den ich spiele, weil alles andere mag ich nicht. Ja, also um das mal fertig zu erzählen, also es gibt eine Klasse, die heißt Necromancer, Totenbeschwerer auf Deutsch und wir haben das immer Necro abgekürzt.
Und ich habe relativ oft und ich hoffe dieses Season auch wieder, ich weiß nicht wie viele noch davon da sind, mit Franzosen gespielt. Und ihr wisst was Necro bei den Franzosen heißt, oder?
Also was das verwendet wird.
Oder, so, und da hab ich,
waren wir im Discord,
da waren wir im Discord,
und ich mein halt so, äh,
kill that Nekro. Und ich meinte halt,
ich meinte halt den
Nekromancer.
Und zwei von unseren
Franzosen meinte, Alter,
voll Racism hier.
Und ich sag, was, hä, was wollt ihr von mir?
Wie Racism? Und er sagt, ach so,
das bedeutet schwarz verfolgt okay verstehe ich weiter ein mikro märz
also kann das multi sprach inter kulturell zu missver- oder ist viel da
sind mit zu als gegner
da müssen wir rein leute müssen wir bei ihm gibt es gepasht werden
militär aber auf jeden fall nach schritt
er ist fast tot naja jetzt ist zu spät
ja der da der muss sterben und dem jetzt wenn es aber 23 haben es die heile erst
weil ihr seht wie lange so ein cc hält wenn man nichts dagegen hat und wir
brauchen den speed dass die leute ordentlich hinterherkommen
Jetzt gibt es Speed.
Da haben wir schön von der Seite aufgerollt, hier die Hips.
Übrigens auch so Noob-Fehler, zu früh auf Gegner schlagen.
Immer erst schön warten, bis man Speed hat, bis man schön reinlaufen kann.
Bis man den Bade nerven kann.
Oder ist doch nicht mal ein Bade, ist ein Druide.
Da ist der Bade.
Das ist mein Job hier, Leute.
Da ist er.
Der will mich stunnen, der Whale Walker.
Ich sehe es dir an.
Aber du wirst jetzt gesnared, Bade.
Jetzt willst du deinen Typ gleich heilen.
Was du auch hinkriegst, aber nicht genug.
Dadurch musst du stehen bleiben.
Und dadurch, dass du stehen bleiben musst, kommen wir an dich ran und können dich killen.
Excellent.
Next.
Installiere das jetzt auch mal.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich kann es jedem nur empfehlen.
Probier das Game aus.
Es gibt kaum ein besseres Sandbox-PvP-Game als Dark Edge of Camelot.
haben wir irgendwas hier noch alles
die quest objectives machen die service brauchen wir noch aber wir brauchen vor allem hier oben
noch diese komischen was echt oder ich sehe nichts tatsächlich auf
Fuck.
Wo ist die Hexe?
Sehe keine Hexe.
Da hinten ist die Hexe.
Ne.
Hä?
Das ist der Männer?
What the fuck?
Shit.
Ja, gut, das war jetzt nix
Ich hab die ganze Zeit eine Hexe gesucht
Aber die haben keine Hexe, oder?
Eine Hexe?
Ich hab jetzt keine gesehen
Ich hab da hinten ein Pet gesehen
Aber das war der Minne mit dem Pet
Na klar, kann ja gar keine Sorg sein
Die kann so hohe Pets wahrscheinlich gar nicht nehmen
Ich brauch unbedingt Endu-Tränke.
Oh, den Typ müssen wir anhauen hier,
den Boss.
Wo ist denn Shani?
Shani braucht Speed.
Immer gucken, wo euer Group Leader
in der Heile hinrennt. Läuft das mit Proton?
Ja, das lief schon vor 15 Jahren
unter Linux.
Wir müssen den Boss da oben schnell killen.
den da.
Okay, nice.
Jetzt erstmal beim Shami bleiben,
dass er buffen kann.
Wenn ihr eurem Supporter,
Supportern das Leben einfacher
machen wollt,
lauft nicht außer Range, wenn die euch
buffen wollen. Weil das ist immer
Abfuck.
Erstmal alles anhauen.
Desserte auch anhauen.
Alles anhauen.
Und da unten ist was, Ink?
Da ist der Bade.
Der Bade, guck mal, der haut schon ab vor uns.
Na gut.
Was soll er auch machen?
Ich meine, da kommt gerade eine Horde
von
was weiß ich wie vielen Trollen auf ihn zugerannt.
Da würde ich auch abhauen
an der näheren Stelle.
Da bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig.
So, aber wir machen gut Progress.
Wie sieht denn hier unsere Stats aus?
Guck mal, wir haben sogar, wir haben sogar Nahkampfresistenz bis auf Thrust ganz gut für unser Level.
Also unser Gear ist gerade wirklich in Ordnung, kann man nichts sagen.
Da vorne kam doch irgendwas.
Ich habe doch da Gegner gesehen hier.
Ein bisschen nach, nach Hips aus, oder?
Saracen, ne, ein Alp.
Das sind übrigens gerade gemischt, ne?
Das sind NPCs und das sind echte Gegner.
So, wo ist die Hexe?
Hier, das ist der Kabber.
Das ist ein Kabber.
Da hinten ist ein Clary.
Clary schnappen wir uns jetzt.
Also sind die Heiler.
Die sind auch immer gut zu killen.
Wenn man kein besseres Target findet,
Heiler killen, das ist nie verkehrt.
Welches Klasse ist gut für Einsteiger?
Als erstes such dir den Realm aus, was du spielen willst.
Dann sag ich dir eine gute Einsteigerklasse.
Such dir den Realm raus und ob du gerne Caster oder Supporter spielen willst.
Ich würde als Einsteiger generell keine Melee-DPS empfehlen.
Einzige Ausnahme vielleicht Skalde.
Geil, das ist ja nicht richtig
Milli-DPS so. Halb.
Mit?
Okay.
Äh, Bock auf Shami?
Also wenn du noch nie
gespielt hast oder sehr lange nicht, dann finde ich Shami gut.
Ähm, weil
Shami
muss nichts machen,
um nützlich zu sein.
Du kannst was machen, um noch nützlicher zu sein,
aber du musst nichts machen, um nützlich zu sein.
Also wenn du gerne Support spielen willst, spiel Shami.
Shami wird immer gebraucht, Instant Invite.
Und wenn du deine Leute buffst und Endu an hast,
hast du 80% deines Jobs schon komplett erfüllt.
Und wenn du nicht direkt stirbst, hast du 90% deines Jobs erfüllt.
So, und die letzten 10% kommen dann später erst
mit Gegnerrouten, Seuchen, CC'en und sowas.
und Waffschieren.
Das kannst du dann später lernen, wenn du
ein bisschen Erfahrung in dem Game hast.
Also wenn du gerne Support spielst, finde ich,
ist Schammy perfekte Einstiege mitgehört.
Wenn du nicht gerne
Support spielst, dann
das ist
eine Supporterklasse, ja.
Heiler, ja.
Naja, Schammy ist nicht
so richtig ein Heiler.
Schammys können brauchbar heilen, ja.
Aber
hauptsächlich Baffen-Shammys
und Nerven.
Oh.
Muss Wasser-Buff machen,
hab ich ganz vergessen.
Da waren Alps, oder?
Oh ja, ja. Da müssen wir jetzt drauf.
Achtung.
Moment, Moment.
Wir müssen gucken, was da abgeht.
Aber wir sind mehr.
Wir sollten die eigentlich gut erwischen.
Kann man komplett nur mit PvP leveln?
Ja, ich level den ganzen Stream schon nur
PvP only.
pvp und die hier machen nur pvp zum level was da drin hier da steht einfach
reiner im zelt keck waited
aber wie gesagt also reines pvp level als chamois musst du aber mit musst du
mit gruppe spielen also aber generell musste da mit gruppe spielen weil das
ist kein game was irgendwie du kennst ja noch von früher
ich habe das eine klasse mit die hot hat beim jahr chamois aber hot sind in der
auch nicht so gut.
Chamis hat
einen Hot.
Den besten im Spiel,
aber der ist trotzdem schlecht.
Dafür kannst du den im Laufen casten.
Ein Hot ist eher sowas wie, man hat
noch ein bisschen Damage drin oder einen kleinen
Dot drauf und castet
im Laufen, will nicht stehen bleiben und
castet im Laufen einen Hot. Also
großartig Damage wegheilen kannst du mit Hots nicht
in Dark.
Also Chamis, finde ich, ist
eine gute einstiegsklasse wenn man gerne support spiele mit gehabt du kannst 80 prozent eines jobs
erfüllen indem du einfach nur am leben bleibst passt und endung gibst und du kannst ein bisschen
rum nerven mit solche dots gegner routen und bach schieren ja und du brauchst eine gruppe
aber du kriegst als charme immer eine gruppe du sagst charme lfg beim instant in weit
Aber wirklich instant, Charmy kriegt immer was.
Was ist der Plan? Der Plan ist Quest abgeben.
Wir haben übrigens das fast durch.
Also die Gruppe läuft echt gut.
Wann haben wir angefangen? Vor zwei Stunden oder so?
Oh fuck, es ist schon 17 Uhr.
What?
Hahaha.
Es ist schon 17 Uhr.
ja genau wenn du eben startest dann also du musst hast du musst das haben wir doch beschrieben die
haben doch diesen how to play haben jedoch ihr play in da steht es auch download client download
launcher so genau wenn du das gemacht hast und dann auf play klickst dann wirst dann musst du
dich in discord anmelden weil daneben account quasi mit deinem discord account zusammen
funktioniert so dass du dich nicht mit mehreren leuten irgendwie einloggen kannst und sonst was
du musst dich einmal mit also du musst auch den disco account hinterlegen da steht aber in dem
guide alles drin ja ja genau die will be prompt so es aus der tour disc oder counter login to
game server genau das machst du einmal und dann musst du halt bei jedem start
geht ein browser fenster auf und verifiziert deine dann discord aber wenn
du das dich einmal im browser eingeloggt hast hält es ja für ein halbes jahr
aber das hast du richtig gemacht wenn also jetzt musst du discord discount
account eingeben der fragt dich dann auch du kannst ja auch neuen discord
account machen wenn du willst dafür aber ich habe einen normalen discord account
genommen die wollen ja im endeffekt glaube ich nur den namen und sowas
Aber passt, da kannst du dich einloggen.
Wo ist der Bade? Wo ist der Bade? Wo ist der Bade? Ich sehe keinen Bade. Da ist der Bade.
Jetzt drehen wir mal um.
Sollte n Speed geben.
Die Midz, die Hips wissen was.
Shit.
Muss aufpassen, dass der Bade nicht so viel macht.
Du bleibst stehen Bade.
Bade platzt, gut.
Ah, guck mal, jetzt haben wir wieder hier zwei
Groups dabei. Jetzt ist es egal.
Oh, da sind noch Alps. Wir nehmen mal mehr.
Oh shit, da sind ja richtig
viele.
Aber wir sind auch viele mit.
Guck, Over Extended Tanks, die
sterben immer schön weg.
Wo ist ein Shunny?
Da
Ich rush da nicht rein
Solange unser Heiler sich nicht vortraut
Bisschen defensiv bleiben schadet gar nichts
Guckst du wie schön sie einzeln abfrühstücken
ja und wie gesagt da ist wenn du einsteigst lass dir zeit ja ich meine ich habe gestern
einem tag fast 50 hier beim launch quasi komplett live mäßig und heute machen wir auch 40 plus noch
hoffe ich mal aber ansonsten dass ihr zeit und dadurch dass du schammi spielst hast du den
vorteil du kannst das game lernen und dich mit dem game beschäftigen du musst dich nicht so
sehr mit einer klasse beschäftigen also du musst als chamois nicht laufen knöpfchen drücken darum
um useful zu sein ab und zu mal heilen wenn einer stirbt und ansonsten baffen
endo gut ist kann sich dann schön mit dem game auseinandersetzen so ein
bisschen die game mechanics sich angucken
ach nee der felix wollte das wissen oder habe ich geguckt felix meine ich
Also, EC Buff XP haben wir schon.
Wenn ihr gillen invite wollt sagt Bescheid.
Gibt 10% XP Bonus.
Ups, GC Count gibt es gar nicht.
Irgendwie Gegner.
Okay, da müssen wir aufpassen, die Taugen, die Taugen.
Der Turk, die Hexe.
Die Hexe steht.
Der Turk muss interrupted werden.
Boah, das sind zu viele, das sind zu viele.
Da müssen wir raus.
Keine Chance, da sterben wir jetzt.
Das sind zu viele.
Das sind fast zwei Gruppen.
Lop, lop, lop.
Jetzt sind wir dead.
Ich dachte, vielleicht kriegen wir noch einen wenigstens weg.
Den da, der blaue, der sieht so aus.
Das war zu viel.
Und, ähm...
Haben wir noch ein paar andere?
Haben wir noch andere Musik?
Ist das hier...
Ah! Release!
Don't turn in? Ok.
Hä?
Wat?
Keine Ahnung, hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Wenn du den eben Launcher startest...
...was ist die beste Rasse für Shammy Kobold?
Haben wir noch irgendwie bisschen was anderes hier?
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Music...
Kobold Schamane, ist eigentlich die einzige sinnvolle Klasse.
Was kann eigentlich alles Shami werden?
Troll?
Frostalf? Kobold, oder?
Also Troll ist komplett useless,
weil in Dark ist
Dex gleich Cast Speed
und Kobold hat den besten Cast Speed.
Ne, Zwerg kann nur auf live Charmy werden. Das kam erst später. Das geht hier nicht.
Haben wir hier Happy Fantasy Music? Irgendwie sowas, bisschen was fröhlicheres. Jawoll!
Das ist bestimmt AI generated, wobei das ist drei Jahre her, da war das noch nicht AI generated.
Sprint and Rush into Keep, okay. Ich habe noch kein SOS am Start.
Okay
Wir sind im Keep
Okay, wir gehen da jetzt rein und geben
die Talkens ab, vermute ich mal, oder?
Nice.
Gut.
Wir haben es. Sehr gut.
WG fertig.
next bg
vielleicht können wir noch ein paar alps killen auf dem weg
da oben stehen sie guckt euch an feuerwizard wir rushen da jetzt so rein
das ist die hexe hier du machst nichts hier kollege du machst auch nichts
ich stehe da oben geroutet und kann nichts machen 14 sekunden man keck wait
das ist der minne mit dem der kann den kann ich in ruhe lassen
Haben wir noch irgendwelche Caster oder so?
Oder sind die alle weg?
Ah, ist ein Clary.
Übrigens, es gibt sogar
Unterwasser-Kombat.
Das ist aber etwas gewöhnungsbedürftig
meistens.
Was ist denn hier?
Tipps am Start.
Wo sind wir?
Wo ist Shunny?
Auf der anderen Seite.
Der wird weggesnackt, der Gude hier jetzt.
Bam!
Oh, die sind im Set.
Die werden gesandwiched, die Hips.
blaue kann man mal kurz um hacken ja man ist halt man ist halt echt op als high
level man sieht hier guck mal wir sind jetzt 25 und die sind 22 21 die kriegen so krassen
damage da können überhaupt nichts dagegen machen wir können können wir mit 820 killen
So, jetzt warten, bis man Speed hat.
Ein Bade!
Na, den können wir da nicht casten lassen.
Ihr kennt unser
Primary Objective.
Baden müssen aninstallen.
Das läuft richtig gut heute.
Wir haben jetzt schon
227 Bounty Points.
Da kann ich mir wieder ein komplettes Equipment
neues Gear kaufen.
Nächsten Battleground.
Kann sein, dass ich 18 Uhr euch was vorschmatzen muss.
Weil ich krieg langsam echt Hunger.
Bis drin. Nice.
Und was war's?
Heute gab es Nudeln mit Lachs.
Korrekt.
Gab's schon. Heute Abend gibt's einfach
zwei Brötchen oder so.
Oh, SF.
Okay, wir machen jetzt anscheinend
keine Battlegrounds, sondern wir machen jetzt...
wir machen machen wir frontier quest oder was machen wir jetzt kein müßli
man habe ich gar keinen bock drauf wenn das die fände hat blockiert ja du kannst
übrigens die game dll von da auch als ausnahme der windows defender machen
hast du viel schnellere ladezeit nicht so wie ich hier jetzt
Er ist sicher, was er genau vorhat?
er will einfach nur verkaufen oder
wenn du da will wenn du machen für das müll oder
vermutet wenn du machen weil andere andere grund warum er hierhin geht kann ich mir
jetzt nicht vorstellen wie bekomme ich das alte das neueste schrecklich
Du musst
im Startbildschirm
Oh, ich weiß nicht. Du musst im Startbildschirm
mal die UIs durchklicken.
Aber Eden hat doch schon standardmäßig
ein gescheites, oder nicht?
Oder meinst du
die Icons?
Meinst du die Icons?
Oder generell das UI?
dass das kacke aussieht.
Also meinst du, die Icons
im Eden-Launcher,
also erst einmal, hast du das gleiche
UI wie ich hier?
Sieht das prinzipiell so aus,
außer die Icons. Also
durchsichtige Quickbars und sowas.
Ich zeig's dir.
Ich weiß nicht, machen die...
Also du kannst ingame...
Moment, ich zeig's dir.
ich zeige es dir also im hauptmenü
ja custom skin musste auswählen
ich weiß nicht was es sonst so gibt custom skin nicht atlantis skin custom skin und dann
gehst du in den launcher in deinem launcher hast du hier oben einen knopf ui configuration tool
das machst du auf und dann startet das ein ui wo du sachen customizen kannst zum beispiel
noch auswählen welche icons du haben willst
ok
dann müsste es eigentlich funzen
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal trainieren.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, ok.
Ja, gut.
Ah, Mana Song, gescheiter Mana Song.
Okay, mal kurz gucken, ob ich ein bisschen andere Musik finde.
Es passt nicht so wirklich, oder?
Fantasy Music.
Tavern Music.
Äh.
Ja das geht ganz gut.
Band of Caverns Quest habe ich.
Ich muss was anmachen, ich mach das mal kurz auf.
Jawoll.
Das ist bestimmt AI-generated, oder was meint ihr?
Ganz viel dieser Playlist
hab ich das Gefühl, ist AI-generated.
Hast du eigentlich meinen Song schon gehört?
Warte mal.
Du hast letztens was gepostet und ich hab gesagt ich guck's mir nachher im Stream an.
Ich bin mir grad nicht sicher ob ich schon angeguckt hab.
Dann hab ich's wahrscheinlich nicht angeguckt.
Wenn mir das nicht einfällt.
Okay.
mal gucken wenn der song zu oft loopt dann wird ausgemacht
eigentlich müssten wir hip spielen oder bei dem sound
ich glaube das ist AI generated musik das hört sich so AI generated an finde ich auch
Vielleicht tu ich denen auch Unrecht.
Weiß nicht, manche Musik hört sich einfach eher iGenerated an.
Aha, Boss bashen.
Das ist garantiert AI-generated.
Sven wird gebasht.
so wie brauchen wir denn jetzt noch aber wie ich wusste dass der wenn du machen will ja
ich wusste dass der wenn du willst als es war so
draus ist dachte er muss wenn du machen was anderes ergibt keinen sinn
Ja das ist garantiert AI generated music.
doch genau das kleider alles das ist alles so klein
Auf derde.
Haben wir es danach dann schon?
Ne, zwei Stück brauchen wir noch.
Das hier?
Ah ja.
Das ist gut entspannt.
So was
Weil es nicht so wirklich RPG mäßig passt
Background music
Ups, ich darf aber an der Wand hängen
Das ist ein bisschen schwierig gerade im Dungeon hier durchzurennen und nebenbei noch Musik rauszusuchen.
Oh, oh, oh, was haben wir hier alles?
Nicht, dass Shani stirbt. Das muss ja nicht sein.
was heißt das von den battlefield 6 leaks bisher? ich finde sie gut aus wenigstens nicht so viel
future shit und wingsuit kram und sonst was aber ich freue mich nicht ganz ehrlich ich lasse mich
auf kein battlefield mehr hypen ich war auf 2042 auch gehypt und wurde sehr enttäuscht
deswegen ich warte mal bis der kram rauskommt. witcher ja das ist gut da hast du recht
Genau!
Pam, pam, pam, pam, pam.
Ein anderes Game, auf das du gerade gehypt bist?
Nicht so richtig, ne.
Ja, das geht immer.
hast du kingdom come delivery 2 gespielt deliverance nicht delivery
noch nicht ich habe mir vor ewigkeiten den ersten teil gekauft habe angefangen
und wollte ich den ersten teil spielen
passt irgendwie auch von den tönen so zu nordischen rpg
so
steiliges dann hat er ist super gut da ist so extrem gechillt
gechillt.
Gibt es da irgendwas, was
länger geht und nicht ein
Loop ist?
Ja, das meine ich, es ist zu gechillt.
Wir bleiben jetzt mal kurz bei der Taverne und Musik.
Das passt auch nicht richtig.
Irgendwie bin ich ja gerade mit der Sache nicht so happy.
das ist einfach mal kurz das was wir eben schon mal an hatten man scheiß drauf
oder
spoderman am start
Warum machen wir eigentlich kein Damage?
Entweder ist 50% genauso AFK im Kopf wie ich gerade.
nice gg so jetzt gibt es noch ein extra level und es gibt ein endometrium
ja die sind alle auf diesen auch alle afg
sollte man am anfang eben die standard festmachung ausrüstung und dann ab level 10 ins bg ja du machst
die also wenn du in der tutorial zone bist hast du direkt ein npc ganz am start neben einem quest
neben einem start quest geber der der starter gier der level 10 starter hier verkauft du machst
einfach deine Level 10 in der Tutorialzone
und kaufst dir dann dort
wenn du ein paar Silber
hast, kaufst du dir bei dem
Tutorialhändler ein Level 10er
Rüstungsset.
ja du musst erst mal ein bisschen die settings und die controls und so umstellen wahrscheinlich
weil da halt meilenweit davon entfernt ist und modernes game zu sein also zum beispiel
zum beispiel sie dieses ganze mit maus drehen und das haben die ganz wird
eingestellt standardmäßig ich habe erst mal umgestellt auf wasd steuerung hier
links rechts treten vorwärts rückwärts laufen und ganz ganz viel krebs habe ich
ausgeschaltet also die settings sind wirklich ab die standard settings sind
hardcore pp
aber musste gucken so dass dieser besten gefällt
wir machen echt kein damage habe ich damit laufen ja habe ich gemacht hat wirklich kein
schaden das ist auch so ein ding wenig damage in pvm heißt nicht automatisch wenig der menschen
rvr also nur weil wir mobs lahm killen heißt es nicht dass wir gegner lahm killen gerade mit zwei
ach ja ich war im vorfeld dabei wie so ein bisschen über dark so ein
group composition theorie ja also die group composition die wir haben ist
eigentlich ziemlich gut gerade zum leveln
wir haben zwei heiler was eigentlich so backbone von jeder gruppe ist dann ein
chamois für interrupts und buffs und endo und alles mögliche
Okay, Shani will weiter rennen.
Ich mach, was unser Heiler sagt.
Das sind eigentlich
Instanzen hier gewesen, aber
die gibt's auf Eden nicht und ist auch gut so.
Die haben in Daum noch nie Sinn gemacht.
Wir haben sie eingebaut nach
World of Warcraft, nachdem World of Warcraft
Instanzen hatte, ohne dass sie gecheckt
haben, was World of Warcraft Instanzen sind.
Das war so eine richtige, wie sagt man so,
Executive-Entscheidung. So, wir brauchen
Instanzen. Ja, aber unser Game passt überhaupt
nicht für Instanzen und was weiß ich. Hauptsache
Instanzen. Wir brauchen Instanzen. Ja, okay.
Wir machen Instanzen.
World of Warcraft hat Instanzen, weil
es quasi
so wie einzelne
Filme im Spiel hat. Ja, du hast
hier ein Piratenboot-Thema,
ein Unterwasser-Thema und sowas. Ja,
was du mit möglichst vielen Groupen als
Group-Content getrennt voneinander machen willst.
Also Theme-Park-mäßig.
Deswegen gibt es in World of Warcraft Instanzen. Das macht
ja auch Sinn. Aber einfach
einen Raum mit Mobs drinnen
zum Leveln. Das muss keine Instanz
sein. Und passt auch
zu da auch nicht. Also das
haben sie wieder nicht gecheckt.
Ja, deswegen
gibt es das auf Eden nicht und das ist auch gut so.
Macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Was sonst hier noch irgendwas?
Ja, nächstes BG kaufe ich wieder Zeug.
Ich muss mich um meine Ausrüstung nicht
Gedanken, weil ich kauf mir einfach im BG wieder was
So ein gutes
Na, Gralf
Auf Gralf
By the way, Skalde
Absolut Highskill-Character
Ich drücke im Kreis drei Tasten
Gerade
Ich drücke 1, 2, 3
1, 2, 3, das ist alles
Mehr brauch ich nicht
massive highskill character so ab und zu brauche ich für der maustaste hier noch
vier und fünf und vorher mache ich halt die songs an das war's es kommt später noch ein
bisschen was dazu so ist es nicht aber im großen und ganzen was das okay endo ist das ja endo
du und bisschen stärke sehr gut cool kommen wir noch jetzt kommen noch länger rennen
so und
es gehen wieder bg oder würde ich sagen
Oder nicht?
Oder doch?
Ich mach mal einen Town Portal.
Weil ich mir nicht sicher bin, was die jetzt vorhaben.
Ich mach einfach mal eins.
Bis jetzt haben sie sich noch nicht geäußert, was sie machen wollen.
ok schade will nach jord habe ich porte einfach mal dahin ich habe keine ahnung was was der plan
ist sollte man also die haben ja schon habe ich schon gelesen
Back to BG, ja das dachte ich mir.
So, nächstes BG. BG. Nächstes BG. Battlegrounds. Blind. Blind.
So, jetzt kaufen wir uns gleich mal ordentliche Ausrüstung. Also wir dürfen bei Level 30 sein.
wichtig ist immer man muss level 40 werden danach ist easy weil ab level 40 kannst du
an rates teilnehmen und jeder raid gibt egal ob man ihn schon gemacht haben egal wie oft
mit dem macht gibt ein level das heißt ab ab 40 ist es wirklich easy mode ab 40 kann so dass so
passives einkommen mäßig spielen einfach ein loggen war ein bisschen raid auf ploppt gut ist
Schade ich schon draußen okay wahrscheinlich log nice dann dann zählen wir mal alles
sell geld könnte auch vor selber aber
so und jetzt kaufen wir uns schnell noch neue rüstung also
sagt sagt sagt man musste auch nicht sparsam sein mit den bounty points irgendwann hat man
man genug so und jetzt brauche ein greatsort ein greatsort brauchen wir noch irgendeine quickness
ja quickness ja haben wir noch irgendeinen gürtel oder so vielleicht dual wielding quickness
Das da, das da, das da. So haben wir alles an. So wo ist Shani? Shani ist wieder da.
In the Wild.
Der Suckzerker muss in den Wald.
Das können wir löschen.
Ach, die sind aus der gleichen Gilde.
Ja, dann gut.
Dann sollten die Bescheid wissen.
Jetzt habe ich Zeit, mal ein bisschen etwas zackigere Musik zu suchen.
Okay, was haben wir denn hier?
Happy D&D Music?
Ne, zu entspannt.
Auch zu entspannt.
Was ist das vielleicht?
Town.
Ja!
Ne.
Ja, das geht klar.
Das geht klar.
Hanbisa von Baldur's Gate 3 Musik.
Okay, wir sind ready.
Leute, ich bin das nicht mehr gewohnt.
10 stunden 11 stunden am stück zu spielen aber jetzt sind es ja nur nur
55 stunden
kaffee fährt immer was ja ich würde ja sofort haftbefehle anmachen wenn es da
nicht copyright probleme gibt
frankfurt goethestraße louis vuitton store zahlt die kollektion barfick auf
sporten so sind erst fünf stunden ja sie nur fünf stunden gar kein problem
aber ich fühlte mein mann pappes fühlt sich an wie früher als wo ich elf stunden
gesessen habe was geht so in frankfurt saumäßig viele baustellen
ok wir machen drei minuten pause noch
Ich hole mir was zu essen, Leute.
Oh.
Wo ist denn
unsere Walk?
Der hat die Quest noch nicht abgegeben.
Ich glaube, das ist AFK.
Okay, kurz, Leute, kurz Essen holen.
Gleich wieder da.
Ich bin letzter Zeit wenig Fahrrad gefahren.
Ich bin erst vorgestern oder so,
oder vorvorgestern die erste Runde dieses Jahr gefahren.
Zwei Stunden knapp.
Da hat mir schon richtig der Pops wehgetan.
Kurz AFK-Sor.
Vertraue und glaube, es hilft, es heilt die göttliche Kraft!
Amen.
Da bin ich wieder.
Oh hier, Bad Karma am Start.
Ne, Random Group.
So, bei der Gelegenheit,
nachdem wir hier eh noch ein bisschen rumstehen,
ähm,
kann ich doch gerade mal gucken,
wie ich meinen Heiler nachher specke.
Chaplan, Healer.
also ich meine es gibt es nur eine skillung aber die weiß ich aus dem kopf
gerade nicht also meine heiler der braucht wie wie war triest back
mindestens 18 für zähle mindestens 38 für instance heißt rest oder ob das war
es dann
Ja.
Das ist es.
Also, 33 heilen,
19 Ork, 38 Pack.
Okay, das muss ich nachher machen.
Und dann muss ich mir
endlich mal Quick Bars für den Heiler basteln.
Dass ich auch wieder was treffe.
Anknöppen.
Okay, unsere
Wahl ist einfach
random
AFK-Invento? Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht Ärger mit der
Freundin oder so. Also das
hat man in Dark öfters.
Nachdem das hier ältere Leute spielen.
Sekunde, wartet mal.
nachdem das hier ältere leute spielen ist der abteil von dead gamer relativ hoch mit verheiratet
und kindern und so und da habe ich jetzt schon öfters erlebt dass die einfach afk gehen
zwischendurch das ist nicht mehr so live hier elite leute wie früher so live 24 7 vom rechner
keine Frau, Freundin, sonst was.
Keine anderen Verpflichtungen. Die müssen was
machen. Das hatte ich jetzt schon öfters. Das ist eine Level-Group.
Einfach Leute, die sind einfach
verschwunden. Die waren da
und von einer Minute auf die andere waren die weg.
Und dann waren die
drei Stunden AFK
und sofern sie nicht gekickt wurden,
random sind sie wieder aufgetaucht.
So, ich ess mal was, Leute.
Ich hab Hunger
Unangenehm, wenn man Real Life hat, ja richtig schlimm, oder?
Okay, Leute
Jetzt machen wir eine Sache, die wollte ich vorher schon loswerden
Und zwar
Wir hatten es ja von Einsteigerklassen
Ich wollte euch mal kurz noch
wirklich im Schnelldurchlauf
nochmal kurz die
Klassen zeigen, habe ich im letzten Video auch schon gemacht
also es war jetzt aber wirklich nur sehr zackig
also wie gesagt, es gibt drei
verschiedene Reiche in dem Spiel, Albion
Midgard
und Hibernia
und in Alb
ist es im Prinzip so, du hast
so ein bisschen das Thema von
mittelalterlichem England
Midgard hast du das Thema von so mittelalterlichem
skandinavien und hibernia so mittelalterliches ja ihr land im endeffekt wobei es halt nicht
wirklich da immer ich mein im mittelalter in irland haben wir auch nicht gezaubert meines
wissens nach und keine pilze gebaut und sowas als ich kenne so ein real life animist mal zu sehen
wir an schlecht zumindest jedes bereich hat andere klassen im vergleich zu sehr vielen anderen rpg
hat jedes reich unique klassen alle klassen sind unique pro reich also du kannst nicht in abends
man in midgard spielen oder so es gibt klassen die ähneln sich ein bisschen aber grundsätzlich
kann man sagen alle klassen sind unterschiedlich ja du hast du ein paar klassen die sind ein
bisschen ähnlich was dann abends man so als main main rüstungstank und du hast hier in den warrior
und so und da einen hero die sind sich ein bisschen ähnlich haben aber im kleine kleine
unterschiede aber im größen und ganzen sind die klassen alle komplett unterschiedlich und du hast
du sachen wie man das wirklich schnell durchlaufen du hast du sachen wie reine nahkampf dps schräg
strich tanks du hast sachen wie cast damit pet supporter main healer main support main heal buff
das so eine hybrid klasse aus melee dps und und heilen dann hast du schleicher wenn man
beispielsweise gerne stellst ist das wunderbar kann man sich tarnen und leute
one shotten und wieder abhauen für mich ist es nichts ich habe noch
nie einen schleicher gespielt in der ort weiß ich vielleicht für leute im chat
wer von euch jetzt schon mal gespielt habe schloss schleicher ist nicht meins
wir gehen die schleicher die laufen auf ploppen bei ihrem fight er auf den sack
ja dann hast du noch casta hila hybrid dann hast du wills mele dps hybrid mele
und supporter und wie gesagt ich kann das jetzt nicht alles durchspielen also
es gibt für jeden spielstil eigentlich in jedem realm apps und man hat auch in
jedem bereich klassen wo ich sagen würde die sind eigentlich fast schon zu gut
für das was sie was sie können also was sie an an skill brauchen ja zum beispiel
muss man ganz ganz klar sagen wenn man gerne bg spielt also mit mehreren
gruppen rumläuft ist feuerwieser einfach brain dead as fuck
du brauchst drei knöpfe machst damage und apps wie sonst was und bis in jeder
gruppe gefragt also feuerwieser ist ein bisschen wie in world of warcraft so
fire mage so 11 11 11 11 11 11 11 11 11 1 1 1 1 ok ab und zu mal schiele
recasten 11 11 11 11 11 das ist das ist feuerwehr also manche klassen sind
einfach zu gut fast schon für das was sie an aufwand brauchen aber das sind
meist noch gute einstiegsklassen auf der anderen seite gibt es klassen die sind
extrem gut aber die brauchen ein bisschen game knowledge und auch so den
den kurven plan was man macht ja also nehmen wir mal 22 caster hier raus
nehmen wir mal zwei cast aus albion vergleichen wir mal zorg und wizard
beides cast die auf den ersten blick vielleicht so ein bisschen nach ich
kaste ranged damage spells aussehen
ok unsere wald ist einfach weg der chamois ist auch einfach weg egal wir
können einfach neue leute einladen aber ich glaube im kopf stimmt wieder und
wir sind aber sehr unterschiedlich ja wohingegen ein feier wizard oder wizard
an sich so eine so eine one button class ist man sieht das auch im chartplaner
ganz gut aber meine chartplaner hier ist auch chartplaner geht guckt euch das mal
an wizard noch mal so zum vergleich wizard
na gut man erkennt aber der hat in seiner skill line drei spex drei skills
drei skills fix im endeffekt ja und jetzt guckt euch mal an sorg beim gar
nicht mehr auf denkt man sich so ey guck mal hier range dps castra ist nicht so
unterscheidet sich extrem sorg kann gut der match machen vielleicht nicht so
krass wie nur sagt aber man muss sich das im detail angucken wohingegen
Gegen Wizard, der klassische DPS 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 Chars ist Sorg, so der ich muss 50 Tasten gleichzeitig drücken, dass es funktioniert.
Als Sorg bist du dafür verantwortlich, du hast ein Pet, was du steuern musst.
Du kannst, du hast bis eigentlich, würde ich mal sagen, fast mit die beste CC-Klasse im Spiel.
Also hier, Sleep, Root.
Hast du die, krasse Sau schnell, hast ein Pet und kannst Damage machen.
Also als Sorc kannst du eigentlich alles außer heilen.
Und als Heiler kannst du eigentlich alles außer Damage machen.
Also es ist nicht verkehrt, sich ein bisschen die Klassen durchzulesen im Vorfeld,
bevor man was spielt.
Aber das Wichtigste ist, sucht euch einen Realm raus, der euch gefällt.
Und dann am besten keine Melee-DPS-Klasse spielen.
Der Rest ist eigentlich egal.
wir haben einen ersatz wer sie ich muss mal mein brötchen bei
weil wenn ich eine sache hasse in game ist es wenn leute einfach abhauen ohne was zu sagen
das geht mir so auf den sack ich meine ich finde es auch blöd wenn
einer 5 minuten später sagt oh sorry need to leave aber dann weißt du es wenigstens
ich habe schon so oft erlebt dass leute ld faken wisst ihr was ld faken ist rhetorische
frage wahrscheinlich können sich die meisten leute darunter vorstellen wissen
aber nicht was ich meine da habt ihr eine idee was ld faken ist
da ist schon alle eingepennt
wo ist unser charme
also ld nennt man das in dark wenn einer wenn bei einem die verbindung abrichtet link dead und ld
fake wäre ich gehe jetzt so und close das game also ich fake quasi einen disconnect damit ich
nicht sagen muss leute sorry ich muss weg und das fangt mich immer ab ld fakes sind schlimmste
weil wenn einer sagt sorry muss weg weißt du kannst du dir placement suchen
aber wenn die leute ld faken wartest du fünf minuten weil du denkst die kommen wieder die
kommen nicht wieder
hier
hier ist mit oder so haben dann werde ich unbedingt ein chami
den chamois brauchen
wir haben den chamois angeblich hier von der gilde im bg
aber nirgendswo hier
Ja.
und hier zeigen
also ich habe keyboard im prinzip brauchst du bloß vorwärts ww also hier
ist rave left as well freitag vorwärts
das wichtigste den rest dann habe ich sitzen stehen auf c springen auf f und
waffe ein und aus stecken sprint auf space und face auf q face brauchst du
öfters dass du siehst wo die gegner sind dann habe ich shift ist dick und ich
glaube, das war alles Wichtige.
Ah ja, noch
ein Trick. Trick 17, Leute.
Ähm, wenn ihr
das Spiel neu startet, dann sieht die Kamera
irgendwie so aus. Das ist richtig dumm.
Du machst die Kamera hinter,
so weit hinter wie geht mit der Maus,
dann sagst du Set Kamera.
Wenn ihr Slash Set Kamera schreibt,
dann merkt die sich
und immer wenn ihr die Kamera resettet, geht die
auf diese
weite Position zurück.
Oh, Schammi!
Lookt.
The Sharks ist auch da.
Okay, Schachs geht nicht.
Haben wir einen anderen Charming?
Na gut.
einen schami auf jetzt sagt man kann ein bisschen weniger ich muss was
futter übertrieben
Warum hat der Chammy nur Endo 1?
Was ist das schon wieder?
Was ist das schon wieder hier?
Bestimmt Cave Chammy oder sowas.
wenn wir das mitgenommen
er ist auch unser level
sage ich doch wir haben keine scham hier am start weswegen
ein bade bade du machst nichts
Guck, deswegen
darf man nicht zu sehr reinrennen.
Wäre ich weiter reingerennt, wäre ich einfach
instant verreckt.
Sobald der Bade was macht,
guck, zack.
Was ist mit dem los?
Warum rennt der in uns rein?
Der will spenden.
Wie wir das früher so schön genannt haben.
Hast du nice gespendet, Lurie.
schöner schöner spender spender
Ja, kaum sind wir da, wird schon wieder gebasht.
So muss es sein.
Ich meine, wir sind auch deutlich mehr.
Ist jetzt nicht als wäre das hier die hohe Kunst oder so.
Warum verliere ich denn so schnell Endo?
Achso, weil unser Shammy ja nur Endo 1 hat.
Ganz verpeilt.
Ah, Mobs. Jawohl, die brauchen wir für die Quests.
Und Dice Twice, was für eine Chalice ist es jetzt geworden?
Shami?
Boah, ich brauch unbedingt Endo-Tränke.
Oh
Nopexe
Wo ist denn Shani? Ich muss zu Shani auf jeden Fall
Der Bersi seht ihr das? Der Bersi der rennt halt komplett wieder volle Pulle rein alter
man muss das ein bisschen safe machen leute was mit euch los
kann ich rein schatz wie der letzte vollhaut man sieht's doch dass sie sonst abkratzt
ja da können wir nicht rein jetzt stehen viel zu viele kasten frei
und das ist dann soll man da einfach ein schatten ohne endos sagt auch ein bisschen
ich gehe da nicht rein also ich gleich guck jetzt was schalke macht
Und er setzt sich hin
Okay, nice, Didi
Setzt sich hin
Okay
Oh fuck, da kommen ja noch mehr
Deswegen Leute, nie alleine reinchargen als Melee-DPS.
Auf Speedtick warten, gucken was da abgeht, gucken ob man ein paar Sachen wegklatschen
kann auf die Schnelle.
Gucken wo Shani ist.
gucken dass der heiler speed hat dass er wieder hinterher kommt
Wie war das mit Ruth?
Wird er durch Dermid gebrochen?
Ja, Ruth lässt die Leute aber nur am Boden festwachsen im Endeffekt.
Die können immer noch casten.
und nahkampf angriffe ausführt durch damage gebrochen und betäubt nicht nur bewegt also
gut schränkt nur bewegung ein aber du hast als charme zwei sachen die du machen kannst was ein
single target root du hast naja root und der route interrupted also sprich oder generell
gut interrupted also wenn du nun caster geroutet hast kannst du den alle zwei drei sekunden oder
oder 1-2 Sekunden erneut routen,
sodass der nicht casten kann.
Und er kann auch nicht weglaufen
aus der Range, weil er ja geroutet ist.
Und dann gibst du ihm noch eine Seuche
und er kann kaum
gegengeheilt werden, wenn er viel Damage bekommt.
Und nebenbei kannst du ihm noch alle Buffs schieren,
dass er keine... Wow.
Oh, oh, wir müssen rein.
Nice, free level. Easy.
Das ist ja, das ist ja ein Service.
Kommen wir hier vorbei.
Keep free level next.
GG.
Jawoll.
Top.
Lul W.
Das sind die 10% Aufgaben.
Ja, das sind die optionalen Aufgaben, ja.
Du bist auch nützlich als, du bist auch,
du bist halt nützlich auch als, als
Shamio, ne? Aber für die letzten
10% muss er auch ein bisschen was machen.
Ich mein, wär ja blöd, wenn das komplett Afk-Schawe, oder?
Oh, Pracer.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Derkequick.
Okay.
Quickness.
Ja.
Also heute machen wir eigentlich Max. Unsere Stats alle haben
Con. Naja, brauchen wir nicht Stärke.
Quickness.
Ah, ja, ja.
Ich hab so Hunger.
Ich hab jetzt quasi das Brötchen
zur Hälfte weg mit nur
dreimal reinbeißen.
umgekehrt sowie chico immer ihre portion weggefuttert hat
ach das ist das bg mit dem mit diesen dummen mit diesen fröschen
die ewig zum respawn brauchen
nächste hacker mainstream erstmal kreisel client
mehr schiff shader ja
ich gehe davon aus dass war damals noch gar kein schäder oder das war irgendwas anderes
Hexe.
Nee.
Minna.
Minna-Ordi-Duo.
Hexe?
Aber Hexe hält ein Pet.
Oh fuck, da sind noch mehr.
da gehen aber die mit drauf
schön abgelegt schön abgeliefert
da vorne geht was kommt man erlebt immer noch der betone in black ist die
hexe schild
Ich muss ein bisschen out of range bleiben.
Oh, die ist immun, die Hexe.
Shit, warum ist die Hexe immun?
Ich kann da nicht rein.
Wir sind dead.
Wir sind instant dead, wenn wir da reinpushen.
Seht ihr das?
Fuck.
Okay, jetzt bin ich als nächstes echt dead.
sobald ich ein stunt kriege bin ich dead
ah es kommen noch mehr mids okay jetzt bin ich gestunt shit damage damage
ah die kriegen es mit assisten grad noch nicht hin ich hab glück die albs haben es verkackt
Was steht hier alles, Burschen?
Okay, wir sind tot.
Wollen wir den schnell killen?
Das sind zu viele.
Okay, wir müssen...
Wir müssen respawnen.
geht ich kriege ich vielleicht noch dauern kommen noch ein hit nein der
er ist evaded, die Sau! Warum? Der weicht einfach aus. Ah ja, next. So, was haben wir? Zack, zack, zack, zack, da brauche ich übrigens ein Makro für.
Man kann mittlerweile alles auf eine Taste legen.
ich kann sicher wie wie ging das recorder
das mit zu high grade
jeden recorder wie das funktioniert hat
recorder guide
Man konnte sich so Makros erstellen lassen.
Recorder.
Ist unser Chami schon wieder AFK?
warte mal schachs
was ist mit unserem chamois los jetzt einfach aus cool ich check's nicht was da abgeht
hatte jetzt gekickt oder was auch drama leute lasst doch einfach level
wann bist du in die bgs also gestern mit meinem heiler bin ich glaube ich
so gut wie gar nicht in die BGs, weil das so überrannt war.
Heute bin ich seit Level 10 in den BGs.
noch kurz unser gilden chamois fragen
Ich muss gerade mal kurz Gruppe organisieren.
Das war's für heute.
Okay, Schachsamstart.
Nice.
Guter Schammy.
Den müssen wir jetzt noch einsammeln.
wo ist er denn mit grad kipp ich hole ihn mal ab
oder schon
das ist aus schatz wird angegriffen ich renne ihm entgegen schatz halt durch halt durch halt durch
ok
wir haben ihn
klaus schachs wurde gerade von wo wir gerade beim thema sind was was schleicher in dem game sind
das waren schleicher jedes reich hat zwei schleicher klassen albion hat drei aber in
In der Regel zwei Schleicherklassen.
Einen mit Bogen und einen für Melee-DPS.
Und Schleicher sind halt meistens recht gut da drin, Nachschub abzufarmen.
Also sprich, wenn jetzt wir einen Chummy invited haben, der zu uns rennen will,
rennt der hier lang, hier stehen die Schleicher und dann läuft er hier lang, plopp, plopp, tot, tot.
dafür sind schleicher da ansonsten kann schleicher einfach nur abwärts sich nerven
Ist unser alter Schami immer noch da und AFK?
Manchmal verstehe ich die Welt nicht mehr.
Das ist mir da zu hoch.
So, zweites Brötchen, Leute.
Ich mache das so, dass ich euch wieder nicht ins Ohr schmatze.
Was geht da vorne?
Was ist da los?
Ah, Hips.
Okay.
Wo ist der Bade?
der ttk
naja und eine wichtige sache was ist diese hand
Ah, meine ich schon, die so nach Erde aussieht.
Die so von unten aus der Erde kommt.
Oder welche?
Seriously.
Gibt zwei Sachen.
Das ist Endu-Buff
vom Shammy. Ausdauer-Buff.
Weil die heißt, das heißt irgendwas
von wegen... Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh! Seitliche Ads.
No! Schachs! Nein!
Bin auch geroutet.
Okay, die haben uns schön von der Seite erwischt.
Da können wir nichts machen.
Okay, wir sind dead.
Da haben sie uns gut erwischt von der Seite.
Vielleicht kriegen wir den noch weg.
Der ist blau.
Der ist nur blau.
34.
Ne, kriegen wir nicht.
Also, das ist Shami.
Der Endo-Buff vom Shami sieht so aus.
und es gibt einen root vom wizard der sieht glaube ich auch so aus aber diese hand aus
der erde das ist der endobuff vom chamois wie ging ich muss mal nachgucken wie das mit recorder
mit recorder funst
Wie ging das mit Recorder?
Weil ich will alle meine Songs auf einen Button machen.
Außer den
Melee Absorb.
Vielleicht jetzt endlich mal Kriege.
Oh, ich krieg Resis.
Jawoll.
Nice.
Warum kann ich nicht auf Train?
Achso.
Okay, jetzt brauche ich eine neue Leiste
mit den Songs.
Ja, das brauchen wir alles nicht hier.
Brauche ich eine neue Leiste mit den Songs.
Resis?
Das da?
so
war mit dass deswegen will ich die alle auf dem recorder legen
irgendwas vergessen
hier hier so
irgendwelche ne melee absorb und die anderen resis kriege ich das nächste mal erst
genau komm wir in die runde role playing
kam früher ganz gute geschichte hat er schon mal auf einem role playing event
also nicht real life in dem game
und ich rede nicht von ich rede nicht von world of warcraft gold scheiher rp oder sowas
ich war mal auf unserem also auf stonehenge dabei doch vom alten server bin ich mal zu
einem in albertsen roleplay event gegangen alter auf du darfst nicht karsten hexe du
darfst nicht kassen das ist wichtig man muss immer das riesige target erwischen
Herr Sinde?
Ne.
Sagt mir nix.
Ich weiß eh nicht mehr vieles.
Zumindest das ist das.
Die Leute
auf diesem Roleplay Event,
die haben Romane geschrieben, gefühlt.
ja da wurde nicht einfach so wie man sich vorstellt sowieso so low iq roleplay
zu ha ha seht welch mächtiger zauberer oder sowas da wurde echt die hat die
haben gefühlt unter zehn sätzen wurde da nichts geschrieben
das war mir zu anstrengend da bin ich bin nie wieder auf ein roleplay event
danach gegangen
Weil wirklich, ich habe Romane verfasst.
So las ich das.
Ich will gar nicht wissen, wie das auf
Real Life Roleplay Events ist.
Wobei heute ist Roleplay,
seit GTA Roleplay und sowas,
heute ist ja Roleplay
eigentlich eher so ein Synonym für
It's just a prank.
So nach dem Motto,
wenn einer dann so übertrieben ausrastet,
boah, alle ihr ganzen Wichser, Kack, Spaß,
I'm just roleplaying, just roleplaying,
ich roleplay, dass ich ein Arsch bin,
just roleplaying.
Das ist was früher so,
früher so dieses, ist alles nur Prank,
war, heute kannst du immer sagen,
so, ich hab scheiße gemacht, es war doch nur Roleplay.
Wobei man sich halt fragt, warum man in normalen
Real-Life-Situationen einfach random anfangen sollte
zu roleplayen.
Was roleplayt man dann da, wenn nicht sich selbst?
Seit wann gibt es Eden?
Season 3 seit gestern.
Eden selbst gibt es seit, ja gut, es ist die dritte Season,
also das dritte Jahr, würde ich sagen.
Die Seasons gehen immer so
grob ein Jahr, würde ich sagen.
Die letzte Season, ja, so ungefähr
ein Jahr geht das Season.
Aber ich mache mir ein paar
Deserter-Quests.
Kreisel-Client.
Was passiert nach einer Season?
Alles Reset. Nein.
Also, das haben die, wie so vieles.
sehr gut gelöst.
Und zwar,
was resettet wird, ist
dein Goldstand,
alle deine Levels und deine Items.
Was erhalten bleibt,
ist, du siehst es ja hier vielleicht,
an meinem Realm-Rank,
deine RPs bleiben erhalten.
Aber,
nicht so wie du denkst, weil es wäre ziemlich OP.
Stellt euch mal vor, am ersten Tag gibt es
AR-10er, oder AR-12er,
das ist der höchste Rank, den man erreichen kann.
Streng genommen 14, aber
ihr wisst was ich meine
deswegen gibt es ein RP Cap
also sprich
bei Release ist das
RP Cap 2L9
und das geht dann alle 14 Tage
glaube ich
weiter
weiter rauf
das heißt selbst Leute die normal spielen
wenn normal neu anfangen können quasi
aufholen auch mit semi
aktiver Spielweise
2L9 hast du ratzfatz
also behältst deine RPs
und bekommst allerdings die RPS erst der Reihe nach freigeschaltet und nicht direkt.
Guck mal, da sind zwei Alps.
Wenn ich das Pet jetzt...
Wenn ich das Pet snähre, dann verliert der Speed, oder?
Oder?
I'm not...
I'm not sure.
Ja, Schaden gekomm...
Du kannst...
Die Leute rennen halt einfach immer
RPs hinterher. Das ist doch...
Standard.
bin der höhe 10 als katz dann hat jetzt entweder in mulan weiter killquets machen
oder in einem anderen gebiet oder kannst du dir begehst gehen
und lass dich nicht frusten weil wenn man neu ist erst mal alles so so überwältigt ein wenn
du nicht wenn du nicht gleich bock auf pvp hast kannst du auch weiter kill quest machen wir können
auch zusammen leveln seit der glaube ich beide mit gehört kannst du weiter du kannst du kannst
weiter kill quest machen mit einer group ansonsten würde ich dir einfach empfehlen schreibt meinem
lfg chat slash slash lfg ist es glaube ich im lfg chat charme 11 oder eure
klasse und guckt mal wer euch einlädt und dann was sie vorhaben
was ich empfehlen würde ist dass man gleich in chat schreibt wenn man in die gruppe in
weiter wird dass man neu ist und just install 10 minutes ago first time player viele sind
dann recht nett und erklärt haben auch was auch ob man da gibt es gegner
so war es in bade erwischt ja ich habe ihn
an den stall bade an ins zoll gleich
wir haben unser job erledigt successful bade gekellt bzw in drei gehindert uns hinzustellen
ich habe wieder vergessen wie kompliziert auch
ich habe vergessen wie kompliziert eigentlich ist zu spielen und nebenbei
einen Brötchen in der Hand zu halten.
Bekomme ich im BG die Rüstung oder woanders?
Also du bekommst immer Gier,
wenn du Gegner killst.
Also, Mobs.
Die droppen
Gier zu einer hohen
Chance.
Im BG bekommst du
Bounty Points und davon kannst du dir bei dem
Händler, der quasi dort, wo du
wenn du in BG portest,
da steht so ein Bounty Point Merchant.
Da kannst du dir dann welche
kaufen aber dafür musste erst gegner gekillt haben in group als als charme
kürze solo keine gegner
hast du dir in der starter zone einen level 10 equipment gekauft müsste es
genug silber haben für ein volles level 10 equipment
alle bis wir sagen
das gibt es da wo der starter die starter quest ist
neben dem typ der die die starter quest gegeben hat steht ein quarter master oder sowas
da kannst du dir von deinen zehn silber oder was am anfang hast
brauchst du waffe schild
brauchst du nicht ist aber ganz sinnvoll weil auch waffe und schild stats drauf haben
Und du kannst mit Waffe und Schild Gegner interupten.
Du kannst hinlaufen und einmal draufhauen zum Beispiel, wenn da ein Caster frei steht.
Also ich würde als Chami auch eine Waffe nehmen.
Aber brauchen tust du nicht unbedingt.
Aber allein schon, weil auch Stats auf der Waffe sein können, wirst du später eine Waffe haben.
krieg einfach mal brötchen nicht weg hier
das war wieder was
den schlag auf schlag wo ist die hexe wo ist die hexe da ist der cover
und es sind zu viele es sind zu viele müssen ein bisschen bisschen weg der
kammer muss erledigt werden er wolle
es ist nicht nicht so auf exzent nicht so weit rein pushen
bleibst du hier
aber wer sie weiß wie man spielt
Okay, wir sollen zurück zu Shani, dann gehen wir zurück.
Wenn der Heiler sagt,
oh du Mist, ist echt so, wenn der Heiler sagt,
stinken und weg,
dann macht er es auch.
Der Heiler sagt, wo es lang geht.
wenn ihr das nicht macht dann geht es euch sowie chance dass der jetzt gekillt wird gleich
aber noch was
bis wann geht das bg hier überhaupt
29 sind schon fertig wenn ich noch fertig
okay nice geht doch gut heute next bg
aber wir können trinkt trinkt trinkt
Ja, die kann ich noch abgeben.
Wobei, ha, wir sind ja schon 30.
Ich glaube, da kriegt man gar nichts mehr für.
Oh, da ist ein Gegner.
Ich versuch zu essen.
Ähm
Hast du die Porte nochmal zum Bind
Guck mal
Du hast die in deinem Inventar
Hast du sowas da
Personal Bindstone
Und da drauf hast du zwei Spells
Personal Bind
Und Town Portal
Kannst du auf die Leiste ziehen
Und wenn du dann Personal Bind klickst
Dann kommst du zum Bindstone zurück
gibt leider nichts eine xp mehr dafür
verstanden wie es geht
das ist halt das problem da auch erklärt nichts
deswegen leute wenn irgendjemand neues und irgendwas wissen will ich sage nicht
dass ich alles über dauer weiß ich kenne mich aber ganz brauchbar aus
also manche sachen habe ich auch vergessen ja ihr könnt mich beispielsweise
heute beispielsweise heute nicht mehr fragen wie die cast wie die korrekte
cast speed formel ist weil sie noch mehr decks gleich schnellerer k speed
kriegen wir hier noch xp von der quest
nächstes nächstes bg was kommt jetzt wild kommt jetzt wilden 30 bis 5 35 bis 34 35
Ja, Wildhorn.
Alles gesellt.
Und jetzt brauchen wir noch eine...
Im Prinzip hole ich mir einfach wieder das komplette Set hier.
Zack.
Zack, zack, zack, zack, zack und Wilton Cratesword, zack, fertig, mehr brauchen wir nicht.
Neues Equip.
Wilton Cratesword, Hero Boots, Hero.
Zack, zack, zack und den alten Kram können wir löschen.
Den kann man ja weder trainen, noch salvagen, noch sellen.
warum man ihn nicht salvage und sellen kann
glaube ich zu wissen
und zwar dass es keine
keiner irgendeinen Money Klitsch findet
mit Trainingsequipment
es gab ja
einen ziemlich harten
ich würde nicht sagen Money Klitsch
mit Season 2
und zwar
konnte man dort im letzten
BG, also in Katal Valley,
konnte man,
wenn man Klassen hatte,
die Kettenrüstung hatten.
Also wenn man eine Gruppe hatte, beispielsweise
die komplett aus Heiler und Skalde besteht,
oder so, konnte man
die Captains an den Zelten
killen. Und dadurch, dass die relativ hoch waren,
haben die teilweise bis zu 2-3 Kettenteile
gedroppt pro Mob.
Die konnte man dann zerlegen und verkaufen.
Das hat krass viel Geld
gebracht am Anfang. Ich glaube, das haben sie
genervt mittlerweile.
meinst du mit level 10 aus dem grünen die gelbe ich wusste gar nicht dass es zwei verschiedene
sorten gibt wenn du level 10 bist willst du aber die gelbe rüstung am gelb heißt dies auf deinem
level
da musste die später holen zumindest ein set aus zumindest basics
set ausrüstung sollte man sollte man haben dann nach level 10
ja macht euch da nicht so ein ding jeder gekillte mob hat eine hohe chance was zu
droppen was ihr braucht schreibt einfach im lfg chat naja also gesagt übrigens
ice skill und für group wenn du pvp machen willst wenn du pvp machen willst
bin ich persönlich besser range dps aber du kannst mit
bei dem leveln nur erde ist nicht so geil
ich weiß nicht ob die ob die nicht vielleicht eher das speck verbessert
haben ich glaube ich glaube die erde speck ist gar nicht so schlecht man
will seit mittlerweile ich weiß aber nicht wie es auf jeden aussieht
der habe ich noch ein extra bolt gekriegt und so was
scharney
Ich suche gerade noch irgendwelche Mobs, die wir killen.
Da ist noch ein Mob.
Auch noch ein Mob.
Da sind auch noch Möpse.
Ich leech da jetzt einfach mal rein.
Warum brauche ich denn so viel Endo?
Also was ich ganz gerne mache, ich kaufe mir manchmal
Sogar beim Level Longwind 2
Auch wenn man sagt, eigentlich ist das verschenkte Punkte
Es ist einfach so viel angenehmer
Solange man noch Low-Endu ist und sowas
Und man kann ja eh respecken, easy
Ich kaufe mir jetzt Longwind 2 einfach, fertig
Oh
ich kann gleich mal viel besser sprintoren und ich brauche auch weniger weniger enden
dann wenn ich renne und sprüht das ist gut zum leveln ist okay später ist es wasted
ich dachte
ein gegner so ein forsch braumer noch
und man essen sie auch fast leer
hier
Ah, zwei Names müssen wir noch killen, okay.
Wie denkst du auf YouTube? Ich hab grad echt Probleme gehabt die letzten Monate.
Deswegen war ich auch nicht online im Stream.
aber ich habe das das was mich am meisten was wir meisten sorgen bereitet
hat das ist geklärt ich bin bald wieder am start sowohl auf youtube als auch auf
twitch
guckt euch mal an die die ganzen kack ada hier
da wollten sie einfach mal rein licht die scouts und in minne dabei das sind mehr die allerliebsten
Schleicher Gangbangs.
Müssen wir die überhaupt killen?
Ja anscheinend.
sieht man irgendwo wer aus der gruppe bus braucht ja du siehst das wenn du hier dann
gucken fenster aufmacht was die haben da kannst du dir aber gerade als chamois kannst du dir
dann nur ein schöner einrichten ich habe jetzt leider man scham ihn auch auf level 1 sonst hätte
ich dir gezeigt also was ich machen würde du solltest buffs auf also kannst du kannst quasi
so eine gruppen view machen wenn ich auf bach klickst da siehst du wer alles was
hat mag ich aber nicht so ich mache mir immer das bach window auf und das findet
man hier hier unter kommt kommt kommt ihr das ist baff baff window da siehst
du was du alles gebracht hast so und in der regel ist es so dass man sich
innerhalb der gruppe abspricht wer was passt nachdem du bist ist es eigentlich einfach du bist der einzige der speck box hat
und dementsprechend reicht es eigentlich wenn du hier dieses kleine fenster auf hast hier oder ist dann für charme die ein bisschen größer machst
dann siehst du was du gebraucht hast du machst siebste hier nebenhin
Und
Ansonsten wie gesagt du kannst auch die große bach übersicht aufmachen hier im gruppen fenster
es gibt auch noch es gibt auch noch eine andere muss ich mal ein bisschen die interface option
ein vielleicht ist zum einstieg ganz ehrlich ich glaube zum einstieg ist das hier im gruppenfenster
buffs gar nicht schlecht das kannst du auch gleichzeitig benutzt um die leute anzuklicken
klickt auch gleichzeitig nimmt die leute ins target wenn du hier drauf ist kannst du quasi
so als kleines als großes gruppen fenster benutzen mit mit gleichzeitiger bach anzeige
was du lernen musste ist was deine buffs sind von den symbolen her die bachsende der regel
sehr eindeutig mit den icons also dass ihr ist backdecks das spektrum die gibt es auch
nur einfach die diese icons also es gibt keine doppeltdeutigen das doppelte ist noch speck und
Aber das hast du eh nicht.
Moin!
Entr-sant.
Äh, Shunny?
Wo ist denn der Suck-Suck-Sirk?
Ist der schon da im Getümmel?
Oh, danke für den Sub.
wie gesagt leute halten euch zurück mit dem gesammel ich weiß nicht wie oft ich
bin in nächster zeit das hat erstmal ausnahme
aber sobald ich alles erledigt habe bin ich wieder regulär da
Oh fuck, Öl, Öl!
Ja, das hat eine...
Guck, über dem Tor gibt es zwei Ölkessel.
Und wenn man da drunter steht, sieht das so aus wie jetzt.
Manchmal muss man das ein bisschen baiten.
So.
Guckt, dass die denken, man läuft jetzt drunter durch.
Guckt, bait, bait, bait.
Wir müssen warten, bis sie schütten.
Aber ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir rein wollen, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich glaube, wir wollen gar nicht rein, oder? Wollen wir rein?
Ich meine, das ist ein Free Level.
Guckt, so, erster.
Jetzt kann man durch.
Und jetzt muss man vom Tor weg, weil sonst ist man gleich wieder dead.
und schaut jede burg gleich aus weil alle bg keeps gleich aussehen das sind die ein bisschen
die albion keeps sind das die diese aussehen wie die albion keeps später sehen die burgen
anders aus und nicht nur pro reich unterschiedlich sondern auch im reich selbst also sieht nicht jede
mitgard burg gleich aus da gibt es auch zwei oder drei verschiedene also mindestens zwei verschiedene
ich glaube drei verschiedene ist das schwerer als wo kann man nicht sagen
kommt darauf an was du in den games machst
der parksteller kriegt aber mal richtig krass aufs maul gerade
mal kurz gucken nach schalke keine wachen drauf hat wahrscheinlich hat
wachen drauf den taunten wir die mal weg
das ist auch was wo er als egal welche art von nahkämpfer ihr seid selbst wenn
ihr irgendwelche oft auf tank seit wenn heiler wachen agro hat immer einen town
drauf ich muss mal trainieren wobei muss ich das muss ich
absorb ja wollen da habe ich spock drauf
so sehr gut
und die zweites zweite parisi jetzt sollten meine buffs komplett sein es ist so op leute
das ist einfach so op dass man jetzt mittlerweile 88 songs gleichzeitig laufen lassen kann also
letzte season letzte season konnte ich zwei hiervon laufen lassen jetzt kann ich acht stück
gleichzeitig laufen lassen ich weiß nicht was ich gedacht hat das ist balance ich beschwere
mich nicht ich meine ich spiele es okay sollen wir recht sein
ich habe guck mal ich kann jetzt hier zeitgleich laufen lassen
einen kombinierten riesig hitze kalt materie und kombinierten zweiten
kombinierten riesig body spirit energy run speed mele dps mele attack speed
das macht auch attack speed oder relativ sicher macht das auch attack speed
spielst du noch wo ab und zu ja wenn du verbrauch reduzieren bisschen heilen und
mille absorb also spricht man man hat mehr leben wenn man im nahkampf getroffen
wird das absorbiert mit als das das voll op keine ahnung warum das warum man sich
gedacht hat das eine gute idee hast du eine gilde ja german efficiency oder
meins in wo nene zum reden nicht ich habe mir gilt aber das casual kam
aber ich habe lange jetzt schon nicht mehr ernsthaft classic spielt
gerade wo sich da kreisel kreisen so brauche vielleicht nicht brauchen wir
haben alles gut für gut equipped sind wir gut equipped
17 über schneller aus dem kieb rauskommt
was soll ich irgendwas in der gaming szene oder auch komplett raus
ab und zu verfolge ab und zu kriegt man mal was mit aber wenig meint sie jetzt
youtube gaming szene oder generell so was bei games update games g also
generell gaming news und solche sachen das verfolge ich schon immer noch und
ich spiele auch immer noch sachen ja so ist das nicht will ich nur da und
gaming youtube-szene naja also gerade deutschland nicht mehr dass das ich
glaube eines der letzten sachen die ich auf youtube deutschland mit was jetzt
los hier aber keine zeit brain afk zu sehen so sein das letzte was ich mit
gekriegt habe youtube deutschland drama war glaube ich kuchen tv versus shurioka
und das war schon so affig und wie soll man sagen so zu drama bates die ganze
zeit ich würde auch gedacht habe meine güte warum guckst du deutsches youtube
überhaupt noch an was sind da vorne sind ja
ich hätte auch gerne auf der wald weiter gespielt
der bade will gefickt werden warte du kannst nichts machen
jetzt müssen wir aufpassen wenn der wm von mir
er mich verarschen
ich war zu langsam das war mein sich war zu lahm ich habe gesehen dass der anfängt zu
karsten der brauchen instant der bär sie sonst wird rot die sind auch höher höher gelevelt
als bade fast tot sehr gut
Hey, ihr Kackschleichers, verpisst euch da mal.
Siehst du, so sieht es aus, wenn man verkackt den Bade zum Aninstallen zu bringen.
Oh, fuck.
Wir sind dead, wir sind so dead.
Straver-Man.
haben uns voll gehittet von der seite
ja einfach wir lesen next da muss ich muss mir unbedingt angucken wie das mit
dem recorder funktioniert
jemand von euch ahnung wie das mit dem recorder funktioniert das war irgendwie
recorder start und dann musste man musste man die spell namen eintragen
oder muss man die spells drücken
erzähl mal overwatch ja also wie gesagt ich hätte auch gerne auf auf weiter
gespielt hätte sich auf der wahl schalten in der richtung entwickelt die
mir weiter gefallen hätte ja also blizzard hat ja quasi gefühlt dann
einfach aufgehört content zu liefern gab halten gar nichts mehr weiß ich auch
auch nicht warum Overwatch so
hatte so einen Hype und so
einen Zug, den man
am Fahren halten
konnte. Das hat, die haben dann aber einfach
aufgehört. Und
was mir auch extrem auf den Keks
gegangen ist, war diese Art,
es darf keine Competitiveness
neben der Overwatch League geben.
Es gab ja kaum
noch irgendwas, weil ganz
ehrlich, was interessiert mich als
Casual Competitive
Gamer, der da nicht
sein Leben rein investieren kann.
Was interessiert mich?
Overwatch League.
Da werde ich nie mitspielen, würde ich auch gar nicht
wollen, aber beispielsweise
die ESL
Weeklys und sowas, das fand ich gut.
Das war auch eher unser Niveau.
Ja.
Und das gab es
ja dann alles nicht mehr.
Was mich auch abgefuckt hat, ist,
dass das Overwatch-Meta
lange Zeit immer so
Ey, ihr kennt es ja, ne?
Ich habe es ja oft gesagt hier, Blizzard
Blizzard Balancing, so
Gut schlecht, gut schlecht
Und, dass die so ewig gebraucht haben
Erinnert sich noch einer an das Goats-Meta
Leute, Goats
Und, dass sowas dann irgendwie
4, 5 Monate, bis es ein Patch gab
Also, ich weiß nicht
blätter hat es ziemlich verkackt bin ich
ich will das sieht aber ich finde schon
muss jetzt killen alligatoren
ja und das
gold zwar drei tanks jaja gold zwar dieses schild meter
das war er mit dem mit tanks also vor allem halt so schiels und das war das
war richtig dumm mal
also hätten so viel raus machen können
hätten so viel draus machen können gerade wenn man ein bisschen
competitiveness gefördert hätte außerhalb von overwatch league warum
darf es warum darf es keine tournaments geben für leute dritter skill
klasse ja wir werden es nie in die overwatch liegt oder etwas besseres
schaffen aber so es l weeklies oder auch irgendwelche warum haben wir nicht
irgendwelche letters gestartet mit der kultur es gibt einen rank modus aber das
ist auch nur mehr schlecht als recht mit daily oder weekly tournaments wurde dich
anmelden kannst mit automatisch generierten brackets und sowas wurde
irgendwelche daily champions skins anlocken kannst du es die hätten so
unglaublich viel kram machen können was haben sie gemacht eigentlich nichts
und irgendwann kann der overwatch 2 nachdem sie irgendwie overwatch 1 dann noch mal ein
jahr am einfachen zwei jahre fast gar nichts mehr gemacht also ich hätte gerne auf der
wahl weiter gespielt aber blizzard hat es verkackt corona das ist schon durch
Wir können auch Deserters killen.
Äh, wo waren denn die Deserter hier nochmal?
Da, gell, auf dem Berg.
Hier, oh shit.
Lass da baden.
Slam, du musst den slammen.
Hoffentlich kriegt er keinen Heal mehr, nice.
Sind die alle tot?
Ne.
Wo ist denn der Pax Zerker schon wieder?
Hat Shani was dran?
Ne, ist doch gar nichts.
Ah, da oben ist der Pax Zerker.
Gibt es den Doktor Kamp?
Oh, gute Frage.
Also geben tut es dem mit Sicherheit noch.
Ich muss mir irgendwas zu naschen holen jetzt noch gleich.
Sobald wir mal wieder ein bisschen Downtime haben.
Sind es Hips?
Gorfs Leather Collar. Taugt das was?
Replenish Target Power Pool.
das ist gar nicht mal schlecht
ich meine für mich jetzt nicht eher für ein heiler
oder es ist ein job den jeder kriegt fragt man unser auch keiner das braucht
auch erst mal erst mal kämpft wie viele mit sind da überhaupt noch gegner für uns übrig
Tatsächlich hier oben geht noch ein bisschen was. Vielleicht sollten wir kurz warten bis der
Rest auch hoch kommt. Oh das sind ganz schön viele. Ja nein nein nein jetzt okay Hexe steht.
Es ist übrigens, Daruk hat eine Line of Sight by the way. Also hier unten können die einen nicht
an casten auf er wurde resistiert jetzt der parkstrecke ist zu tief trainer
der ist zu weit
hips wo
ob schalke etwas anbaut hat die pushen einfach zu krass rein die tanks guckt
euch das an so sieht das dann aus
charlie brauch speed von der seite die räume jetzt von hinten auf
hinter uns es kommen noch immer durch
so als muss der ganze train muss jetzt mal umdrehen
und wir müssen die hips killen
Guck doch, Alter.
Leute, ihr müsst umdrehen.
Da sind Gegner hinter euch.
Daniel Lull, danke für den Sub.
Excellent Subscription hier.
Kommen die Mids jetzt mal zurück?
Auf Mids.
Jetzt sind die Hälfte ja noch nicht da.
Jetzt kommen sie hier wieder in einer Linie gelaufen.
Okay, den können wir umbörsten.
Nein, nein, nein, Bade, du machst nix.
Leute, ihr wisst, was unser Job ist, ne?
Was meint ihr, wie viele Baden haben wir heute schon zum Aninstallen gebracht?
Realistisch betrachtet keinen, aber ich hoffe mal mindestens fünf.
Hm.
So, erstmal schön Dessert-Requests erledigen.
Drei Stück noch, haben wir, sollten wir haben.
Ich buff nochmal eine Runde Wasser-Buff.
So.
Okay, nächste Pause brauche ich unbedingt Zucker-Kram.
Also nicht, dass ich Diabetes hätte oder sowas, so ist das nicht gemeint.
Ich brauche irgendwas Süßes zum Futter noch.
Zum Glück habe ich keine Diabetes, Mann.
Das Brot, das hätte mir jetzt auch noch gefehlt, ey.
Aber ich habe Blut abnehmen.
Ich habe Blut ab...
Ich habe Blut abnehmen?
Was ist das für ein Satz, Mann?
Ich habe Blut abgenommen bekommen.
Vor einem Monat.
Und Blutzucker.
Top.
eigentlich fast alles top
blutzucker ist super
kinder boxes auf faktor gegner wie kann immer noch im inventar umklicken schalke
Moment, Shani ist zurück. Aber das sind Gegner, ne? Ich meine nur. Fuck, ich habe kein Speed.
wir sollten weg und unseren heiler abholen gegen die
können wir nichts machen das sind zu viele sind mindestens zwei groups
was sagt die waage 81,3 oder 81,4
Irgendwie so.
In dem Dreh.
So, wir müssten doch jetzt eigentlich auch fast fertig sein mit dem BG.
Wir können Quests abgeben und Desert.
Wenn wir die Quests abgeben, jetzt haben wir locker oder ziemlich gut, sollten wir 33 haben.
Ja.
Oh, was ist hier los?
Keck Waiting.
Na geil.
Ne, da können wir nicht reinpushen.
Aber es sind auch nicht so viele.
Oh, Schachs ist debufft.
Äh, gestunt meine ich, nicht debufft.
Ah, CC läuft aus.
Ich glaube, wir gehen, ne?
Ich glaube, die meisten der Mids hat es nicht mitbekommen.
Die sind zu engaged.
Die kommen nicht in den Chat.
Schachs, Move-Tisch.
Auf.
Und der F-Programmer, was sagt deine Waage?
82 auch gut und ich weiß ja nicht wie groß und wie viel vorher aber
klingt es nicht so übertrieben viel so 33 34 haben wir auch schnell level 40
leute wenn wir level 40 haben ist easy ab level 40 kann ich einfach normale
Raids mitmachen und gut ist. Wenn du 82 hast und dünn bist, dann bist du wahrscheinlich relativ
großer dann 190 oder so
ein paar 80
hier 34
train
Battle Songs. 1, 2, 3, 4. Oh, jetzt gibt es gelben Speed. Sehr gut. Exquisite. Gelber Speed. Sehr schön.
sind wir auch schneller als diese npc speed flying leute ist jetzt schon
speed 6 für arme und nicht wirklich speed 6 also man zählt die die speed songs in dem
game durch also jetzt gelbe ist speed 4 der davor blaue speed 3 speed 1 2 3 4 5
gibt es speed 5 und speed 6 ist quasi schnellster schnellster speed song plus rennen
mal gucken hier sind bestimmt wieder irgendwelche alps am start
wir sind auch gar nicht hier drüben sind die deserter ich muss ja wir müssen uns nachher
wirklich mal die die patch notes angucken weil als ich aufgehört habe so
sagen wir mal 60 70 prozent durch diesen zwei durch bis jetzt zu diesen drei also
da kam ja schon noch neues zeug dabei und jetzt sind sie sind drei kam noch
mal neues zeug dabei und zwar jede menge und ich habe auch einmal kurz die
ankündigung überflogen nichts gemacht in der richtung ich habe mir keine patch
und irgendwas durchgelesen müssen wir müssen wir eigentlich auch mal reingucken
es gibt irgendwelche neuen kisten tasks oder sowas und irgendwas mit frontlines
und hast du nicht gesehen habe ich null durchblick was da eigentlich sache ist
10 von 10, let's go.
Oh.
Langsam merke ich es echt am Hintern,
dass ich nicht mehr gewöhnt bin elf stunden am stück zu sitzen wenn gestern 11 gestern
von 13 uhr bis bis 24 uhr ja das sind ja elf stunden max bei meiner windows installiert
kommt immer sie benötigen treiber weiß einer weiß nicht für was das dir fehlt aber du weißt
auch dass ich für windows der falsche ansprechpartner binde
also
welche linie distribution benutzt du privat auf deinem rechner max archipel
away ich use archlinux
Ich mache auf der Arbeit kein Windows.
Ich habe einen Windows Notebook, das ist aber alles.
Ich mache auf der Arbeit null mit Windows,
glücklicherweise.
Und sonst so, Leute.
Oh, die wollen alle mal aufs Klo.
Dann bin ich dabei.
Ich gehe nicht aufs Klo.
sondern ich hole mir gleich noch was zu naschen so bock jetzt paar kekse zu fressen
und ich kann das ich meine ich bin jetzt wieder regelmäßig rennen gewesen fahrradfahren und die
Waage ist auch okay. Heißt im Endeffekt keine Gedanken machen.
Quest turn in.
nächste quest west
ich hatte aber mit dem fabian sonne also mit dem fraser oder phase da mussten wir
alles ultra dumm aussprechen glücklicherweise habe ich mir das nie angewöhnt da hat man
nicht quest gesagt und west und ja so ein bullshit gelabert teilweise so ab und zu
paar runden mit dem frasier kopf spielen oder irgendwas in der richtung das
vermisse ich ja schon aber es gibt irgendwie gerade keine passenden games
so richtig
das sagen wir seit jahren schon
schon
Es ist nicht gerade ein neues cooles coop game
was denn
Für 1 und wenn ja muss das erst mal der friseur cool finden
dem gefällt ja ein games ja fast nichts mehr ich weiß ja auf der xbox hat er sich jedes egal wie
miester spiel war ja auf der 360 hat er sich das gekauft um dann microsoft points zu sammeln oder
xbox points wie hieß dieser kram noch mal microsoft points oder achievement punkte
Die gamers score microsoft points war die war die währung mit bezahlen konnte es gamers score hieß das
Okay
Was echt ich habe keine gegner gesehen wo sind wo sind hier gegner da
ok bade zum an den store bringen please
der packst ca der ist wieder richtig der will es aber wissen dass da ist immer dabei
leute wie ist es für euch angenehmer mit lampen oder mit lampen aus ich persönlich
spiele immer lampen aus das hat auf jeden gar keinen grund auch schütze tipps
schachs no
park
bin ich zu weit drin
guck das passiert wenn tanks zu weit raus rennen
da wird jetzt gesnared er wird jetzt gebashed oh nein fuck gut das war noch ein bisschen mehr
aber macht nichts
sind wir 35
jetzt können wenn wir realisieren sind wir aus dem bg raus oder
oder nicht
genau wir brauchen noch
ist das inklusive 35
jener
Ja.
Hol mal kurz was zu trinken.
Und was zu naschen.
Bin gleich wieder da.
Amen.
Kann man die Lampe ausmachen?
T drücken.
Okay.
Ist Schachs rausgeflogen?
Wo ist Schachs hin? Hat er was geschrieben?
Ich glaube, der ist rausgeflogen.
Der hat öfters schon mal LD gehabt.
Früher. Kann mich dran erinnern.
Also wenn du T drückst, kannst du die Lampe an- und ausmachen.
So, ich habe jetzt hier
exzellent Kekse
nachstellt am Start.
und sie ist mich gerade tod rumliegen weil ich rausgelebt bin aus dem bg und
wir noch irgendwie die verbleibenden leute auf level 35 kriegen wollen
Ich weiß, er hat öfter schon mal LD gehabt.
Früher auch.
da sind die sind nämlich die gegner schon ja das hat keinen sinn wir sollten
die 35 glaube ich war das machen
naja kann
alles in mit oder
egal ich habe ein keks kram am start
und schachs
jetzt wieder
ja
Wie viele Deserter brauchen wir denn?
Vier Stück.
Ja, müssen wir einfach vier Mobs hiten?
Ah.
Ah, shit.
in dem bade
jetzt sind wir dead
wo ist er nicht da ja gut dann machen wir schnell jetzt ist doch kein ding da
machen wir einfach schnell machen wir einfach schnell
Don't release, okay.
Ja, wir haben die Deserters
noch nicht gehittert, oder?
Ah, Shani, high IQ.
Einer noch.
Sehr gut.
so und jetzt dürfen wir jetzt verlesen
die des abgab diesen stream schon weiß nicht doch nicht so viel aber wie gesagt
warte doch erstmal ich weiß nicht wie oft ich am start bin
ok was jetzt
weil ich glaube wir werden wahrscheinlich mit so ziemlich allem
anderen schneller
egal ich fresse jetzt hier meine keks
Was ist das?
aus das was ist der plan
ok ließ mal weg sehr gut
sehr schön da level 40 ruft leute ab dann ist ab dann haben wir durchgespielt
Chatge, mal die Frage an irgendjemand, der vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Ahnung von Eden hat, wie es aktuell ist.
Weiß jemand, wie die Recorder-Geschichte richtig funktioniert?
Ich hatte für Season 2 mal für den Heiler was eingerichtet.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, noch nicht mal Blödsinn.
Noch nicht mal für den Heiler was eingerichtet.
Keine Ahnung, wie das funzt.
Äh, Battlegrounds.
Irgendwie muss man sagen, ich probier das jetzt mal.
recorder start oder so
so
abgeben
gleich mal weg zeug kaufen
ok verkaufen ist nicht jeder der sich
da ist zum verkaufen alles verkaufen
wild trinkets weg haben wir nicht und jetzt kaufen wir uns hier die aktuelle equip konnte
man da nicht auch einfach irgendwie rechts drauf klicken oder shift rechts klicken oder
irgendwie sowas shift left click left control left klick control right klick irgendwie ging
dass man schneller kauft
so und jetzt noch ein great sort und dann haben wir es wieder zack zack zack
zack zack zack ich gebe hier noch meine restlichen bounty points aus für guten
schmuck weil moll weg ist das letzte bg wo es einen händler gibt
ach gut
um einschnitt
ok
zack zack
sehr gut ok also wir machen gerade break gerade zehn minuten break wie es aussieht oder neun
minuten break kurz gucken ob schachs wieder da ist ja schon ganz sinnvoll
hat er echt internetprobleme google mama gibt es noch irgendwas was ich mir
kaufen kann was sinnvoll ist weil wie gesagt letztes begeben quickness aber
constitution hammer stärke haben war quickness hammer und charisma charisma
hammer also ein bisschen also eigentlich brauchen wir nichts mehr
es gibt es eigentlich sonst noch zu kaufen
creator speed auf der hand und so das brauchen wir nicht ich habe selbst speed
ein gürtel ja quickness den da dual wielding shield ist da aber das sagt
bisschen quickness und mehle es ist dabei
gar nicht mal schlecht leute das ist gar nicht mal schlecht fast kept fast kept
riesig so da kann ich das jetzt ausprobieren wie es mit dem recorder
funktioniert man kann irgendwie diese button knöpfe in einen zusammenfassen
so recorder start recorder ist active recorder stopp ok recorder start und jetzt sage ich 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
recorder stop und nur recorder wie funks das
des cards
recorder
moment ich muss mal neues fenster machen
recorder recorder recorder safe aha recorder safe chance
ja
und jetzt wie löst man das jetzt aus
hier
recorder icon hier hier
Ja, aber wie kriege ich da jetzt einen Button draus?
Append Help.
Open Short YouTube Video for Recorder.
Ja, gut.
Das ist gut.
Slash Recorder Help.
Okay.
Nice. Lass uns das doch mal erklären, wie es funktioniert.
Wow, wow, wow.
Okay.
Das habe ich gemacht.
Ja.
Ach, da gibt's...
da gibt es den recorder jetzt ach so das heißt das kann ich jetzt hier drauf
packen
geil jetzt macht er alles an auf einmal sehr gut ja wunderbar habe ich doch
rausgekriegt wieder krempel funktioniert und jetzt kann ich meine chance alle auf
einmal an machen mit nur einem button sehr gut exzellent
ja da muss man erst das hätte das haben die richtig gut gemacht
gibt's auf live bei der wm ich
so dann warten wir bis weiter geht es geht weiter in fünf minuten
dann kann ich jetzt ja in ruhe mal was trinken und war meine kekse voran oder
aber
ausschalten optimist irgendwas machen
und dann esse ich jetzt in ruhe keks was
hat man das hoffe nicht oder
Ja, da, okay.
Oh.
Max, hast du schon eine neue Katze?
Nee, ich war doch erstmal noch.
ich werde nächste woche mal wieder ins tierheim fahren
ein bisschen futterspende abgeben
Oder vielleicht auch Geld spende, mal gucken
Oh, was geht denn da ab?
Boah, massig viele Alps, Alter
Hört ihr gar nicht mehr auf?
Aha, Oma.
das schaust du einfach nicht hätten die rennen weg
da vorne nips wir sollten da gar nicht groß hin wir sollten uns jetzt einfach
direkt verpissen direkt verpissen
aber ganz schnell
also gegen gegen die mit dem kiebel brücken kann man noch nichts ausrichten oder versuchen
die das einzunehmen und es ist unser genau habe ich das jetzt nicht erkannt
naja
ich kann da nicht rein wenn ich da reingehen bin ich
das ist ein bisschen ins ded
der ins ded ist es der typ
tower er wir müssen weg und scharli
aber die trau ich hoffe mal die trauen sich hat nicht so sehr an den tower ran
das ist schon die katzen bilder im discord kredit nachher
Wo sieht man wie viele BP man hat?
Moment, sag ich dir gleich.
Neue mit sind arrived.
Und wollen gebasht werden.
Ich warte auf einen Stun.
Ich mach ja gar kein Damage an denen.
Was ist denn da los?
Ich muss mal Shani abholen kurz.
Das siehst du hier glaube ich da.
Wenn du auf Attributes gehst und da unten in diesem Fenster siehst du Bounty Points,
skill points unter control c attributes
da ist zwar ist danke für den zapp wie gesagt ich weiß nicht wie oft ich in
zukunft nächsten monaten online bin oder nächsten wochen monate ist vielleicht
übertrieben nicht ob da ist wieder alles ich denke man ein zwei monaten wieder
alles ganz normal
Ich hasse Pilze.
Also real life finde ich ja Pilze ganz okay.
Aber ingame hasse ich Pilze.
Nicht Pilz, sondern Pilze.
Was ja da auch ein Unterschied ist.
Na?
Na, den kenn ich.
aber irgendwie haben wir gefühlt nur leute ich auch sie sind zwei noch gerne
das ist ja witzig dass ausgerechnet jetzt reinkommt in die gruppe
So, wisst ihr, ich habe meine Keks fast alle schon gefuttert.
ich habe ich ein problem ich habe gerade innerhalb von zwei minuten oder drei
minuten sechs kekse gefordert und jetzt will ich mehr von alles kann ich mir
nichts mehr da chat was war hier gibt zwei möglichkeiten ich warte jetzt fünf
minuten dann lässt dieses bock ich will jetzt noch mehr süßes futtern nach oder
ich gehe jetzt runter und hole nochmal sechs stück aber ich glaube ich war
war fünf minuten und gucke ob das wieder nach ist
macht es sinn in den bgs die bp für rüstung aus dem jahr sehr viel sinn
kauft ihr im bg immer ein aktuelles rüstungsset wenn du nicht anderweitig
gute rüstung hast ich habe auch alle bp ausgegeben heute immer für ein aktuelles
Rüstungsset.
Macht Sinn.
Als Chami brauchst du keine Waffe
und kein
Schild zu kaufen.
Aber nachdem
da Stats drauf sind, schadet auf jeden Fall auch nicht.
Wenn dir Stats fehlen, kauf einfach.
Aber Rüstungsset.
Rüstungsset würde ich mir immer kaufen.
Oh diese Hillcat Quest die dauert ewig.
Die spawnen nur hier und bisschen weiter vorne und man ist ewig damit beschäftigt.
wir sollten lieber gucken ob die machen die das central keep wenn ihr das aber nicht dass sie
das hinkriegen weil es auch doch okay wir machen central keep nichts gesagt
level easy let's go
aufpassen aufpassen für das öl der parkstrecke wieder voll drin
hätte ich jetzt sonst könnten wir rein pushen aber ich habe keine punkte für
ist aus ich habe lieber lw2 gekauft bis welches level geht das erste bg du
meinst das level 10 ab 14 oder 15 du kannst du auf der homepage von ihnen
nachgucken ich glaube 14 mit 15 glaube ich das nächste glaube ich 10 11 12 13
Ich geh mal kurz hoch hier auf die Brüste und guck mal ob da irgendwas geht noch.
Da oben!
Aber da komm ich nicht hin.
Ah hier!
Ah egal, kommt man nicht hin.
Haha!
Trinkt bloß nichts wenn ich den da...
Wo sterben die denn gerade?
Ach, da oben sind noch Alps drauf.
Moment, ist das offen?
Wir sollen zum Lord?
Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Mensch, da ist überhaupt nichts offen.
und die alps haben es eingenommen
jetzt haben wir gelitten jetzt sollten
wir eigentlich raus springen
Okay wenigstens noch ein Schleicher gekillt.
Wo sind Shani?
Shani ist raus oder?
Ja, das war nix mit Free Easy Level.
Die Mids haben es verkackt.
Aber wir kriegen schon Level 40.
Das dauert, wenn es, keine Ahnung, eine Stunde vielleicht.
dann sind wir 40 und dann ist auch gut weil mit 40 kann ich einfach auf jeden
null x beliebigen raid sonst wie krieg immer ein gratis level
danach kriege ich quasi brain afk 50
so farbigen ab und zu schreiben wir uns über das kort noch ja also das letzte
mal gesprochen mit ihm ist glaube ich schon bisher ja ja aber klar ab und zu
noch mit der karte keine games die großartig zusammen spielen können
quest wird jetzt auch schwierig spielt für split fiction zusammen also
ich den fabian für solche games in interessen kann wer auf jeden fall
Was ist der falsche Mob?
Es war klar, dass sie draufhauen.
Es ist der falsche...
Oh, fuck. Ich hab nichts gesagt, es ist nicht der falsche Mob.
Lul. Ich bin...
Kacknoob.
Ach, das ist der falsche Mob.
Bleibst du da?
den Conno, Dude.
Was? Der wird doch noch geheilt.
Ich fass es nicht.
So, jetzt aber.
2 Prozent, Mann.
Anzeige ist raus.
hat der fabian noch eine social präsenz auf der aktives ich glaube am besten eine
chance hast du auf twitter ich glaube so richtig aktiv ist er nicht aber liest immer noch
fragt mich aber bitte nicht welcher seiner 500 account setzt der letzte und der richtige ist
hat ja auch gefühlt 50 50 xbox accounts eifri sie der friseur xx friseur der friseur xxx und
überall hat er james gore xbox gamers gore gemacht mit den gleichen games weil er nicht
teilweise habe ich den eindruck gab mir wieso weiß ich dass das wieso er muss
dann auch immer rauf und rerollt und was geht da ab gerade
aber da rein da rein oder da mal rein
ich guck mal ob ich die hexe krieg ja hexe steht
immer schön heiler frei machen
jetzt können wir langsam aber sicher pushen
f8 pushen jungs das stand früher immer bei uns wenn man den server gebootet hat
da stand im boot menü immer f oder in diesem diesem px lecker f
da stand immer f8 pushen jungs drin dass man nicht vergessen wie das das weitergehende
Bootmenü aufzumachen oder so.
Das hat sich bei mir irgendwie
im Hirn eingebrannt. F8 pushen, Jungs.
Sag ich heute manchmal noch,
wenn ich in irgendein Bootmenü will,
obwohl es mit F8 gar nichts zu tun hat,
sag ich immer noch manchmal so zu mir selbst.
F8 pushen, Jungs.
Den Dude hier brauchen wir, die anderen brauchen wir nicht.
Nur den Boss.
Überhaupt nicht hässliches Model oder so.
aber wie gesagt game ist 20 jahre alt aber uns mal nicht beschweren
gleich 36 und leute dann ist auch 40 auch noch weit
ich gehe nicht auf vor 40 sage ich euch wird sich muss sein
schnell rein lischen
vorne auch noch rein lischen
die stadt habe am start okay um sein alps
jetzt schon wieder hin also ich guck mal
ob wir die anderen erwischen er wäscht mir nicht
warum war moment warum ist eigentlich mein jolo maus wieder aus habe das gecheckt ist es
ich wundere mich schon die ganze zeit wieder warum die maus so kacke aussieht
What the fuck?
Oh, was jetzt?
Okay, Game, okay.
Alles gut.
Einfach gecrashed.
Warum? Man weiß es nicht.
Zu viele
hackerman maus dinger
ja ihr account ist being locked out
auf game
game lass mich rein
Ja.
Volvic.
Oh, ich hoffe, das hat mein Rekorder-Kram sich gemerkt.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Caster Low Level ist ziemlicher Sack.
Ja, okay, was auch immer.
Ja, geil.
Danke, Game.
Hat sich nicht gemerkt.
warum geht mein jo egal ich lass mal jolo maus jetzt aus muss man das irgendwie
noch extra einschalten jetzt oder was
Wann ist das?
Frag mich, wann das vorhin kaputt gegangen ist.
Control Alt C.
Wow!
Ist vielleicht busy groß, oder?
Was sagt ihr?
Ist das...
Oder angemessen?
mit dem minimal zu groß
control alt c wie macht man das jetzt kleiner hier
ja perfekt
und das ist ziemlich gutes nämlich gutes juwel eigentlich ist ja auch besser
über mollweg trinkt jetzt nehmen wir gehen zum zu wie geht zum central
keep und holen uns ein free level korrekt
den level kasse du kannst auch ganz ehrlich du kannst kasse nicht alleine spielen alleine
ist solo ist kaste erfreulich du musst es in der gruppe spielen und die ersten zehn
level sind immer ein bisschen holprig egal für welche klasse da ist ein schleicher der
wird jetzt weg gerubbelt guckt euch an beim geplatzt
jetzt dürfen wir es aber einnehmen oder
ah what the fuck ok wir sollen alle raus so ist sharni
hä
ich pleck's grad nicht aber wir sterben gerade
Ja gut, dann killt mich auch, please.
Okay, der Barmherr, den fuck ich jetzt nochmal ab.
Ich mach zu wenig Damage, Leute.
Alter, Bersi, einmal draufgehauen, wir hätten ihn gekillt.
Guck dir schon an, der Bersi ist sogar gerade vorbeigelaufen.
Fast, fast noch gekillt.
erstes bg fertig nice gz
hat er sich das hier der hat sich in die korder ja gemerkt
eis
mollweg ist
aber manche bgs sind einfach zehn da kannst du nichts machen
das nati
und gehen wir nicht auf die alps die anderen mit schlafen
ach so wir wollen unseren heiler holen das natürlich immer sinnvoll da sage ich
nichts
Ich denke immer das sind Alpwachen dabei, das ist unser Turm.
Diese Quest dauert ewig hier.
ich mag die meistens nicht
boah ich merke richtig dass wir die energie ausgeht er aber level 40 alter ich muss noch
level 40 waren ich höre es bestimmt nicht mit 35 auf level 40 muss sein dass
es eine stunde stunde durchhalten noch eine stunde muss ich noch durchhalten
jetzt ist gerade ein bisschen c aber dafür lief die restlichen bgs wie ihr
wie am schnürchen kann ich immer alles perfekt oder prozent perfekt laufen
Ich wollte noch Highlight-Epic machen.
Irgendjemand Bock auf Highlight-Epic?
Der auch 5-Witch-Plus ist?
Also wenn ich dann 40 bin, so dauert der noch ein bisschen.
Aber morgen.
Morgen ist auch noch ein Tag.
Shit, da vorne sind ganz viele.
was geht mit dem alp ab und hinten von hinten als
scheiße hat mir ist hat und sein
der altwurzel ist kaknuk
schnell schnell schnell schnell damage damage damage
oh noch mehr alps
ach fuck von hinten pushen die hips rein
wie habe ich meinen kompass gerade kleiner gemacht
macht
wie habe ich meinen kompass eben kleiner gemacht die ganze freund
da gibt es einen klopf für ansonsten kann man das auch hier machen kompass kompass kompass
chat sie den kompass
wenn ich blind hier gibt es immer den kompass normalen kompass da ist doch jetzt
36 sind wir schon mal
36 3 das wird
die leben noch
leben noch gesagt werden
Vertraue und glaube, es hilft, es heilt die göttliche Kraft!
Ja, sieben Stunden, das geht noch.
Das geht mindestens noch eine Stunde, bis wir Level 40 sind.
Oh, das ist gerade sehr zäh hier in Molvik.
Aber so sah es die anderen BGs für die Gegner aus.
Wir haben die ja die ganze Zeit weggeruppelt.
Hier sind wir etwas in Unterzahl.
Mir persönlich wäre es lieber, einfach FVR-Zone Killtask zu machen.
Das geht super schnell.
Das BG hier geht mir immer auf den Sack.
Teilweise zwischenzeitlich sind hier sogar komplette Gruppen rumgelaufen.
Pre-Made Gruppen, die sich auf MOLWIG spezialisiert haben.
Als man noch XP und RP off machen konnte.
Da ist was.
einer noch ein fisch noch guck mal wir haben das erste mal eine waffe mit einem ordentlichen skin
auf fack fack fack zum turm
der ist fast tot der dude fast tot oh man haut einer noch einmal drauf
alter jetzt blitzblock da ich fasse es nicht
ich glaube die leute sind auch ein bisschen müde gerade weil da hätten wir nicht sterben
müssen gerade hier hierbei richtig crazy client der hat man wirklich sterben müssen gerade
leckt auch ein bisschen jetzt war eben ist auch online gaming immer
wenn man auf den sack kriegt ist die standard ausrede das hat geleckt
Charlie ist unten.
Ja, Kollege, ist klar.
Da hat er sich einen abgestrafed.
okay da geht jetzt eine komplette mit gruppe drauf auf die hips hier da sollten wir mit
gut
Alter, warum sind die schon alle so pro-gefärbt?
Das sieht ja richtig
professional hier,
richtig pro-Gamers am Start.
Alle mit Level-Rüstung,
grau und gefärbt und Skins.
Warum die das her?
Wobei, weiß ich nicht, ob das Skins waren.
Vielleicht nicht so auf dem Haufen stehen.
Aha.
die trinkt jetzt gerade nicht hören
oder geht es noch immer schnell sind vielleicht
ja doch noch geht es weil die dies bahn doch irgendwann
gut
ok probier doch mal das kippen
ob es hinkriegen so gratis level wäre jetzt natürlich hier chefskis da werden wir deutlich
schneller weil dann sind wir im endeffekt 38 so gut wie dann ist es zu 40 wirklich nicht mehr viel
okay das kannst du vergessen
bade es leckt es ist lecky es ist ziemlich lecky gerade
ich glaube wir haben wahrscheinlich wieder 3000 3500 spieler harrison fjord
die da haben wir auch immer kreativer das war guter name
Oh fuck! Einmal nicht geguckt!
Der Pax, der Pax Cerca kriegt jetzt auf den Sack.
wir sollten das schaffen wir sind ja deutlich mehr fünf sekunden stehe ich noch
eben
den kasten schnappen wir uns
Will der jetzt abhauen?
Ja, will er.
Aber der kommt nicht weit.
Sehr schön.
Da hab ich noch ein paar RPs gemacht.
Jetzt gehen wir Quest ab.
Dann sind wir 37.
train 1234 die einen ganzen schaden gibt es dafür das hat jetzt voll gelohnt zu trainieren
er alles gestellt
Was haben sie jetzt vor?
Was haben wir jetzt vor?
Haben wir noch vor BG, oder?
Okay.
Ah, wir machen eine Quest.
Wir machen eine PvE-Quest-Loop.
Okay.
Ja, es ist auch gerade echt zu anstrengend hier im BG.
Es ist Gona, müssen wir glauben.
20 Jahre altes Game, ich brauche länger zum laden für was neues.
Das ist ein Bug in Windows Defender.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir die Quest machen, oder?
Ge...
Okay, das war zwar nicht meine Frage, aber...
Wo ist Nana denn hin?
Woll' weg.
Weil mit dem Dungeon wär die 39.
Ah, wir können ein Portal machen.
ok wir machen wohl den 88 mann dann schnell das geht auch zackig zu fünf
minuten oder halb fünf minuten für level das deutlich schneller als in
molvik die leute wollen schon echt tg machen tg ist das langweiligste was es
gibt die jesen level 50 raid wo du im endeffekt nur sticks und eine taste
drückst
also wirklich richtig von arsch
ja und h mtp
Oh.
Accept.
Boah, ich bin echt müde, Leute.
Aber 40 muss heute sein.
Ich hab keinen Bock,
morgen einzuloggen.
Ich seh nen Raid, in dem ich Level machen könnte
und kann nicht hin, weil ich kein Char hab,
der Level 40 plus ist.
50er Heiler lohnt sich nicht.
Okay.
Let's go.
ok hier die paar bosse brauer
der mit jet vom skala der hatte hatte der nicht noch eine text speed text
speed komponente mit dabei oder war das eine extra sache moment da muss man
kurz gucken ja charplan skalde das ist wirklich bloß damage war das auf live
dann der fall kam das irgendwann dass der auch noch eine attack speed komponente
drin hat
ja dachte ich auch dass sie mit attack speed mit drin ist aber steht irgendwo was
davon da
ok fahrzeug gebasht werden kann ich meine game ne fetzt ist das glaube ich
Das war's für heute.
erst fähig kaputt
spodas schon wieder
das ding ist übelste übelste labyrinth in dem dann schon check ich nix der nächste
dann schon ist auch so ein labyrinth da check ich auch nichts ich laufe da für
den leuten der mehrere ebenen übereinander
du weißt nicht welche mobs wo stehen das ganze wir
und als double scout perfekt bin ich echt gut ist besser als man denkt
Oh, nice, next.
Ich mach Brain-Aff-Modus, Leute, jetzt.
Tap.
Anytime. Tap. Anytime.
Gehen wir da runter, oder?
Ich hab hier keinen Durchblick.
Hab any timer so mehr kann man von mir gerade nicht erwarten
Da unten wollen wir langen
Oh mein brain ist kaputt
wirst du dich bald den nächsten anytime style kriegen dass ich immer mit dem town drauf hauen muss
Residenzliebherr.
Das lasse ich jetzt als Overlay, das ist genau richtig.
Also Dark Dungeon Content und wie ich mich fühle gerade.
Nur so, ohne tieferen Sinn.
Jetzt so einen Caster mit ein bisschen
Ehe
aber es war ja auch fakt da kommt ja noch einiges
mein sieg creditworthy sieger
was wir sind 37 37 und ein paar mobs hier oder was
gut so aber recht sein oder 37 trainieren war schnell kurz am moment wir sind die ganze zeit
schon 37 alle ich kann gut man hat sich einfach nichts bewegt
der frucht der frucht dass der frucht haben war hat man sich echt wird die
namen sich damals ausgedacht hat für die mobs kommt man auch so was ich meine
immer noch besser als ford berg oder das andere fisch vorhanden ist
so war
er ist ja nicht sehr vegan der wagen denke ich mal
es leckt seht ihr das auch dass es zwischendurch immer so kleines black
black spikes hat ja chat fragen sie auch gerade lag fragezeichen leck leck leck
aber jetzt ja fertig
moment da heißt wirklich einer high lord tarnkappe
habe ich mal gespannt wie high lord tarnkappe aussieht
Wie gestellts da ist.
Guck hier, Highlord Tarnkappe.
Sind wir hier richtig? Ich habe hier keine, null Orientierung drinne. Absolut null.
Ist das Highlord?
Highlord Tarnkappe! Da ist er.
Jetzt bin ich aber enttäuscht.
Der sieht aus wie jeder nur noch 15 andere Wehrwolf
und ist nicht mal getarnt.
Fake.
Vielleicht ist ja eigentlich der eigentliche Trick,
dass er das gar nicht ist.
Dass er so gut gestelzt ist,
dass man nur seinen Fake
Mob
zwei stück noch okay dann haben wir es
rege chat prege level 40 wenn das durch ist die 35 plus ziehen sich echt gerade richtig krass
Pesham dauert das ganze bis 22 aber länger wird es nicht dauern weil dann
gehe ich auch penne ich bin kaputt bin keine elf stunden mehr gewöhnt
Wo sind die Mobs, die man killen muss?
Moment, das hier ist nicht der eigentliche Übergang wie oben
Der sieht bloß genau so aus
Oder doch?
Ach, was weiß ich
Hier blickt doch keiner durch
Ne, wir müssen hier runter
shiny kennt sich aus perfekt
auch guck mal hier sieht es tatsächlich mal ein bisschen anders aus
wo sind die andere crew pin da war doch noch eine
Ich war fast aus der Map gefallen, glaube ich.
Bin zu hängen geblieben.
In Dark ist es immer gefährlich, wenn man hier an solchen Sachen hängen bleibt,
dann klitscht man manchmal auch außerhalb der Map.
Aber da ist nix.
Also man kann nicht irgendwie durch klitschen, um irgendwo anders rein zu klitschen.
Man fällt da einfach runter und dann bringt einem das auch nix.
Dann wird man zu Pinstorm geportet.
Aber wisst ihr wofür Darug echt ein gutes Beispiel ist?
Da müssen wir jetzt ernsthaft noch auf Respawn warten.
Wo Darug ein gutes Beispiel für ist, wie cheatsicher es ist die Sachen Serverseitig
zu machen in da gibt es im prinzip keine cheats es gibt einen schied ja aber das
ist würde ich jetzt sagen das ist jetzt nicht so ein klassischer cheat was
kennt es gibt es gibt die es gibt zwei sachen es gibt einmal radar wo du quasi
weil das kommuniziert der komplett unverschlüsselt da gibt es leute die
haben das software programmiert das ausliest und die leute auf der map
anzeigt die du selbst gar nicht liest das natürlich schon schieten und man kann
wohl mit packets manipulieren auch speed klatsch sich sich holen dass man
schneller rennt aber das ding ist halt das ist halt serverseitig super super
schnell detectable was bietet speed speed er kann zack er kann also server
Oberseitig ist halt eindeutig größer kleines seite für sichere beziehungsweise
licht freier und und cheater freier online games
Ich will nicht auf riesen sporn warten please präge prägen gibt sich im pre mod ja auch
Bray?
Nein.
Doch, sowas in der Richtung gibt's.
Was für eine ist denn das hier überhaupt, wo wir sind?
Hai?
Ne, King.
king wie man das bitteschön aussprechen soll
sie werden es ist einfach mal geräusch geräusch und in spracherkennung rein
dann kommt es raus als mob name
Moment, wer fehlt uns denn jetzt noch?
Fehlt uns noch einer?
Moldov, wo ist der Typ?
und doch wo ist er denn da müssen wir irgendwie sonst wie rum
jetzt sagt ich hoffe müssen einfach nur hier vorne rechts lang jetzt damit wir
den finden
übrigens beide wieder aus ego perspektive sieht man sofort was passiert alles klar ich weiß nicht
ob es irgendjemand gibt der dauer in ego perspektive spielt aber mein erkennt tut man nichts
jetzt ja jetzt und dann runter okay und dann haben was auf ich fall nicht aus
der map
ob da vorne ist der letzte boss aus hört sich so anders machen die irgendwas
spezielles sie machen überhaupt nichts ich stehe da einfach nur sinnlos im
dungeon rum und warten abgefahren zu werden ist auch nicht so als hätten
irgendwelche spezial fähigkeiten
da ist er
Ich mag den Dungeon nicht.
so als haben wir ja als kommen wir zum eingang
bestens wir rennen durch
hier
ja das rauf please jetzt irgendwas mit ae cast wäre super und ich meine damit
kein charme dort ich weiß was ordentlich der mit schmack
charme dort zählt nicht für mich
ok next
ok, Inventar ist auch fast voll
Ah hier sind wir oben, okay nice
fast
fast da sind wir, jawoll
gibt es hier brauche ich noch irgendwas
besser oder schlechter als man anderes
alles okay und wo gehen wir jetzt hin nachdem 38 sind
agier okay
Hauptsache hier raus.
MonkaW.
Ach, hier ist das.
Okay.
Das ist da, wo sein Char gespawnt ist.
nf gehen wir jetzt okay okay er ist raus geflogen kann das sein
na na na ist rausgefroren
glaube ich
wir machen den fc gut na ja nf ist super angenehm
NF ist super angenehm. Da machen wir jetzt zwei, drei Killquests und dann sind wir easy 40, das gibt mega XP.
Ja, I didn't even bother to go to the live servers. I was on live, I think, I can't really remember, 10 years ago or so.
Also in the beginning I had big hopes.
Es sei.
The time they overtook the game from EA.
I thought, yeah, new developer and they will.
Have more motivation, but then they fucked the game and did nothing.
Nichts. Das letzte was ich gelesen habe war, dass das Live-Game von zwei Jungs weitergegeben wurde.
Bestes Englisch, ne?
Muss ich dazugeben.
Massive Poggers.
Wir sitzen alle in einem Boot.
Ich glaube wir machen die Mid-Quests.
Die Mid-Quests bringen uns auf jeden Fall bis 40.
Alle Accepten.
Wow.
Ich will das aber wissen.
Die Mid-Quests reichen komplett aus.
Für 40. Easy.
Aber gut, man.
Wenn er alle accepten will, accepte ich alle.
Michael, 5 Spelianen.
Ja, der ist auch am Start noch.
Es gibt Leute,
die sind Anfang an mit dabei.
Okay, nice.
Let's go.
Der Chain-Lore.
Ja.
Chain-Lore fehlt echt noch.
Brauch ich, dass wir wieder jemanden time-outen können,
weil er ASCII-Cocks spammt oder so.
Oh.
unser heiler ist happy über wie gut sie wollen wirklich ja das ist für mich
helfen das kann nur der chain weil der wird ja auch dann time ortet
Okay, let's go.
Das sollte jetzt glücklicherweise schneller gehen.
Also die NF-Quests, die sind richtig gut.
Max, glaubst du eigentlich, du wirst in Discord Copyright striked, wenn du da Anime streamen würdest?
Warum sollte ich um alles in der Welt, sollte ich Anime streamen?
Wie kommst du da drauf?
Ich bin doch wahrscheinlich der Letzte, der Anime streamen sollte.
Aber ich würde höchstwahrscheinlich
Ich glaube das juckt da keinen großartig
Oh Shani let's go
Ich guck nochmal, ob ich alle angenommen habe, aber ja, easy, alles angenommen.
Du meintest, du würdest mit uns schauen, aber Twitch würde das nicht gut finden.
Meinte ich sowas wirklich? Das hört sich nicht nach mir an.
auf geht's
ok 2,7 er die 1,7 level
also schwierig sein 1,7 level muss machen im prinzip müssen wir einfach nur die roten
Punkte hier abarbeiten und dann sind wir easy.
Sind wir easy 40.
Eats.
Was ist das 40? Eats.
Um nicht zu sagen.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
sind wir 40
Aber wann soll man kennen okay, weil man alles klar machen war
einfach tap alles alles weg alles weg hauen egal ob es für die quest braun und ich alles killen
hier stück noch dass wir den killen tatsächlich
auch das nicht
43 gibt es den letzten speed den kriegen wir heute
aber nicht
einfach kurz hier warten die die respawn rate gestern war echt schnell
habe ich da gegner gesehen
da hinten ist was
eine wahl war noch haben wir das ist das ein komisches jettibeschen hier
als 5 von 10 erst
das haben wir schon weil es ja nicht so als müsse man das groß für die xp machen
Okay, eine Stunde noch, Leute
Wenn wir es bis dahin nicht haben, lasse ich es bleiben
Aber ich gehe stark davon aus, dass wir in der Stunde
Easy 40 packen
Wir müssen eigentlich nur 2-3 Quests hier fertig machen
Dann das 39
Und das andere auch, also das müssten wir eigentlich easy hinkriegen
Aber das ist gut.
Also es ist ein echt guter Season Start gewesen.
Level 50 auf dem Heiler.
Quasi instant.
Jetzt 40 plus.
Ball auf dem Skalde.
Das heißt, da kann ich morgen schon mal bei beiden Chars dann die Epic machen und den Skull of 50 machen mit ein paar Raids und dabei Currency farmen.
Vom Heiler mache ich die Drachenquest, dass ich da die ganzen Sachen kaufen kann.
Und nebenbei level ich den Shami und Runi noch.
Wenn das durch ist, ist das auf jeden Fall morgen übermorgen noch zu tun.
Dann level ich einen Char auf Alp, dass ich dort auch Raids mitmachen kann, Currency farmen kann.
Wahrscheinlich mach ich mit Clary auf Alp den Clary zuerst, weil die Hexe ist kein guter Group Char.
Dann kann ich gucken, immer das machen, wo es mir gerade danach ist.
Haben wir das eigentlich nicht geschafft schon?
Du musst doch eigentlich schon fertig sein hier.
Oh, und diese komischen Schneedinger.
Ah, davon brauchen wir noch.
Jetzt haben wir es 10 von 10.
Exzellent.
da ist nächster spot also zwei quests schon mal fertig das
gibt schon mal fast fast level nicht ganz aber fast level 39
Was ist da?
Müssen wir Snow Crabs killen?
Ah, Snow Crabs. 20 Snow Crabs. Ja gut, hier sind glücklicherweise einige.
Alles pullen, alles anhitten.
5 Stück.
6, 7, 8 Stück.
den stück
max ans trinken das sehr gut gut dass du sagst
und trocknen halten sie habe ich schon den ganzen tag heute geschwätzt ich bin
es auch nicht mehr gewöhnt acht stunden am stück zu labern aber ich dachte mir
wenn ich heute den kreisel klein starte auf level 40 plus dann kann ich das auch streamen
das sieht sich nicht gelangweilt vom rechner und macht pv
können bisschen schwätzen und vielleicht ist dann für mich nicht ganz so langweilig
wir haben es ja
also allein schon die drei quest sollten jetzt zumindest level 39 sein
chat gemacht die frage an und leute die zugucken spielt einer von euch eigentlich
auch unter seite nur random irgendwie weil er sonst hier
und wenn ihr da auch spielt also ich gehe mal davon aus auf eben denke mal
auf live wird kaum einer spielen wenn ihr auf ihnen spielt wo spielt ihr
ah weiß ja schön dass du da bist
was muss man hier kick adi die schneeschuh banditen was verkehren
ist so weg hier ist mal die finger von mir
hier.
Wie viele müssen wir noch killen?
Neun Stück?
Neues Sub-Badge?
Oh, das wird echt Zeit.
Ich brauche aber erstmal eine Idee.
Was könnte man als Sub-Badge da noch machen?
Weil den goldenen Keks mit Halskette haben wir ja schon.
Noch dickere Kette?
Ich glaube, wir müssen da komplett neue machen.
Ich glaube wir brauchen ein paar Low-Level-Subs, wo der Keks noch nicht vollständig ist und dann
die bisherigen quasi für ein-Jahres-zwei-Jahres-Sub oder so. Business-Keks, den haben wir sogar,
wir haben einen Business-Keks. Mit Anzug. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich den als Immortrainer habe,
aber gibt es könnte man könnte man benutzen
warum haben wir noch auf den mobs rumpen wir sind fertig oder bin ich schon
fertig braucht ihr nehmen
wenn ich bin ich blind warum machen wir die box noch eine wir sind fertig
herrscher die anderen haben es genauso wenig gecheckt wie ich
da hast du recht allein schon aus dem punkt aus dem grund dürften wir die
batches ist das eigentlich nur neue batches die quasi on top kommen geben
ja das stimmt hast du recht leute sollen ja auch neues kriegen
und jetzt wurde
Aha, okay.
Zwei Stück noch.
Oh.
fünf jahre bin ich so lange wirklich schon am stream so krass ob mir gar
nicht weil du bist seit anfang an dabei
Kommt mir gar nicht so lange vor.
Alter.
Was ist denn da, Dude?
Ja, das zieht bestimmt voll, oder?
ist etwas das schlimme ist auch wenn das eindeutig nicht ernst gemeinte nachricht
ist irgendwie glaube ich traue ich traue dass der michael fünf spieler dazu dass
er das wirklich macht
kann jetzt weitermachen please
zum nächsten mob camp ich bleibe einfach noch gestickt und schlaf halb ein
ok
habe ich das gemacht ist der fall schon gar nicht mehr
Wo rennen wir denn hin?
Ich will einfach nur zum nächsten Spot und diese Scheiß-Quest fertig machen.
Ich dreh durch.
War das das Physik-Grill?
Ne, das mit dem Physik-Grill war das Ebaro, oder?
der auch schon ewig nicht mehr da war
der jetzt ja der jetzt ja lehrer fast fast ist glaube ich
vorstellen die zeit dafür geht
sie brauchen wir letzten stream da stimmt ich bilde mir einen den habe ich tatsächlich das
kann sein ja ja also nicht präsent im kopf hatte ich nicht mehr
bei the way das ist nicht definitiv nicht irish sea was der game hier an
zeigt
Okay, das ist hier Spawnix.
Gleich weiter zum nächsten.
Das hier sackt.
so ein Lurie-Mob, da spawnt immer nur einer.
Wenn wir den hier machen,
dann
sind wir morgen noch da.
Ich werde wahrscheinlich den Stream auch löschen.
Ich lasse dann erst wieder die Sachen fürs Wort.
Wenn ich wieder regulär streame.
Wobei ich kann ihn auch da lassen.
der etwas brain afk berieselung braucht kann in sich im vorteil gucken ok
ist hier war sie nicht verstehen
also in so mmo in so alten mmo ist es gerade wo die leute auch noch älter sind und so und
das schon über 20 jahren oder 15 über 50 was ist das gegen 15 jahren spielen
Es gibt Leute, die schaffen es legit, nicht geradeaus zu laufen in einem Spiel, ohne dabei verloren zu gehen. Das ist jetzt kein Spaß. Also wenn man in einer geraden Linie läuft, sind die nach einer Minute, sagen die, looblies, looblies, I lost you, looblies, looblies.
Du musst einfach nur geradeaus rennen, ohne irgendwas zu machen und die Leute sind lost.
Das ist eine Sache, das werde ich nie verstehen.
Können wir die Wölfe hier nicht auch bashen?
Hier unten?
Ne, nur die hier.
Ne, das kann nicht dement sein.
das ist so ich das ist so ich verstehe das ich kann das nicht nachvollziehen wie kam man beim
gerade das ist das wissen die laufen geradeaus und dann auf einmal so wo sind die leute hin und
ein habo sind die jetzt sind sie weg das habe ich auch schon in anderen mmo gesehen das ist
mir auch in woche schon aufgefallen ich das kann ich weiß nicht wie das passieren kann so
10 von 10 da ist so haben wir lasst uns abgeben oder dann sollten wir jetzt
zumindest 839 39 5 oder so sein
geboten glaube ich vermutlich denke ich
sie bekommen gucken 50 zum thema tik tok ich habe es ja letztens auf twitter
geschrieben weil letztens beim friseur gar nicht richtig beim barbershop heute
geht man schon immer zum friseur
auf hake ja ich habe mich verportet aus steht wo soll man hin
guck mal leute wir sind fast 40 zumindest war ich beim barbershop und
ich habe da gewartet weil ich erst in zehn minuten dran war oder so und vor
mir saß einer so ich habe dem zugeguckt und dann musste der friseur mal an die
kasse für weiß nicht eine minute oder so wenn es hoch kommt einfach mal kurz
an die kasse 60 sekunden ja und da hat der typ dann unter diesem abdenkmantel vom friseur sein
handy raus gefummelt tik tok aufgemacht sich schnell drei shorts also wo gemerkt der friseur
hat gesagt sekunde mit gleich wieder da ist vor zur kasse und war auch gleich wieder da und in
derzeit das hat er nicht ausgehalten einfach kurz zu warten und hat unter dem
friseur dienst oder diese abdeckung sein handy rausgeholt tickte aufgemacht sich
drei shorts reingezogen bis der friseur nach 60 sekunden wieder da war also das
verstehe ich meine aufmerksamkeit das ist ja das kann man immer mal
aufmerksamkeit nennen das ist das ist ja keine aufmerksamkeit spanne mehr wie alt
ja ich würde schon sagen nach nach super generation also wahrscheinlich so 15 oder
so
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Wir sind verloren, ja.
Aber das hat sich so...
Das hat sich so...
Ich glaube, jede...
das hat jede generation gedacht und dann ging es trotzdem irgendwie weiter hast
mal wieder leute der es bahn angemacht weil nein
ob ich nicht jetzt nicht so als würde ich das jeden tag machen dass hier der
e pic
nicht der e pic von der e pic
nur friede sollen wir kennen genau
die sie denn sleeper ich will 40 werden einfach nur 40 und nix
ich froh wenn das durch
40 ist fast die 50.
40 auf 50 geht komplett AFK eigentlich.
Kann sich auf den Rate stellen und gut ist.
Ist das dein Dark Cursor oder hast du ihn immer?
Ne, das ist nur mein Dark Cursor.
Damit man hier ordentlich was sieht.
Game.
Game, please.
rege rege rege
auch eine neue waffe ich mache ja ungetemplet und ohne der
weiß überhaupt kein der mensch guckt es mal letztes jahr hätte ich den mob
wahrscheinlich zu schottet oder mit mit mit ordentlich schaut der sport schottet
doch doch bg level geht ziemlich gut aber mollweg sagt gerade weil weg ist
mit hips und alps voll
und ich will einfach noch bis 40 das ist alles
was da los warum sind da gegner
ob nur die wm fast alles wo sind der bade der bade hat resistiert okay
Kann ich mal bitte einen Speed-Tick bekommen?
hier
wo kommen die ganzen 50er her
kurze frage wie war denn noch mal deine linux terminal konfiguration das war
irgendwas wo western kitty zusammenschneiden nur western du meinst für die bilder im terminal
das ist das kit der kitty autor hat sich dieses bilder protokoll ausgedacht diese
mögliche methode wie man bilder im terminal anzeigt aber das hat mit
kitty nichts wirklich was nicht was zu tun western kann das auch
also brauchst kitty nicht installiert das ist nur western
Wo gehen wir denn hin?
Wir springen bestimmt ohne Skate oder so ab, oder?
Oder was haben wir vor?
Ich hoffe, der
Group disembarkt uns, sonst
fährt die Hälfte weiter.
Oh, wir haben einen am Steg vergessen.
Ich raste aus.
Die Leute.
Alter.
Wie brain AFK sie immer sind.
ich war heute 40 ist mir egal ich mache nur solo 40 und kill noch fünf mobs
ich benutze plan west haben ja
So, ich denke mal, der disembarkt uns hier jetzt.
Oder?
Ja, macht er.
Da ist ein Lagerfeuer.
Obacht!
Auf!
Weiß man schon, wo Polemo Pilz diesen spielt?
Ja, Pilz muss ich gar nicht überlegen.
Der wird hip spielen.
You play like shit!
Und Polemo spielt Alp, soweit ich weiß.
Alp level ich mir auch noch zwei Chars.
Alter.
Können wir jetzt please was machen?
Ich will Level 40 werden.
Ich raste aus.
Auf was warten wir denn jetzt noch?
wir müssen hier glaube ich so klein so ist schnee schnee riesen killen
darauf den auf den einen der afg
jetzt aber
face reveal im wasser auf in der peking suppe war das doch oder
max max liegt in der peking suppe also der richter peking super hat man
richtig Bock drauf gerade.
Astro Headset Spiegelung.
Ne, ich hatte den Astro Headset.
Turtle Beach hatte ich.
Turtle Beach hatte ich ein paar.
Habe ich auch vorgestellt.
Und jetzt habe ich seit Jahren
das Biodynamics MMX 300
und es geht einfach.
Ich habe bei dem eigentlich nur eine Sache gemacht,
einmalig, und das ist die Ohrpolster getauscht.
Der Rest ist,
ja, und einen neuen Pop-Schutz drauf
auf das Mikrofon, aber das war's.
fährst du aktuell fahrrad ja ich bin von paar jahren habe ich die erste die runde der der der
die erste runde in dieser saison gemacht ich habe ein bisschen ich habe es ein bisschen schleifen
lassen ich habe die letzten fünf monate kaum was gemacht weder fahrradfahren noch joggen aber ich
bin gar nicht so schlecht mittlerweile also dass ich scheine ganz gut ausdauer
aufgebaut zu haben weil ich bin jetzt letztens wieder ein bisschen vermehrt
gerät und es ging eigentlich ganz gut ja wenn auch ein bisschen langsamer und ich
bin ziemlich lahm geworden im vergleich zu einem vor einem halben jahr was mir
richtig also mich richtig fertig gemacht hat ist das fahrradfahren ich bin zwei
stunden gefahren letztens erste sagen wir mal so zwei drittel ja zwei drittel
kommt hin ungefähr denke ich zwei drittel der strecke gar keine probleme
gegen ein recht gut und dann ging nichts mehr
es lag nicht daran weil ich zu wenig gegessen habe oder so es ging einfach
nichts mehr ich habe ich habe nur sehe ich habe nur
semi in die pedale getreten schon haben die übelste oberschenkel gebrannt
ich bin jetzt ich bin das letzte drittel mit zeit halten euch fest ich glaube 120
watt oder so gefahren im durchschnitt 120 das ist so das ist das ist
regeneration watt zahl so früher gewesen das fährt man für für regenerationen
fahrten
Ich glaube, wir sind 40 eigentlich jetzt mit der Quest.
Aber wir können ruhig noch die letzte halbe Stunde...
Wirklich, also das war...
Da ging gar nichts mehr.
Ich habe sofort gemerkt.
Aber ich war halt auch der Richtung nichts mehr geübt.
Max, hast du bei dir auf der Arbeit auch mal die Möglichkeit zu stehen?
Ja, nachdem ich eigentlich fast immer Homeoffice machen kann, außer einen Tag die Woche,
kann ich hier an meinem Schreibtisch stehen oder sitzen.
Und ich habe meinen Hometrainer nebendran.
theoretisch könnte ich mich bei langen langweiligen stundenlangen meetings auch
auf mein fahrrad setzen und eine runde radeln mache ich aber nicht könnte ich
aber auf der arbeit selbst haben wir den stehschreibtisch aber da habe ich
natürlich kein fahrrad
ein aufwand für schreibt ich brauche ich nicht bewegt mich genug
Ich habe einen Stehschreibtisch.
Kann ich hochfahren,
wenn es mir danach ist.
Aber ansonsten, Laufband brauche ich nicht.
Laufband ist was für Leute, die sich dann quasi,
die halt auch die ewig lange Zeit
vorm Rechner hocken, aber sich danach
oder davor nicht bewegen oder dazwischen.
Ich brauche kein Laufband.
Okay.
Oh, jetzt kommt das Ding.
Jetzt müssen wir
Groove Protector und Beatles killen.
Klippenkäfer.
Cliff Beatles.
Aber wir haben sicher 40 danach.
Easy.
Wir haben sogar wahrscheinlich mit dieser Quest jetzt schon 40.
Weil so zwei Bubbles könnte das geben.
Man nennt das aus irgendwelchen Gründen Bubbles.
Diese Einheiten.
Weil die früher rund waren.
Im alten UI.
sind heute noch und naja
was ist denn ein ständiges ui ich muss sagen ich finde das was ist das besagen ist das was
sie haben auf ihnen ich finde das eigentlich ziemlich gut für die folge wenn man das mal
mit dem cluster vergleicht was ein was das das offizielle standard hat also ich
finde das das beste jetzt nicht streams neidmann und sie irgendwie killen oder
so
die crew protector dinger ghost ist ghost eigentlich komplett outdated und
Buzan basiert doch auf Ghost UI, oder?
Ich glaube, Buzan ist Ghost UI.
Oh.
Wird das gar nicht.
Waren das die Holzfäller, die wir killen müssen?
Nee.
Chopper.
Doch, Chopper müssen wir killen.
ja chopper helikopter
master chopper damit haben wir auf jeden fall 40 wenn wir die quest jetzt hier
haben
easy 40 wir sollten doch so schon haben
was macht die bäume denn da
also ich wie gesagt ich glaube dass bis an die ui ist eine weiterentwicklung von groß
Also kannst du auch ruhig Pisanen-UI verwenden.
Da hast du auch die Eden-Karten und so dabei.
Chopper!
Jawoll!
So, damit sind wir auf jeden Fall 40.
endlich also wir sind mit zwei easy easiest sind wir 40
sobald wir die quest abgeben
bin ich schon 39 und alle anderen nicht auch habe ich mehr xp ach so weil ich
meine quest schon abgegeben habe
oh beatles
cliff beatles
Was war es?
Wir könnten zurückfahren.
Oder vielleicht will er noch eine Quest.
Ich mache auch noch eine Quest fertig.
mit dem ich meine ich habe noch 20 minuten zeit
die männer ich schreibe ich schreibe mal dass ich
den spätesten 30 minuten weg muss
Wo ist, wo ist denn unser Bersi?
Guck, Leute, das ist das, was ich meine.
Einfach geradeaus laufen und irgendwie...
Was ist das schon wieder?
Was ist das hier schon wieder?
Wie kann man verloren gehen beim geradeaus laufen?
Jetzt stehen wir hier und warten auf einen, weil er keinen Bock hat am Rechner zu sitzen.
Wie alle anderen, die das Spiel spielen.
Sowas nervt mich immer.
Mich nervt es nicht, wenn einer rumnoopt oder nicht weiß, wo er drauf hauen muss oder so.
Das ist okay, kann jeder spielen, wie er will.
Aber so dieses, während alle anderen spielen und was machen, AFK gehen, jetzt warten sieben Leute, das fuckt mich ab.
du wirst du wirst die season nicht spielen warum beste zeit beste beste da
kursion ever
es ist nicht so als kann man jede jede woche eine neue season spielen oder so
welches level bist du 40 also ich habe jetzt hier noch dinge aber ich habe noch quest zu
abgabe und 40 damit hat sich für heute erledigt das ist auch gut weil ab 40 kann ich auf rates
wo ich quasi passiv durch rennen level parade kriege da habe ich jetzt nämlich weil man heiler
ist ja 50 genau man heiler ist ja 50 und da geht dann mit dem lohnt sich nicht so sehr auf rates
zu gehen dann schau 40 zu haben ist optimal bevor ich den skala 50 mache mache ich den
schami oder den juni noch 40 dass ich immer so passiv quasi die die die levels holen kann du
machst bei black somit naja gut wie sieht es da eigentlich aus da habe ich immer mal ab und zu
ein bisschen was auf reddit gelesen gibt es da irgendwann schon ungefähr einen release zeitpunkt
Ich meine, das ist natürlich schwierig. Ihr müsst da halt beim Starten am besten halt irgendwie die zweite Hälfte von der Eden-Season abpassen.
Dass da ein paar Leute hingehen.
Weil ich glaube, wenn eine Eden-Season gestartet ist, wird keiner in der, keine Ahnung, einen Monat nach Season-Start irgendwie auf einen anderen Server wechseln.
Was halt cool wäre, wenn es irgendwie so getimt ist, dass ich das alles nicht so sehr in die Quere käme.
Also dass man quasi jeden Season spielen kann und wenn jeden Season dann am Auslaufen ist,
eine Blackthorn Season oder so.
Dass man quasi zweimal im Jahr einen Season Start hat irgendwo.
aber lernt bestimmt einiges bei das passiert auf open da auch gerne also auf dem kram von
wie hieß der server noch mal vergessen atlas in den ich phoenix atlas
Open Dark
Phoenix
Phoenix ist
also
ja
ja ich hab gelesen
das ist ja alles noch auf der ursprünglichen
also ursprünglich war das ja mal
wie hieß das
Dark Dark und Light oder so
Das war irgendeine olle C-Sharp.net Framework Software, die ja mittlerweile einige Free Shards etwas modernisiert haben.
Dawn of Light, nicht Dark of Light.
Ja, irgendwie so, genau.
Und läuft es eigentlich mittlerweile auf .NET Core?
Oder immer noch nur auf .NET Framework?
So die aktuellen Sachen.
Ist Core, na immerhin.
Ja gut, offiziell heißt es ja nicht .NET Core mehr, aber halt, habe ich jetzt mal gesagt, zur Abgrenzung von .NET Framework.
Na immerhin.
Ach war das nicht alles, oder was?
Questlog ist fertig.
Find ich aber cool, dass wir zwei Leute am Start haben, die ein bisschen Erfahrung mit
dem Freeshot-Backend haben. Ich hab da auch schon ein bisschen durchgeklickt,
mal auf github aber wenn man sich da nicht tiefer einiges blickt man nichts
was hast du dir zu dem witcher trailer gedacht
Ey, gesagt habe ich mir, hat sich der Hype bei mir ein bisschen in Grenzen gehalten.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich so Bock drauf habe, Ciri nochmal zu spielen.
Vor allem müssen sie sich ja storytechnisch irgendwas ausdenken, warum Ciri nicht mehr auf einmal so OP ist.
Ganz ehrlich, ich hätte auch nichts gegen nochmal Geralt gehabt.
Oder ein eigener Witcher.
auf serie habe ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so großen bock zu spielen wobei
man aber sagen muss so sehr interessiert mich jetzt auch nicht wer die
hauptfigur da ist sondern das spiel taugt die also ich ich traue cd projekt
red durchaus zu da auch was gutes daraus zu stricken
wir haben einen guten track record an games ja mit mit cyberpunk haben sie ein
bisschen verkackt am anfang aber mittlerweile soll es ja wirklich gutes
game sein ich habe es nicht mehr angefasst
das heißt jetzt übrigens auch leute wenn das auf dort netz auf dem neuen dort
läuft dass man theoretisch jetzt auch sein dark server auf linux laufen lassen
kann oder
weil so was für das man dafür unbedingt windows braucht ist ja eine zumutung weil
ich meine windows offen windows auf dem desktop ist ja schon für arsch aber windows server alter
es heißt ja nicht unbedingt dass nur weil die runtime cross-plattform ist dass es nicht
irgendwelche anderen die Penalty hat.
Ja, läuft. Okay, nice.
Okay, also läuft das
wirklich. Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Ja, gut.
Immerhin.
Es ist schade,
dass man die Leute, die quasi
Eden und so machen, man kann das ja in keinster
Weise supporten so richtig. Das Einzige,
was man halt machen kann, ist,
das in einem stream zeigen oder in dem video erwähnen und so dass eben mehr
leute spielen weil du kannst ja nicht supporten du kannst weil alles was
irgendwie den anschein erweckt bei einem free start dass sie damit geld verdienen
würden würde halt sofort die rechtsabteilung vom spiel quasi vom
hersteller auf den plan rufen ihr wollt auf vorgriff sieht das anders
aus da interessiert die ganzen private server das nicht und die machen alle
billigen Cash Crap mit im Shop.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich würde das Projekt
supporten. Ich würde mir
ein Eden-T-Shirt bestellen,
eine Eden-Kaffeetasse oder
whatever oder keine Ahnung.
Ich würde da auch was spenden
für das Projekt, sei es nur für Serverkosten oder irgendwie.
Aber die müssen da halt vorsichtig sein.
Aber ich finde es blöd.
Und ganz im Ernst,
ich hätte gar keine Schmerzen damit,
wenn man wirklich spenden könnte,
dass
wenn die Bock drauf hätten, dass
1-2 Leute Fulltime dran arbeiten könnten
wenn es
würde allen nur zugute kommen
die könnten was machen, worauf sie Bock haben
und
die Spieler hätten noch mehr Content und Sachen
eventuell vielleicht auch mal ein paar Tools bauen
dass sie vielleicht sogar irgendwann mal eigene Zonen
bauen können, was auch immer, man weiß es ja nicht
aber das geht halt nicht
weil sobald du irgendwas hast
was nach Geld verdienen aussieht
kommt die Rechtsabteilung von
na ok, ob die Rechtsabteilung von Prozort
überhaupt existent ist, keine Ahnung.
Aber gibt's Probleme. Bist du schneller
weg vom Fenster, als du gucken kannst.
Ziemlich kacke, hä?
Weil könnte man donaten
Für Eden
Hätte ich schon längst donatet
Ja und sei es nur
Und sei es nur
Dass man die Serverkosten übernehmen kann
Es läuft soweit
Ich weiß auf Hetzer
Eden.
Billig, ja, den habe ich irgendwo mal gesehen.
Ich glaube, wenn man die IP pinkt und Trace routet,
sieht man auch Hetzner.
Weiß nicht, auf welchem Hetzner,
auf welcher Kiste, aber es wird nicht die billigste
VM sein.
Dementsprechend
kostet das bestimmt schon ein paar hundert Euro im Monat.
Also,
blöd, dass man nicht spenden kann. Ich hätte schon öfters
was gespendet für Eden.
Bestes Game, beste Version.
Leistes Entwicklerteam
Und wenn man sich überlegt
Die machen alles besser als der Hersteller
Wo Geld und Manpower
Dahinter steckt, wobei das auch nicht mehr stimmt
Da arbeiten ja angeblich
Nur noch zwei Leute dran
Haben wir es geschafft, Leute
Fucking shit, man
Fünf Minuten, dann hau ich ab
ich habe ja ein locker level 40 guck mal level 40 fast so schon und ich habe noch
zwei quest zum abgeben haben dann wahrscheinlich sogar 40,3 oder so
ich meine an manchen world of warcraft private server aber in leute fulltime
mal gucken wenn ich auf blackstone spiele
schauen wir noch ein feierlicher video ich gehe dann pennt so kaputt
haben wir jetzt zurück
Sounds.
Gibt es eine lustige Story zu?
Wusstet ihr, dass die
Sounds der Monster in Dark Age of Camelot
dass das
Stock-Sounds sind.
Also quasi sowas, wie man heute
als Stock-Fotos kennt.
Gibt's ja auch für Sounds.
Und zwar
angeblich haben damals
die Entwickler
keine Möglichkeit, also sie hatten da kein Studio
oder Leute, die sich gut mit Sounds auskennen und so.
Und die haben so eine
Stock-Sound-Footage
CD gekauft.
Und da waren halt, was weiß ich,
300 verschiedene Sound-Files drauf
und daraus haben sie halt ausgewählt, das was am besten passt.
Deswegen hören sich die Mobs in Dark teilweise so komisch an.
Weil das Sounds sind, die nicht explizit für diese Mobs gemacht wurden,
sondern einfach Sounds aus so einer Stock-Sound-Collection.
Deswegen hören die sich so weird an, so teilweise überhaupt nicht passend zu den Mobs.
Habe ich mal in irgendeinem Blogpost von der Dark-Entwicklung gelesen,
dass das Sounds sind, die sie irgendwo
auf irgendeiner CD gefunden haben.
Vielleicht stimmt es auch hinten und vorne nicht.
Aber will ich mal eingelesen zu haben.
Wenn man sich überlegt, die haben das ganze Spiel
glaube ich in eineinhalb Jahren entwickelt
damals, also jetzt Base Game, natürlich nicht
jetzt hier alles, was wir hier haben.
Heute bist du bei einer
Spieleentwicklung in eineinhalb Jahren noch nicht mehr über
Konzeptart rausgefühlt.
Zockst du noch ein Singleplayer-Game?
Ja, ich will unbedingt Kingdom Come Deliverance
spielen. Eins
und dann zwei.
Ja, Avowed ist so ein Ding...
Also ich mag Obsidian, ich habe fast alle so die Klassik-RPGs von Obsidian gespielt.
Aber Avowed hat mich nicht so geschockt.
Obwohl es ja wohl in der Pillars of Eternity Welt spielt.
Da muss ich aber sagen, Pillars 1 hat mir vom Setting deutlich besser gefallen als 2.
entsprechend keine ahnung wie doll ich das finde moment wir gehen nicht heim
wir gehen alb monka ist please ich will einfach nur heim quest abgeben und level
fast 41 vielleicht sogar sein
die reicht
Oh, wisst ihr was?
Was das, wisst ihr was der schlimmste Emote ist,
was mich immer mega triggert?
Das da.
Und noch schlimmer.
Aber das da, das da ist ganz schlimm.
Ja, Manu, das ist aber...
Das finde ich gut.
Und in Dark hast du manche Leute,
die machen so.
Das ist wirklich so...
Ausgeburt der Hölle, Alter.
Ja.
Die...
Ja, das ist auch nicht so dolle.
Ja, aber das Zwinker-Ding ist das Schlimmste.
Also früher haben die
Mädels immer in MMO-Chats
den Nasen-Smiley gemacht.
Ist auch nicht mehr angesagt jetzt.
Ja, heute, heute, Uwe, ja.
Ist es eigentlich, dass die Amis richtige Probleme haben, das Wort Uwe auszusprechen?
Ich bin der Uwe, ich bin auch dabei.
Wie ging das?
Hallo, ich bin der Uwe und ich bin auch dabei.
Also Uwe können die nicht aussprechen.
weil weil you you you wii das kriegen die klinik gewaggen
jetzt hier ist die wollen wir wirklich noch albquests machen ich kann ja mehr
ich will aufhören für heute genug dauer please
der ist hartnäckig scharney kennt keine gnade zwei noch albquests gemacht
Ich kann schon gar nicht mehr selbst laufen. Ich kann nur noch Stick, Stick, Brain AFK machen.
und die angeblich sind hier irgendwelche mobs ach die viecher ok rey book ich
Ich pull mal die Viecher von da hinten.
Da ist ja noch mehr.
Komm mal her.
Lettland Bomber.
Ah, Bowner, nicht Bomber.
Wollte gerade sagen.
Was?
Sieht nicht irgendwie gefährlich aus.
aber Bounder, was? Pounder?
Bounder.
Was auch immer das heißt.
Aber eine gute Gruppe war das,
muss man echt sagen.
Ich meine, man darf, guckt,
der Kern der Gruppe,
also hier,
Shani, der Paxzerga, Friki,
Zogsorg und ich,
wir sind im Prinzip
seit heute Mittag
um
Chat, wann haben wir angefangen?
Nach Trollheim irgendwann.
14 Uhr oder so?
13.30?
Oh.
Es schreckt mich nicht so.
Ich denke, ich wundere, was hier für
Gegner sind.
Am Ende ist ein einzelner Scout.
Wir sind grob zusammen.
Das hast du selten.
Und man muss auch sagen, die wussten alle, wie man spielt.
Also PvP.
technisch in den unteren bgs war richtig richtig gut im mollweg hat dann halt ein
bisschen gesagt aber letztendlich hat es nichts machen kann ich alles immer wie
am schnurchen laufen
mit baum brauchen wir gar nicht
Es sind noch mehr von den Viechern.
Ups, falscher Knopf.
Falscher Knopf.
Sollts wieder umdrehen, da müssten die eigentlich respawns sein.
Hier sind nur Bäume.
Richtig spät ja.
Eigentlich würde ich jetzt pennen gehen.
aber ich mache die quest noch mit fertig kann es kann es auch nicht einfach hier
mittendrin sagen ja zu leute an das stehen die hier ohne speed da immerhin immerhin heiler speed
gibt's noch
haben wir es?
ja die sind die haben wir
so
jetzt noch ein paar Freibugs killen
So und was ist das hier hinten?
Sind hier die Brauntrachen in der Ecke?
sein dachte eigentlich ein bisschen weiter unten aber vielleicht auch nicht
ja das müssen die braunen drachen seien hier
ja doch das sind die braunen die trade links müssen wir killen
track links müssen wir kennen habe ich gestern erst gemacht mit meiner einer
sind nicht die cliff crawler sind die track links sind nicht die spinnen keine sport am end killen
Warum killen wir die Spinnen?
Die Spinnen, wir haben gar keine Quest für die Spinnen.
Die sind schon alle kaputt im Kopf, Mann.
Hier, wir brauchen die Brauntrachen.
Die kleinen Brauntrachen müssen wir killen.
Die Träglings.
benutzt du eigentlich Komoot oder so?
Ja.
Zum Planen der Rauts
benutze ich Komoot.
Und ich habe auch vorne oftmals
mein Handy drauf. Ich habe so eine
Abdeckkappe
für den Lenker.
Also da wo...
Wie nennt man das? Ich weiß nicht wie das...
Stem heißt das auf Englisch. Ich weiß nicht wie das auf Deutsch heißt.
also da wo man den Lenker dran macht
an diesem Rohr
da ist oben so eine Kappe drauf
und da habe ich so eine extra neue Kappe
mit einem Gewinde
wo man quasi mit einer extra Handyhülle
das ist passende Gegenstück hat
In der Vorbau ist das ganze Ding
Ja, da kann ich
Mein Handy drauf klipsen und das Komod gucken
Weil eins muss ich sagen
So sehr ich mein Garmin Fahrradcomputer mag
Für
Stats zum Anzeigen
Und Steigung von einem
von einem Berg und sowas
und wie viel Watt man gerade tritt
und welcher Gang und welche Übersetzung
und wie viel Zeit vergangen, wie viel Kilometer
und sowas
für Karten
und Navigation ist mir mein Handy
mit einer ordentlichen Navigations-App
und
schöner, schöne, große Farbe
lieber, ja, als dieses
1 FPS, dieser 1 FPS
Garmin Navigator
Deswegen habe ich oftmals Garmin vorne dran und
Und das Handy drauf
So, ich glaube wir haben es Leute
Ich glaube wir haben es, ich glaube wir sind fertig
Wir sind fertig
Hoffentlich will er jetzt nicht noch Snowdonia oder sowas machen
Dann
Breche ich ab
Wir sind ja sogar schon 40.
Wir sind ja sogar schon 41 mit den Quests wahrscheinlich.
Oh nein, der geht nach Sordonia.
Oh, da ist ein Gegner.
Der platzt einfach jetzt nur.
Killed by Pox, so muss das sein.
Da vorne ist noch was, oder?
I lost you guys. Einfach Map aufmachen und gucken.
Wann Battlefield 3, wenn die die Rush-Server gefixt haben.
Rush ist kaputt in Battlefield 3
Ich hätte richtig Spock, mal wieder ein paar gute Runden
Battlefield 3 Rush
Aber die haben es ja wohl irgendwie nicht
Gebacken bekommen und die
Rush-Server crashen irgendwie jede
Runde oder jeden Map-Change und so ganz schlimm
Voll für den Arsch
Okay, der ist hart drauf
Der will wirklich jetzt noch nach Snowdonia, gell
Oder?
Oh, please
No
Shani hat kein Erbarmen mit uns.
Jetzt müssen wir noch
Sonoronia machen.
Hast du die Battlefield 6
Konflikte? Ich habe auch die Leaks gesehen, ja.
Aber ich lasse mich nicht mehr hypen auf dem Game.
Ich habe mich auf 2042
hypen lassen und da kam dieser Schrott bei raus.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
ich finde das sieht deutlich besser aus als das was ich von 22 42 kenne gerade dass das
bisschen er den den klassischen battlefield look und und viel wieder hat aber ich freue
mich da nicht mehr drauf ich warte erst bis was rauskommt naja jetzt kommt übrigens die
map wo die designer keine lust mehr hatten wie man hier sieht die haben sich einfach gedacht
kommt drauf copy paste mir einfach den gleichen berg fünfmal hin und fertig
würde zu sellout dafür machen auch wenn das scheiße ist ja würde ich machen
also mal angenommen das sind ähnliche konditionen wie so 20 42 weil die haben
das hat dick stonks gebracht ich habe mich da ein bisschen geärgert
dass ich noch ein Battlefield 2042
Video machen musste, obwohl mich
das Spiel so abgefuckt hat.
Aber letztendlich war das
echt gut Kohle.
Die haben sich da nicht lumpen lassen. Die wussten
wahrscheinlich schon warum.
Die haben sich schon gedacht,
wir kaufen gleich mal
drei Videos, weil nach dem ersten wird er
keinen Bock mehr haben.
Also lassen wir den gleich mal für drei Videos
unterschreiben. Da kann er sich
nicht mehr wehren.
Guter Plan, oder?
Taktische Marketingfüchse bei EA.
Marketingfüchse, das hört sich an wie was, was der Held der Steine sagen würde.
Gibt es hier eine Wüsten-Map?
Eventuell gibt es einfach gute Maps.
So zur Abwechslung.
Ja, Nala, du kriegst
Protect.
Charmys brauchen kein
Protect. Das ist overrated, outdated,
she baited.
Okay, drei Lizards noch.
Und dann müssen wir da runter.
Da wird er uns auch noch hinschleppen.
Ich sag's euch.
Ich glaub da...
Okay, wir haben's.
ich müsste eigentlich mal trainieren
1, 2, 3, 4
jawoll train
gab es jetzt noch irgendwas wichtiges
lass mich gerade mal gucken
gibt den letzten Wasser
Buff
schielt haben wir das ist hier eigentlich passt
wir haben es gleich leute ist gleich geschafft
die letzte quest
monka quest
was brauchen wir denn dann dann
dann dann dann 20 forest etten sieg aus ok let's go
Ich cast nochmal einen Wasserbuff, falls sich irgendjemand weggeklickt hat.
So.
Letzte Quest.
Please.
Lass es die letzte Quest sein.
Was sagst du zum Gildennamen vom Gruppenlied?
Sieht mir zu Elite aus
Ich finde die Idee gut
Aber
An sich finde ich es dann
Weiß nicht, strahlt mir das zu viel
Pro-Gamer-Elite aus.
Vielleicht ist das aber auch die Absicht.
Und dann ist es wieder genau richtig.
Was ist der Name vom Lied?
Der Gildenname ist...
BigPVP-Niss.
Lull, er hat Penis gesagt.
Keck Wait.
5 bobs noch gleich ist geschafft wir können uns direkt hier vorne weit und zurück zurück porten
also wenn das der plan ist dann hat schon die die die high iq route schlechthin gelaufen
Wenn wir genau jetzt hier rauskommen, bei der letzten Quest, wo wir uns walpen.
Ja Patrick, ich habe auch ein bisschen gebraucht.
Ich habe auch erst am Anfang gedacht, hä, was soll das sein, was soll das sein, bis
ich dann irgendwann mal ausgesprochen habe und ich habe mir gedacht, ah ok, jetzt habe
ich es verstanden.
Aber das ist mir zu Elite.
Wir haben es, wir haben es, wir sind durch!
Nein, nein, falsche Richtung!
Nein!
Wir gehen wieder weg!
Wir machen noch mehr Quests!
Was will er denn jetzt noch machen?
Penny Mountains ist nichts mehr?
Sauvage?
Vielleicht?
Äh, wo ist es denn?
Krone, ähm
Sauwatsch?
Nein, wir machen Sauwatsch noch
Ah
Wahrscheinlich
Also richtig nice group
Man hat auch gespürt die leute also gerade die die wir am anfang nur die bgs hatten die gruppe die wussten alle wie man spielt
Was hat er eigentlich der immer reingehören ist gestorben ist aber ansonsten
war das echt gut
Ja zum glück habe ich montags frei sonst wäre ich jetzt schon auf
schade hat es auch wirklich sehr gut geliedet alles manchmal musste die leute ein bisschen
anpacken dass es vorwärts geht geht nicht anders gerade wenn man heiler spielt ich meine du bist
für alles zuständig guck mal der muss heilen der muster der muss heilen da muss dafür sorgen dass
dass die Gegner nichts machen können.
Der muss gucken, wo wir langlaufen,
welche Route wir gehen.
Das ist halt...
Und wenn dann die Tanks noch rumnoopen,
dann...
geht's dir auf den Sack.
Ach, bist du im Stream?
Nice.
Ja, echt gut.
ok letzte quest ja warum höre ich mich so an wie könnt warum warum höre ich mich schalke
fragt gerade im im game chat warum ich mich wie wie der max fps von youtube
an ich weiß auch nicht war mal eine sehr ähnliche stimme
Wir haben eine sehr ähnliche Stimme
Wir haben auch zufälligerweise den gleichen Avatar
Auf Twitch und auf YouTube
Ja
Ja siehst du
Die Welt ist klein
easy jetzt erzählt mir mal nicht dass mit got easy mode ist also gerade hier auf ihnen würde
ich sagen jede gute alp kastakrupp und jede gut eingespielte mit ja wie nennt man das hip hybrid
Mitgrub frühstückt hier die Durchschnitts-Mitgruppe ab.
Also wenn ihr, genau, wenn ihr was Easy Mode isst, dann ist das hip.
Allgemein muss ich mal zeigen, wie das diese Season ist.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass mit schlecht wäre, ja.
Also es ist was...
Gute Mitgruppen können auch was killen, aber ich hab den Eindruck,
es braucht bei mit so paar Prozent mehr Anstrengung.
als gerade bei Hip.
Dafür habe ich den Eindruck,
dass in Hip mit Abstand die meisten Noobs rumrennen.
Du hast in Hip, finde ich,
mit die besten Gruppen und teilweise auch mit die besten Spieler,
aber du hast extrem
viele Kack-Noobs, die rumrennen.
Wo du teilweise denkst, ey,
wo läuft der denn jetzt hin?
Hip ist,
das liegt wahrscheinlich daran,
weil viele einfach mal Pilz sticken und halt komplett...
Ink, ink, ink von hinten.
Fuck.
Jetzt haben sie uns weggerubbelt.
Okay, das sind aber 50er.
Und die haben uns schön von der Seite erwischt.
Macht nix, wir gehen nicht noch mal her.
Please, please.
vorbei jetzt. Vorbei, ja?
Es reicht genug jetzt. Jetzt können wir uns sparen.
Das letzte Quest.
Ja, okay.
Hätten wir die gut engaged, hätten wir das
durchaus schaffen können, aber gerade bei den Mobs von hinten
und sowas willst du machen.
So.
So, Quest.
Finish. Ups.
Guck mal.
Sehr gut.
41,5.
Jawoll.
Wir sind 42, Leute.
Guck mal, fast 43.
Mega nice.
Ich geh jetzt ausloggen.
Mir reicht's für heute.
Uff.
Ist das mit Thor, Max?
Nein.
Das ist auch nicht mit Thor.
Also ja, es ist mit Thor
Stats. Das stimmt.
Aber ohne so Sachen wie beispielsweise diese Aerez und sowas.
Gibt es nicht.
Ja, ja, Cap Increase, das gibt es alles.
Ja, das stimmt, da hast du recht.
Ja, okay, Thorastets, aber keine Artefakte.
Genauso wie du sagst.
Ja, du hast recht.
So.
ausgetrunken
und jetzt, Leute,
geh ich pennen.
Übelst kaputt.
Der Frasier!
Wait a minute.
Das ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen.
Nee.
Wie Fabian, hast du auch Bock zu spielen?
Ich dachte, es ist so ein bisschen random, ja
Hab ich grad schon gedacht
Ja, Fabian, wie sieht's aus?
Mit dir würde ich sogar auf Hip spielen
Ich spiel Bade, du spielst Menta oder sowas
Oder wir spielen Alp, keine Ahnung
Ich spiel freiwillig Sorg, du kannst Clary spielen
Oder du machst hier einen Mid-Char.
Da können wir endlich
im besten Realm spielen.
Monster Hunter, okay.
Na dann nicht.
Besser Begehli da auf Mid.
Wer macht denn das aktuell?
Ich habe die, ich habe so die letzten, ich habe Season 2 nur so bis zur Hälfte gespielt oder so, sagen wir mal zu zwei Dritteln gespielt.
Da war es noch hauptsächlich der Grieche.
Der ist aber jetzt in Alb.
Wer ist das denn in?
Ach du, okay, ja nice. Dann sehen wir uns demnächst in BG.
Gibt es eigentlich
Neverlater, hast du eigentlich mal wieder
Irgendwelche
Dark Songs gemacht
Der hat richtig
Nice Dark Musik
Da muss ich euch mal vorspielen, wartet mal
So zum Schlafen gehen
Ah fuck, ich habe zu viele Fenster auf
Wo habe ich denn jetzt die Musik hier
Ja wartet mal.
Ähm.
Enter Name oder?
War das Enter Name?
Äh.
Dark Polemo.
Right Left.
Äh.
Song?
Ja.
Ah, warte mal, warte mal.
Wo ist denn der andere?
Ist das?
Play all night mit Pils, genau.
Ich habe das mal eine Zeit lang in der Schleife laufen gehabt, während ich gespielt habe.
Da hat der Mendefekt einfach aus der BG, aus dem Discord,
ein paar Sachen rausgeschnitten von den jeweiligen BG-Liedern
und hat so einen Song draus gemacht.
Finde ich mega nice.
Ich hoffe, da gibt es diese Season auch wieder welche.
Also normale Tabs, normale Durchschnitt-Tabs-Anzahl.
Damn, Hibis ist ja der Klassiker schlechthin.
Okay, aber Leute, ich geh jetzt wirklich
pennen. Das reicht mir. Ich hab keinen Bock mehr.
Wir sehen uns morgen.
Morgen dann
brauchen wir die
Epic für den Heiler, eventuell die Epic für den
Skalde. Den Skalde Richtung
50 mit
TGSH und hast du nicht gesehen?
Und wenn sonst
nichts geht, leveln wir den Charmy
ein bisschen. Oder
wir leveln schon mal den Clary.
Oder die Hexe. Mal gucken.
Aber ich glaube, ich mache erstmal alles
auf Mid auf 50.
Auf Hip habe ich gar keinen Bock.
Den Bade level ich dann
irgendwann mal wieder, wenn ich sonst nichts zu tun habe.
Morgen Abend
RVR BG.
Ich könnte
RVR, ich könnte BG RVR
streamen eigentlich.
Da müssen wir aber gucken.
Was meinst du, was für ein Delay gut ist
für BG RVR?
Ich will es nicht zu lange haben.
Meinst du, 30 Sekunden Delay reicht?
Weil so ganz ohne Delay ist halt auch kacke.
Da können die schon gleich im Stream gucken, gleich kommt eine Crew von hinten oder so.
Das ist viel zu wenig.
Quatsch, 10 Minuten brauchst du im Leben nicht.
10 Minuten.
Die meisten Leute sind so brain AFK.
denen kannst du sagen, Achtung, Feinde von hinten und sie checken es nicht.
Zwei Minuten?
Fabian, weißt du, was ich mich schon die ganze Zeit in MMOs frage?
Vielleicht hast du ja eine Antwort drauf, weil du kennst diese Spieler auch.
Es gibt immer wieder Leute, du läufst einfach nur mit Speed geradeaus
und du weißt genau,
dieser eine Typ, weil er es schon ein paar Mal hat,
der hat gleich Stickloss
und du weißt nicht, warum.
Man versteht es einfach nicht.
Die Leute laufen einfach nur,
die Gruppe läuft einfach nur mit Speed
geradeaus und auf einmal hat er
Stickloss und es ist laufend.
Wie geht denn das?
Ich verstehe nicht, wie das geht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich meine,
das kann ein 80-Jähriger mit einem
Auge, wo nur noch eine Hand funktioniert,
kann sticken und Sprint drücken.
Das sind immer die gleichen,
ich versteh's nicht, keine Ahnung,
läuft geradeaus, zack, zick, los.
Dass man eigentlich, wenn man's gescheit
macht, gar nicht unbedingt alle auf dem Haufen
stickt, mal wieder da, aber ich weiß nicht.
Ja, also
das ist schlimm, aber du kennst die.
Ja, vielleicht laufen die von Hand und
checken's dann nicht oder so.
Kann auch sein. Kein Schimmer.
Aber Fabian, wenn's dir mal nach...
Die Leute haben gesagt, wir sollen mal
irgendwelche Koop-Spiele wieder spielen.
Aber da gibt's ja... Du hast ja auch wenig Bock
gerade auf irgendwas. Außer ich fang mit
Monster Hunter an wahrscheinlich. Aber Monster Hunter
ist ja nicht so meins.
Aber Leute, ich geh jetzt echt
pennen. Neuneinhalb Stunden.
Ich hab ja davor noch eine halbe Stunde gestreamt.
Da hab ich den Stream neu gestartet.
Also, wir sehen uns morgen.
Vielleicht morgen Abend. Runde
BG-RVR, muss ich mal gucken.
Also, mit Heiler
ist mir das im Stream eigentlich viel zu anstrengend
und Skull ist bis morgen nicht 50.
Heiler kriege ich Zustände, wenn ich mit euch labern muss,
Dark erklären muss, plus
Treespec-Heiler in der BG.
Gut, in der BG ist im Prinzip noch
einfacher. In der BG stelle ich mich in die Ecke,
spamme Group-Heals.
In der BG ist Heiler jetzt nicht so wild.
Ja, mal gucken. Schauen wir mal.
Bis morgen, Leute. Ich geh jetzt pennen.
CU. Schön, dass ihr so lange dabei gewesen seid.
Macht's gut. Tschüss.
Ach, und Fabian, bis noch da.
Ciao.
CU.